the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club it's frightening just how good the
play is at the US Women's and US Open
championships in St Louis freaky results
abounded as players press the day before
the second rest day Bano caruana almost
slipped in a scary back and forth game
that had him running for a draw to
retain clear lead after slashing their
way through the the majority of the
field two absolute Killers remain tied
at the top of the women's standings with
each racking up another win in a field
this deadly you'll need a crystal ball
to predict who survives day nine of
thrilling chess coming up
[Music]
[Applause]
next
[Music]
welcome back chess fans to day nine of
the US chess championships and US
Women's chess Championships held at the
same L chess club we started the in
front of the kingside diner staple here
in the Central West End if you come in
during any time of the day you will
surely find a Grandmaster having their
lunch their breakfast or their dinners
here it's been a fantastic event so far
let's go to the studio and start the
action welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club proudly presents the US and US
Women's chess championships some players
are running out of chances as round nine
begins
now
hello and welcome everyone thank you for
joining us I'm kerina NSA and I'm here
with yaser Sahan and Christian Killa
Kate how did you like your free day it
was a wonderful day to recharge and meet
with some of the players yeah that was
nice for sure hello everyone and Welcome
to our live coverage of the 2023
national championships we are ready on
set for a fantastic finish the players
are rested they're going to BR give it
their best as we got three rounds to go
do the honors Kate tell us the standings
after eight rounds of really
Championship chess let's start with the
ladies let's take a look so in the
ladies section we have two leaders Karis
and beckim to janova having a fantastic
tournament and running away with two
extra points against everybody else in
the field what a performance what a
seven out of eight fantastic and then we
have a two-way tie for the third place
arena crush and Alis Lee with Five
Points and in the open section we
standings here we have a so leader
Fabiano Karana leading with one extra
point 5 and half out of eight but there
is a bunch of players right behind him
Wesley s Lenard Dominguez Hans nean and
abanu Mishra with four and health points
that's a trailing pack of wolves to be
sure and tell us about our format for
these two national championships we play
two 12 player round Robins which means
each player plays every everybody else
in their respective section the time
control is 90 minutes for first 40 moves
followed by 30 minutes for rest of the
game and there is a 30second increment
from move one players are not allowed to
offer draw they're not allowed to just
make a draw um just by agreeing to it
offering draw absolutely traditional
scoring system one point for win half a
point for a draw and zero points for
loss just remind me what the situation
would be in case of a TI first
absolutely if two players die for first
there is a two game rapid match with 10
minutes and 2 second increment if
players are still tight there is
Armageddon and Armageddon means white
gets 5 minutes black gets four four
minutes and black gets the draw OD
wonderful and tell us about our
remaining
schedule today we have round nine and
there two more rounds to go we always
start at 1:20 p.m. Center time and if
necessary we will have playoffs on
Wednesday October 18th wonderful
Christian we're going to be crowning
champions in 3 days but good who are our
Champions going to be well absolutely
it's a race to the finish line right now
as we enter the championship rounds the
players and us as well we had the rest
day but now it's go time so let's take a
look at who our leaders are as we enter
these last three Championship rounds
we're going to start with the Ladi
section I have to say take a look at
this this is absolutely historical put
it in the history books Karissa and
begim toova identical line score mirror
image of each other as you can see they
started off with a draw in round number
one after that a couple of Victories and
that draw against each other in round
four and they've been on a tear since
just an amazing performance for both of
these ladies I would say the performance
of a lifetime for two players in the
national champion ships but let's see
who uh karissa's road ahead is entering
the last three as we can see nazzi Pisa
the two time US Women's chess champion
she's been having a difficult tournament
so far only three points and definitely
Karissa with the white pieces today she
will be looking to continue her streak
but I have to say this one is not going
to be easy round 10 with the black
pieces and I have to say that's the key
matchup with the black pieces against
the five lifetime if I'm not mistaken uh
National Champion Anna zatonski just an
incredible lady she's not having an
amazing event so far but she can
surprise everybody at any time and in
round 11 to cap it all off for Karissa
well she will be facing ruang Yan the
Wild Card going into this event but
she's have she's been having a pretty
decent event up to this point four
points and how about her co-leader that
is beim toir Jova as you can see woman
GR Master beim toova Seven Points out of
eight that's just an incredible score I
have to say today with the white pieces
against ruang Yan in round 10 I have to
say that's the critical matchup for beim
as well against the atime national
champion Irena crush and she's been
having difficulties against that
particular opponent she has been
eliminated in The American Cup twice in
a row by Arena Crush so definitely that
one is going to be a difficult game for
for beg him round 11 against the
defending Champion that will not be
defending her title in this year's
competition Jennifer U but we've seen
her at play and we've seen what she can
do Jennifer can definitely play remember
what happened uh not yesterday but the
day before yesterday against Irena Crush
she had a difficult position managed to
turn it around and almost successfully
defeated Irena Crush so that one is not
going to be easy either but what's
happening in the open section in the l
section it's a two horse race right now
but in the open section take a look at
that we do have the sole leader Fabiano
Carana one point ahead of the pack but
look at that pack Wesley so Lenard
Dominguez Hans Neiman and The Sensation
of this event the young sensation of
this event ABI Manu Mishra just an
incredible tournament for young ABI Manu
only 14 years of age that is absolutely
ridiculous exactly come and let's take a
look at the road ahead for Fabiano our
leader going into the last three rounds
this is the big one the big Clash that
we were anticipating a few rounds ago
round nine with the black pieces he will
be defending against Hans Neiman round
10 against ABI Manu Mishra with the
white pieces definitely an opportunity
there there's a big rating gap between
these two players but it doesn't really
matter at this competition because ABI
Manu is surprising absolutely everybody
and round 11 with the black piece
against the three-time national champion
that is The Clash of Champions against
Wesley so I have to say a lot of
fighting and exciting chess coming your
way but really big challenges for Fabby
it's not going to be an easier road
ahead for him and Kate do the honors uh
here we are in round nine tell us H tell
our audience what they can expect for
the parents let's start with the ladies
let's take a look we have you playing
esan then a very important match for the
standings players who tie for third
right now Lee playing crush and then the
co- leader toir janova playing Yen then
abrahamian playing zatonski then another
coer real force in this tournament Yip
playing pit and for me that's really the
Marquee matchup right there because you
know whenever you're playing against
those national champions they can upset
you absolutely and then cantz playing
kashian and the pairings for round nine
in the open in the open section all eyes
will be glued to dis match h man against
Fabiano caruana really really important
match then we have saw playing Robson
which is another important match in this
round absolutely absolutely is Ray Ray
is a 50% but he's crawled his way back
into the tournament yes then we have
Dominguez playing tank which I see also
as an opportunity for lanir to make his
move try to catch up to Fabiano exactly
then sh playing Jong savian playing
aronian and shankland playing Mishra
another Marquee matchup as well the
players have been fighting incredibly
hard as we see uh well the big Clash uh
Hans nean with the white be says favano
with the black cleaning the board always
NE taking away all the fluff in the dust
but they have been fighting very hard
Kate what are they fighting for they're
fighting for a really nice price Fund in
the women's section we have
$152,000 as the price fund with first
place winning 40,000 second place 30,000
and third Place 20,000 all the way to
the 12th Place $4,000 nice and in the
open section what is the price F there
here it's
$250,000 with first place winning 60,000
second place 45,000 third place 35,000
and again all the way to 12th Place
$6,000 and we are underway for round
nine as E4 E5 uh essayed by Fabby Knight
F3 Knight C6 it's all about the joke
piano and the berlins yes uh what's your
prediction coach my prediction is we're
going to see Bishop to B5 let's wait and
see because I know Fabiano has played
Bishop to C4 exclusively in fact this
tournament um three times if I'm not
mistaken so Hans probably has looked at
that understood that
okay com as I was doing my monologue
that he's not going to play Bishop to C4
it was brilliant no seriously I thought
you were doing a great job right into
the right until the moment he played
Bishop C4 you had me convinced yeah well
we're going to see the jooan I guess but
you know what's funny about this matchup
they've met in classical chess I believe
three times okay in every single one of
them Fabiano is with the black pieces
and Fabiano has a 3oh score has won all
of his games in B Bundesliga last year
uh then at the singfield cup and then at
the national championships right and he
won all of them with the black p this is
so definitely a difficult opponent for
Hans but at any point you know in his
young career up to this point these
things can change very quickly this type
of Dynamics between players can change
very quickly and this score can kind of
feed his revenge right corre in this
tournament nice and we have Bishop C5 I
mean there are lots of opportunities
here for uh mixing things up D7 D6 as
played today in the guitar Masters uh uh
White was Magnus Carlson his opponent
played H6 followed by D6 followed by G6
nope Fabe today h stays with the main
line and I saw a little Shake of the
head there by did he mix up lines
already no no no no like like I think
he's just kind of like reprimanding
himself like sometimes you prepare for
your opponent right and you're expecting
your opponent to play maybe he was
thinking Bishop E7 or something and then
you say nah he won't play that he'll
deviate and maybe uh
just a little head shap C2 C3 and we'll
keep an eye on this all important
matchup just wanted to say that again
for me lanir Dominguez has had a quiet
quiet Road getting here he's plus one
he's in that trailing pack of players
but he's up against Andrew Tang the
lowest rated player in the field he has
the white pieces and lanir could be
saying okay let me
make my move uh D6 Knight F6 Knight C3
and instead of proposing a perk defense
G7 G6 in this case we have a E7 E5 a
filor um I've never as black I've never
been afraid of this ending I don't know
if uh you feel similarly Queen takes
King takes Bishop C4 Bishop E6 I've seen
lots and lots and lots of games and
black has basically acquitted himself
well uh so I don't see the ending as a
threat but why isn't this more popular
at the highest levels coach well
generally not taking on E5 yes uh the
ending is generally quite good for black
because you have this C6 idea to control
uh D5 the king then goes to C7 it
doesn't really matter that I lost my
ability to Castle that King is going to
be safe on C7 and what I mean is this uh
end game take take excuse me it seems
like my you can do it I'm not sure
actually it's this might be some
connectivity issues that we have uh
Bishop to E3 yeah we have some problems
with the internet just remember that
white moves first smart boards I wish
that was the problem something like
Bishop E3 and then C6 the king HIDs to
C7 and it's actually a very good Square
for no Knight B5 check no Knight D5
absolutely no problems and black is
supposed to be quite
safe Knight to F3 is the main line of
course keep the tension as is put some
pressure as soon as possible on Black's
pieces you have to defend the E5 Square
we're expecting Knight to D7 again we
have exact issues with that but Knight
to D7 would be the move and what I'm
expecting is Bishop to C4 Bishop to C4
put pressure on F7 sometimes if you're
not paying attention you might fall uh
into some traps for example Bishop to C4
right Bishop to E7 and we have ideas of
Bishop takes F7 in this that that
sacrifice I studed intely as a a team
take you have to hide on G8 otherwise um
you are in trouble on E8 after Knight D6
the queen is strapped on f8 after Knight
D6 uh that's a double attack so you have
to go all the way to G8 Knight E6 Queen
to E8 it's a funny light I was always
surprised that it's not very good for
white it's not that bad for black
exactly yes yes and if we look at uh the
engine yes the engine is saying that
black is doing more or less okay so even
that Bishop to E7 move works for black
at the same time you have to know
exactly uh what you're doing and by the
way if I remember correctly after Bishop
to E7 there was a funny move G4 yes G4
in this position very interesting very
enterprising but the question is will
ler actually be looking for those type
of positions or is he looking to just
keep a long-term Advantage slight
long-term Advantage take advantage of
the fact that Andrew Tang is taking some
risks with this opening choice and by
the way Bishop B7 is on the board
inviting Bishop takes F7
no I know those tactics you know it's
funny but seriously it's not a joke I
think every Grand Master I I know has
literally studied the sacrifice and I as
a kid just I reveled in this position
because I just thought it was so
extraordinarily compelling and anything
that you know just fascinated me in the
chess and and kept my interest I was all
gung-ho about because I was looking at
these again very forcing uh variations
you you won an exchange in what the rook
in the corner uh Rook to A8 Rook Rook to
F1 because the Rook is under attack and
then my analysis again and I'm talking
about as a as a teen would go takes
takes and I would go like Knight F uh
kn5 right so I'm
looking yeah and the idea was twofold to
play Bishop
H3 and as well as Knight F3 and I would
go F2 F4 and I would literally play game
with myself from the starting position
and I I just loved it I just thought
this was just so exciting on with pieces
thinking like oh really nice sacrifice
I'm getting that rook and then I lost
and I was like how did that happen I
very very very upsetting and again
another huge Marquee matchup and look at
this it started the same way as a Joko
piano uh wesle so versus Ray Robson two
roommates together in the day at Webster
and instead of Hans neeman's C2 C3 more
or less the main line uh uh Wesley
trying a little little bit of a Twist
not the triple twist but a little bit of
the twist twist with Knight C3
eyeballing the D5 square and where would
you like to take us Kate let's look at
the women's section and the leader Curry
say because I'm very surprised in that
game Curry say against Nazi PID nazzi is
playing the karukan again okay after a
not very successful game with it last
time she's trusting that opening again
uh hopefully this time she she she made
some very important uh uh improvements
and I believe we have the exact same
position she played against beim toova
yeah in that game uh beum actually was
allowed to play A5 A6 also including uh
C2 C4 and it was a terrible game for
Nasi now these positions are supposed to
be double edged and if I remember
correctly like nany put her Bishop she
moved her Bishop
and somehow those were those ended up
being loss of
tempies uh for black queen to C7 was
also misplaced the way she played it
because after Rook C1 Bishop D2 Rook C1
C4 ideas you had some problems on the SE
file as well so exactly a lot of things
went wrong for Nazi in that game I'm
sure she did her homework and I'm sure
she improved uh her stance and her
understanding of this particular
position because right now now she's
blitzing out her moves exactly uh I'm
much more familiar with the ideas of
playing F7 F6 to CH chip away this uh
Center uh pondue in the middle of the
board you play F6 you recapture with the
bishop you aspire to play E5 and if you
can get rid of white center then it's
quite okay and then when black Castle is
on the king side and The Rook has open
F5 and everything works for black
suddenly exactly so we'll we'll keep an
eye on the chissa Yip game I want to go
uh also to Bam where are you bam she is
up against our Wild Card Player uh and
you know I must say the organizers
really try their best they they they
want to uh create a field of the best
players in the United States but they
also have a right to invite you know uh
a wild card player and sometimes when
you invite a wild card player they just
it's a disaster and people say well why
didn't you invite the other person why
so you know Wild Card players are you
know like the kind of
danger ruen 50 and we can remember the
wild card for the US senior Championship
melik Kian who end up winning that
tournament exactly and I remember wild
card player in the Len tournament that
was Joba who like almost lost every
single game it was like a
disaster uh going on here well let's see
uh first of all let's take it from the
very top uh beum with a white pizza she
goes she decides to go for the early
kingside fianchetto uh one of the nice
things about this setup is if you do
transpose into a Catalan you kind of
avoid Bishop B4 check ideas and the open
Catalan uh with the white king already
on the queen side so it's a foxy way of
playing the openings also you can go D2
D3 followed by E2 E4 going into a kind
of King's Indian attack and finally you
can transpose into a kind of uh uh
English ready with C2 C4 okay C4 D4 now
that is a surprise move for me with the
inclusion of Bishop on E7 and uh the
pawn on E6 the move
d4 is maybe too ambitious this is like
overdoing it if you will and beum says
Okay the reason you're not supposed to
if white does nothing if white plays you
know quietly then you know black can um
transpose into a kind of a Boni where
the pawn on D4 is well protected but the
move but the move B2
B4 it's really nice it looks like it's
offering a pawn but be careful taking
that pawn if you take that pawn check to
the king hits the Bishop you have only
one move Knight C6 Knight E5 followed by
Knight E5 more pressure on that Knight
and suddenly that Bishop on
D7 uh is an a bishop on G2 pardon me is
an
ambush uh to the Knight so you can't
take the pawn but from White's
perspective white is ready to play
Bishop B2 and take this Pawn now this is
all Theory and it's been played quite a
number of times but I've always liked
the white side
of uh this variation B let's just let me
just refresh the board to see what ruen
did against and she's she's uh waiting
and in fact uh Christian if you don't
mind I just uh bring up this game
between beum yes and got it R Yang for
Castle is is is by far uh the main move
in the position castle and C5 and in
fact not that surprisingly so I have to
say because I feel like I've seen this
position maybe from but it's with the
pawn on G6 usually yes yes I think it's
something along these lines for example
if you start G3 G6 let's say D5 Castle
Bishop G7 uh something like this I see
this very often not so much with a
bishop on E7 and as we can see uh this
has only been played 17 times 13 times
excuse me at least in the that base all
of them well 10 of them out of 13 with
Castle um Bishop to B2 want to trade my
flank Pawn for your Center pawn and my
guess is that right now black has to for
the moment sacrifice the pawn with the
move C5 so what you want is get this
position with the Knight on C6 but you
have to put that Knight behind the pawn
on C5 don't go Knight to C6 first
because then you're going to be PR to
all sorts of attacks with B5 get the the
pawn from D4 win that and win the game
so C5 has to be played first and then
Knight to C6 in this type of instance um
generally B Tak C5 is not played by the
way in general you want to keep the
tension as is and in fact D3 to get
ready for E3 and try to put pressure on
the pawn on D4 it's a I used to play the
Boni you know I'm a bon player these are
the type of Bon structures that we see
very often but I still don't like them
with the white pieces I guess uh there's
a differentiation there between you and
me because you played a lot of English
right so maybe you had some instances
where you were seeing this type of
structures I haven't seen them that much
I don't like them with the white pieces
too much if I can ask you st
statistically speaking yes how does
white Fair uh percentage wise quite well
uh quite well D3 um 60% of the games
have been won uh by white 60% that's
huge that's that's big especially
because 30% of them have been a draw and
only 10% have been won by black so
definitely percentage wise white is
having the easier play it seems like
Kate break the tie I like white he
Christian I have to go with Christian I
like black because I'm getting more
space with black pieces and I like that
can we Shuffle the cards well you know
and maybe I will retract that at some
point because I'm making parallels with
the positions that I know quite well
with the pawn on G6 the bishop Pawn G7
those are the ones that I generally
don't like and now I'm seeing with the
pawn on E6 I don't like it visually but
I'm sure there's details that I'm not
necessarily aware of I will get aware of
what the details are in just a few
minutes but before I can do that I just
make the parallels with that pawn on G6
Bishop PA G7 which I like for black
exactly if you could take the move
Bishop B Bishop B2 back for a second
quick question for you Castle's A2 A3 A3
A3 C7 C5 has been played C7 C5 E2 E3 Now
isn't White playing a bloomenfeld Gambit
with an extra Tempo in hand s of sort of
yes yes yes um and I'm not sure I take
take it's a bloomenfeld Gambit but I
already finished my development as black
on this side right um maybe I don't even
have to take but let's say I the bullet
and take the pawn D4 and or do I take is
the question let's continue taking and
now you play D4 right and I always
thought that these were very dangerous
uh positions to take the gam upon even
when they're you're white and black I'm
actually doing it with an extra Tempo so
I was just I wanted to ask you
statistically oops I don't see you
hasn't been played no not so often no at
all after e o my goodness I'm having
huge problems with my board today but uh
after B4 Let's uh take a look once again
so you hit your accelerator A3 E3 with
the power of my mind right you see what
I'm doing here with the power of my mind
is how I switch Mind Over Matter
Christian you're just impressive E2 E3
E3 hasn't been played has not no Bishop
to B2 was played only once almost
exclusively it's one of those positions
that we feel we've seen before right but
in h in fact we haven't it's a different
position dude I think your database is
missing some games because this looks so
common I I know I know there's a lot of
issues we're having with database with
the platform right now so maybe that's
the case but right now my database is
saying no nothing uh Kate I mean a lot
of uh the grand Masters they're they
take pride in their databases that they
have like a million games five million
games how about you did you ever go for
quantity massive quantity no I was
really happy when I think I was about 12
or 13 years old when I got computer to
actually have database and go through
the games so that was great but uh I'm
not the one who is keeping up so well
with uh databases the database okay
we'll keep an eye on Bam's game Alice
Lee our birthday girl from a few days
ago she is up against Arena Crush uh who
as we all know eight-time US champion uh
Alice uh with the white pieces and
um it was eim bolab I'm going to butcher
is not his name he would play the system
as black we called it the BOGO Indian
when you've got a name like babo it
becomes the BOGO Indian Bishop B4 check
Bishop D2 Queen E7 and I must confess
there was a time that I played this
myself as black and I found it a very
easy uh neutralizing line now I play
this line as well with black pieces even
at the Olympia then I made a draw
exactly kind of equalizing kind of
trying exactly um I'm not I wasn't
trying to equalize it usually with the
move B7 B6 funnily enough I would play
moves like Bishop takes just for
argument sake Knight takes and then
after say castles now whether they put
the bishop on D3 or Bishop on E2 didn't
matter how was I solving this bishop I
wasn't playing the move D6 to give it a
diagonal I was actually D6 yes D6
exactly an E5 and I would develop the
bishop over what I consider it's more
natural diagonal nope that was not
Arena's approach she went for B7 B6
Bishop D3 castles Bishop takes D2 Knight
takes D2 castles and that it does give
Alice this chance to try to get a kind
of a moroy bind with the move E3 E4 uh
meaning that after takes Knight takes D4
it's not that easy for black to get in
the move D5 and as long as white can
maintain this Pawn in the
center there's a there's a space
Advantage it might be small but uh I
found it to be advantageous for white
and another big game uh these two ladies
who talk about rivalry right here right
tat for sure but okay once again the
Petro defense very hard to get anything
against it and I think it was actually
Boris Gan who said you know what let me
just Retreat my night how are you going
to get an advantage with for versus four
and three versus three well you know C4
you know they play for some space
Advantage but it's tiny Christian what's
caught your eye where's the action
where's the action bring show is the
action let's see what's happening in the
Hans the Marky matchup of the round in
the open section and Fabiano with the
black pieces right and we did see the
Italian and we did see this idea of A5
and this is all about the Italian you
can play it in so many ways we've been
uh this discussing all a length how
black can approach this position one of
them with A5 the other one is A6 you can
go D6 first and leave the pawn on A7
this one is more of a novel approach but
it does seem to equalize as well still
plenty of theory left in the position
castle and D6 inviting this move Bishop
to G5 uh black is saying Fabiano is
saying come on go Bishop G5 let's let's
go into this variation that we've seen
ler with the black pie essay against Sam
Sean so H says no I'm going to go Rook
to E1 Bishop to A7 come on Bishop G5
let's get something entertaining in the
position h no no no we're playing
classical uh just today Knight bd2 and
finally now that you covered this
diagonal I have time to go Castle now
Bishop to G5 is no longer possible in
the position not yet at least now we
have H3 and Bishop to E6 Bishop to B5
don't change on E6 that will give black
a perfect position Knight to E7 a D4
Knight to G6 and Bishop to A4 and the
players are still following uh something
that has been explored at length in this
position by the elite level players
Dominguez with white pieces against
Wesley so Knight to H5 in this position
seems to be the move proposed by the
theory by the engines as well with the
idea to directly get a knight to F4 and
put immedia pressure on um White's King
side especially now that we're not going
to exchange the light Square Bishops
anymore so I do have that resource I do
have that weapon in my Arsenal the
bishop on E6 ready to sacrifice it on H3
things of that nature probably I'm going
to put the queen behind uh this bishop
either there on D7 to settle for Bishop
takes H3 or even Queen to F6 at the
right moment these are these are the
type of strategies that we have in this
positions for for black as for white
white is just simply going to wait a
little bit by the way take a look at
this once again remind our viewers this
was a big matchup and we anticipated
this one a long time ago because Hans
was always uh closely behind Fabiano
right now with a victory with the white
pieces he could potentially catch
Fabiano so big opportunity big chance
for Hans he will definitely not go all
in because he don't want to go all in
you're still in the second position
you're not going to go fully all in but
you do want to put as much pressure on
your opponent as possible you need to
look to search for that elusive Victory
Murphy's Law over here Christian yes
whenever you explain something so
perfectly that nobody can misunderstand
there's one guy who guy hey man I get it
if I play Knight takes E5 of Knight take
C5 you'll take with the pawn going to
take on and you'll take on D4 and I
won't be a pawn up
but being clever I would include D4 D5
ah see how clever I am yeah I'm not
going to give you the pawn you are I
clever and now you lose I wanted you to
move your Bishop backwards so if you had
moved your Bishop backwards I was ready
to play Knight takes E5 exactly now the
question is can you sacrifice and
obviously yes this is um it seems like
it is welln because nobody in fact fell
into this trap okay in the position and
this is a very beautiful Trap by the way
because it comes out of nowhere I mean
do you actually have enough pieces here
to Checkmate me it seems like you do
Knight
gf4 um and you don't have something to
block the action of the bishop3 would be
a good move right now it would be a
great move right now unfortunately you
don't have that Rook to E3 maybe if you
do spend time with uh Knight to F1 then
I just take I take another one the
attack continues because I'm going to
open up with F5 as well you cannot move
the knight from F3 because the queen
will get involved into play this is a
decisive Advantage for black so you
cannot play D5 for this particular
reason take on H3 D5 H3 is a really nice
reputation but D B on H7 that's a
highway on the
diagonal guided missile you know right
out of its Silo uh fantastic stuff uh
thank you for that uh Christian as we uh
just uh I want wanted to go around and
yes here it was uh the game I really had
my eye on well yeah I'm a bit of a
carocon player myself I enjoy uh playing
the black side and I was more than
curious how Nasi was going to repair
right uh because she had lost her
previous outing with AO against A5 what
I find intriguing is first of all uh
much like her game with vean she didn't
bother to stop A7 A6
she said I'm not concerned about what
you're doing on the queen site go ahead
and get your Pawn to A6 well Karissa
said uh coming uh wait a second wait a
second Rook C8 but you know I like this
for Nazi because with this Rook C8 and
also if you play A6 if let's say U car
plays A6 I play B6 I'm also ready to
push with that C5 exactly now you've got
it even further supported so okay both
players keep A5 A6 as well as a A7 A6
and
a uh aian and Bishop to B4 and now this
is what I was waiting for I thought that
this was absolutely vital that uh Nasi
gets in this break F7 F6 because as long
as this two pawns remain intact I feel
cramped and she's playing really fast
Nazi right she lost no time one hour 30
minutes on her clock so she knows what
she's doing right uh whereas Karissa she
already lost 15 minutes so she's the one
who's out of the book right now exactly
so I'm seeing a good prep and again in
this case a quick question for you
because I can recapture a myriad number
of ways one way I definitely don't want
to recapture I don't want to recapture
with a knight because that would invite
Knight to E5 followed by F4 uh
recapturing with the bishop makes a lot
of sense because I do want to play
Knight G6 and and E5 again I think if I
get in the move E5 I'm satisfied but for
the moment this bishop irritates me so
I'm most tempted to recapture with the
Rook even though I do block my Bishop I
kind of release my knight to make uh E5
possible your uh quick take would you
prefer to play White would you prefer to
play Black why uh I would prefer to
capture with Bishop first of all I feel
because after Rook takes F6 I'm
wondering if white can go something like
Knight C5 Knight C to try to get rid of
that Knight on D7 who is guarding the E5
Square now I'm going to recapture with
the bishop okay now you know I'm a pawn
grubber I don't want you grabbing my
Pawn so I'm going to play V6 okay I
capture that and now you've opened up
the a file advantageously for yourself I
get that so I'll move back to B4 okay
but now haven't you encouraged me to uh
before I was anxious to make the break
E5 now with my Rook on C8 okay I was
thinking maybe your pawns are a little
too
advanced I see what you no I see what
you mean Bishop C3 is actually a very
good move you're going to pick up a
Tempo against my Rook I don't like that
so I will continue with my previous idea
of Knight G6 so that I can play for E5
and I go Rook A7 here okay now I don't
want to tolerate a rook on the seventh
rank so let me get my Rook back
out and I yeah I mean you're right maybe
black kind of recovered and it's ready
to push the pawns I don't know it's it's
it's uh one of the things I really do um
value greatly is experience I think that
if you just play an opening over the
years you kind of get the the the the
right feel for it Nazi has been playing
uh the Caro Khan for quite some time now
the question is is this a position that
Carissa is familiar with because I'm
pretty sure it's one that Nazi is
familiar with we'll keep an eye this
position really requires some accuracy
from Karissa as well because he don't
understand how to really kind of grab uh
this position then black can push on the
king side on the queen side in the
center with E5 it's yeah it's it's fun
stuff and again uh Carissa comes in with
an absolute career defining performance
itself s out of eight and uh well I mean
if I'm in Nazi shoes I'm sitting there
saying you know what I want to play
spoiler you may be having the tournament
of your life I'm not as n you know that
Karissa really needs to win right she
needs to kind of keep up with beim who
is playing extremely well so there is
pressure on Kisa whereas there's not
much pressure on Nazi right now yeah
there you go and back over to you uh
Christian where's the action I'm looking
at this game we were discussing about
this one as well Shanklin at the
beginning of the show and Mishra who has
been absolutely sens Sensational in uh
this event up to this point and with the
black pieces is throwing the gauntlet he
playing the French like okay let's play
Let's play a long game let's see what
you have against the French I'm not I'm
trying to catch up with a leader I'm not
trying to make a draw I'm not playing
any sort of berlins I'm looking for a
fight and that's exactly what we're
seeing right now and of course Sam is
going to uh be very happy to accept it
with Queen to G4 one of the most
aggressive lines against this particular
line of the winware queen to C7 and
Bishop to D3 not Queen takes G7 this is
the main line Rook to G8 Queen H7 I take
on D4 sure he got a couple of Pawns I
got one back I cannot take on D4 because
Queen to C3 is coming along the way so I
have to usually defend with Knight to E2
against Queen takes C3 it's very
theoretical but it does seem like black
is doing quite fine in that particular
case I think what Sam is trying to do is
avoid those main lines with this idea of
Bishop to D3 the idea behind it is that
if you do take on D4 now I don't have to
take on G7 first I can first defend my
Pawn on C3 but now the bishop is out
right so this is a much improved version
than what we've seen in the previous
line that I just showed with the bishop
on F1 the bishop on D3 is a perfectly
placed piece you take on C3 now I take
on G7 and this is a completely different
uh situation and I want to say a
favorable one for white so black says no
no no okay you play this bishop to D3
now I'm grabbing a Tempo with this move
C4 Bishop to E2 I go back but now we
have a closed Pawn structure on this
side there's no more C takes D4 there's
no uh more ways to take advantage of the
fact that my queen is already out on
this side of the board and cannot help
the defense on the queen side Bishop to
D2 Knight F5 defend the pawn on G7 H4
and now we have this position wow H5 H6
both of the players are playing fairly
quickly but I have to say Mishra is
quicker than Sam and we know that Sam
whenever he knows his uh theory he
blitzes out his moves right he doesn't
wait he he doesn't try to trick his
opponent maybe pretend that he forgot
his theory he just blitzes out his uh
moves and put puts a lot of pressure on
his opponent not in this case so perhaps
Mishra has surprised uh Sam out of the
opening with this French defense
statistically speaking how do uh only
three games only three games and in fact
white has won every single one of
them oh dear not Queen to H3 Knight to
F3 by the way by the only move played in
this position right Queen to H3 is a new
a wrinkle okay it makes some sense right
you want to go
G4 the question is so Bishop D7 go ahead
and play G4 if you'd like what happens
why not B5 what because I think this is
the plan right in the position I can
push for B4 you cannot capture with the
a pawn and if you capture with the c
Pawn the D4 is hanging exactly but
aren't you doing me a favor by I mean my
Bishop on D2 is terrible my double Pawn
so I go G4 you go G4 you probably have
to I I think Knight F3 actually B4 might
come on the board and maybe I don't
answer okay now you have still G4 so
maybe I shouldn't uh hurry up with that
maybe A5 first but okay you go G4 kn7
and now
wewh the key question with the move
Queen H3 is Sam Shanklin prepping F4
Knight F3 Knight H4 F5 I mean it's slow
but okay you could go why not let's see
who's first that's the question who's
first yeah and Knight F3 and B4 yes and
so we get something like this do you
even continue with Knight H4 or I'm not
sure if I'm worried about B3 or not I
prob take that pawn you're going take
the pawn I think I will yes way I think
I will and I will put my Pawn on A2 and
then Rook B8 and Rook B1
yeah
yeah what don't forget you cannot
castle Yeah that you probably forgot
about that no no no I mean I remember
these games of B vinck where they played
in the world championship and he would
put his King on D1 in these closed
Winward positions this isn't the closed
this is you play B5 B4 very very fast
yeah and okay even you get to F5 but
what else okay you got to F5 now A2 Rook
B8 is coming you're still not getting to
my king that easily right exactly I mean
even when he goes F5 F6 uh double edge
we'll keep an eye on this queen H3 maybe
a bit slow uh quickly r ra Wesley say
Wesley so well this was the the um Joko
piano with Knight C3 C2 C3 we've been
witnessing that in the Hans Neeman game
with the Knight on C3 again it's sort of
like Wesley saying that this Knight
doesn't go anywhere to play F5 because
I'll always jump to D5 but okay what can
I say I'm not a big allowing is white
going to allow Bishop
G4 yes Bishop G4 oh okay it's white turn
so maybe H3 are we expecting don't know
it could be Rook E1 it could be Queen D2
but go ahead H2 H3 let's say I I match
your H7 H6 with my H2 H3 you know if you
play no Bishop E6 this is the structure
I do want to avoid right then I've got
too many sets of double pawns right and
I can two double pawns and on the E file
the C file and remember games of
Grandmaster Duncan subtle where he would
play Queen B1 Queen A2 and uh his Queen
would be perfectly good on the queen
side okay well keep an eye on this game
by the way for me leavon
aronian uh is well what can I say
sometimes it just doesn't go well no
wins yeah one of the big favorites
rating favorites coming in the into the
event all draws save for one defeat this
is not an event that he's going to
remember remember it looks like one of
those Queen's Gambit accepted endings
four versus 4 two versus two uh slight
Advantage for white just because uh Sam
has an edge in development so a little
bit of a it looks very solid for black
right on the other hand these positions
two players who haven't had a
particularly good tournament uh darush
and Jeffrey Jang again similar ending I
mean you can you can really uh learn a
lot studying these four versus for two
versus two endings one player in
particular uh I was very fond of as a
youngster AA
Rubenstein and he play yeah baby one of
the great Legends of Chess he played
these endings very very well and uh
studying his games gave me a great
insight into these four versus four
isn't a white here kind of happy already
Rooks on open files so white has some
extra tempos here exactly white is the
first and
definitely uh got that going now the
question is is what you really need to
do is you need to you need to play
Knight E4 MH at the on the one hand
opening up the rook and you need to play
Bishop C3 like if you could play both
moves it's like huge Advantage like just
maybe even winning Advantage white
because you just have uh control of the
open highways in diagonals so yes so but
from from uh Jeffrey's point of view if
Jeffrey can play Bishop C6 he'll close
off the C file and then both Rooks
develop on those same open files and
like it's okay precisely so it it really
comes down to a Tempo or so again I'm
just going to check with the Hans nean
game before uh going over to the women
after Knight H5 by the way no D4 D5 uh
no allowing tricks on trick Knight F1
very and maybe now this move Knight
takes uh E5 could be a threat Knight F4
Knight G3 takes on D4 and we are up to
date with the players now if we follow
the game of Hans neemo and Andrew Tang
for a moment remember there was a
capture on D4 and Hans recaptured with a
knight he did not play C3 takes D4 so
Knight takes D4 in this
case a little bit more compelling
because we're uh hitting both the bishop
as well as the F5 square and I don't
know are we still in yes Theory uh
Christian somehow we are still in theory
and uh in fact probably what would be as
quite well-known Theory because
Dominguez versus Wesley is a big big
game from only a few months ago in this
line he takes D4 at least to my eyes is
quite surprising it doesn't make that
much strategical sense because you allow
me to take both with the Knight which
most likely were force you to give me
the bishop air but also I can take with
the c Pawn right exactly in fact two
nice Knight takes D4 seems to be the the
only move in the position if you do take
with the c Pawn after the move C6
followed by D5 black seems to be getting
and you might be wondering why C6 and
not D5 first well first of all I'm not
trying to only put tension in the center
but I'm also trying to create another
Avenue for my Bishop on A7 via B8 once I
play the move D5 for example if you go
something like Bishop C2 I go D5 if you
do go with the move E5 I will play F6
and I will play it very quickly I'm
going to challenge you immediately in
the center and I'm going to be saying
that all of my pieces are more or less
perfectly placed for what's coming
against your king side The Rook is no
not on E8 yet so on f8 is perfectly
placed to open up the file the queen is
going to go to F6 this bishop right now
has the the potential of of attacking
and pressuring the pawn on D4 but also
maybe transferring on the other diagonal
once these two pawns get exchanged so I
have a lot of options in the position
and it does seem like white has not even
challenged black in this structure with
C takes D4 Knight takes D4 has been
played um three times five times excuse
me every single game in this position
exclusively nice and the next move
another surprising one Bishop
just giving up this is all Theory
apparently yes to give up that Bishop we
cherishing right our missile uh that was
a beautiful Bishop why are you giving it
to me right visually right now I'm
looking at the position I'm like so
happy with white I got the bishop I have
the center everything seems to be
working in my favor it doesn't seem like
you have anything going on on that side
maybe even this night on F4 without the
Outpost uh um provided by The Pawn on E5
maybe it's a liability in the position
right that's how I feel at least when I
look at the position but then you look
at the engine and you look at the games
being played in this one and after D5
once again it does seem like black is
doing just fine if you go E5 Queen to H4
and in fact I'm starting to get a lot of
tension building up on this side some
sacrifices are going to come in the air
yeah Bishop takes H3 is an idea even
Knight takes H3 at the right moment and
it doesn't seem like you have a clear
way to improve your position Knight
takes G2 be careful careful be careful
for example if you go something like
Bishop to E3 Knight takes G2 finishes
the game on the spot I take you go here
I go Knight to H4 or Bishop to G4 Bishop
to F3 I have options this one is all
shirro more yeah Knight H4 is compelling
fin finishes the game so you see out of
the blue something happened on this side
right uh you have to be careful with
white and it does seem like you need to
bring reinforcements on this side with
Queen F3 we still following that game
between Dominguez and Wesley saw and
right now there were a couple of moves
played D takes C4 which I believe was
played in correspondence games and queen
to F6 which was the move provided by
Wesley and I do think that Queen to F6
is probably the more um tempting move in
the position the plan is clear well I
actually have an immediate threat right
now you cannot spend wasting time for
example with E5 because of Knight takes
h3s that's a check give me the queen
whoops and if you don't then I just
exchange I get my knight back I'm a pawn
up and the compensation so what you have
to do you have to defend this Pawn on H3
or the queen on F3 plers move was Bishop
to D1 King to H2 has been played as well
and then we go into this variation take
take take take
take to be honest I don't see the
advantage for either side right now
right it's even I take on e4 at the
right moment I can go back to D7 we have
the opposite color Bishops I don't have
any huge weaknesses in the position as
black maybe you still have a slight pull
as white but this is not going to be
enough Knight takes D4 is on the board
and right now let's see if Fabby is
aware of this by the way I'm sure he is
when he when you think about lir and
Wesley when you think of lanir and
Wesley as big rivals to Fabby he's
studying their games very very closely
and I'm sure he's got this in his uh
book but once again let's remind our
viewers who are joining as late that
Fab's road ahead Kate it's not easy he's
playing he's playing every one of his
games against his closest competitors
today Hans Neiman tomorrow abano Mishra
and round 11 Wesley so and Wesley will
have white as Neeman has white today and
Misha will have black tomorrow but that
game you talk about all Champions
matchup I mean only one point behind
Wesley could do himself a solid winning
the last round game I mean then I'll be
asking you all about the
playoffs much more and look at that Bish
Tak D that Knight on D4 uh came pretty
swiftly so he knows yeah you prud is
about keeping the two Bishops or I mean
the Knight on F4 actually looks
dangerous right together with the Knight
on G6 and white piece is a little bit
removed to the queen side exactly I
don't like giving up the bishop at first
but now when I see the kind of targets
on H3 it's a different story it's very
concrete right you have to follow it up
with D5 otherwise white plays D5 and
you're in huge trouble right if I manage
to start kicking your pieces backwards
but yes D5 putting a lot of pressure and
it does seem like this gives some
chances for black as well if you get
overly ambitious as white you start
playing E5 try to close position like
this queen H4 F6 Knight takes H3 things
of that nature start to be uh quite
tempting in the position and in fact are
giving black uh not a decisive or a very
good Advantage not Advantage but an
attack a very good attack on that side
nevertheless you have to be careful with
both sides you have to be aware of the
details in the position it does seem
like by the time expenditure that we're
seeing right now perhaps Fabby is more
aware of what he has to do talking about
uh you know teeny details tiny details
uh the move Queen H3 by Sam Shanklin was
not followed up with what we thought was
the visually attractive looking
g4f uh there was no B5 by the way but it
was Bishop D7 probably a more
traditional move in such positions
Bishop D7 again again no G4 no F4 no
let's playing Knight F3 in a big
kingside uh expansion no Bishop that's a
surprising yes exactly like great I
understand the bishop is no great shakes
on E2 that is it maybe we just want to
clear that square tonight to play Knight
E2 Knight E2 okay that makes sense and
the Knight will find a good Square on F4
but if I let's say vacate I back and 92
92 and much more traditional I'm not
interested in castling short and you're
going to show me your Tactical
explosiveness by sacrificing on age six
but I'm going to go castles and I'm
going to tuck my king over here how will
white break through you're not going to
there's no breaks on the queen side you
can't play the desirable B3 that's
illegal you can't and if I play F4 I'm
not really ready to play F5 because
black species are also ready for that
breakthrough well the other thing is I
don't even think you want to play F5
like even if you could like is it
desirable for you to you
know trade the light Square Bishops
that's my liability that you're trading
off after all right like okay you go
Bishop takes let's say I go Knight B6
just I'm I'm making some moves and in
this particular case I think the bishop
on D7
its exchange has been actually
beneficial right and The Rook on A1 is
going to have a very difficult time
joining the game somewhere exactly uh so
I'm not I I don't follow it yet I mean
this must be some extraordinarily deep
prep by um Sam Shanklin Knight E7 again
Knight E2 castles and I was kind of
being helpful to you F4 let's say I go
King what if I just now Retreat the
bishop to F3 okay excellent and I put my
king safely in the corner G4 excellent
okay so the way I used to play the
French was I uh I I liked the
night on A4 not the queen I like the
Knight as the blockading uh piece so
you're welcome to play F5 if you would
like I may start with Bishop E3 Bishop
E3 King D2 conic the Rooks excellent so
D2 and so I've got what I've want and
you get what you
want I want to put my knight right so I
may play something like A4 okay I'm
going to give up that pawn Rook A3 you
the moment you said I'm going to give up
that pawn now I have open a
file I said I'm going to take
it you enjoy your open file I'll enjoy
the extra fun um actually A1 it it's
it's actually funny what we've been
doing Kate I have been playing King on
C8 to B8 to A8 because I had wanted my
king in absolute safety the funny part
you put your Bishop on F3 I don't know
why and it turned out to be the perfect
location uh for uh teasing my king okay
um yeah this is what what both French
defense players you want to play but I'm
not sure how to break in there exactly
and once again uh why is this game of
Mishra and Sam Shanklin so importantly
well Sam with a victory he could be in
that group of of players playing in the
second place Mish conversely if he could
have a victory or he could even find
himself in clear second going into uh
tomorrow's 10th round game where he
plays against fobby over to you
Christian breaking news guys please beg
him is
winning I know what right I had the
exact same face as you just did because
Ru Yang took on B4 in this position no
yes she did Queen A4 check Knight to C6
Knight to E5 that was and now she played
Rook to
B8 what she missed the next
move
C5 your Bishop is not getting out if you
take on C5 right now unfortunately your
Bishop is no longer protected that was
the whole idea of Rook to B8 protecting
the bishop on B4 now the is not
protected you go Knight D7 I take the
Knight take extra piece game over oops
how do you defend after C5 you can go
Castle I go Knight D3
back I asked the bishop where are you
going with the bishop Bishop to A5 I
take on C6 I take on A5 you go A5 I go
A3 to so fair I was completely focused
on take C6 a move like Knight D3 I could
easily Miss as black after C5 it's over
I there there's no way to save the
bishop that's an extra piece that's an
extra piece is there's going to be an
extra piece in the next few moves
capturing on B before after the bishop
loses Tempo Bishop E7 and Bishop
captures B4 that's very brave
right and this is a cold shower right
now because she spent a lot of time on
this bishop takes B4 and trying to make
sure that after Rook to B8 that Bishop
comes back home we're safe no C5
finishes the game beg him continues to
storm through this event and this is
move six Bishop Tak before was move six
guys you're lost at move six after
Bishop takes B4 and there is I mean
there's uh bearing an accident uh
there's nothing saving you right now
this is going to be a full piece you
don't have any compensation I mean you
might get a couple of Pawns but that's
not much right you're losing one of your
most important minor pieces in the
position this one is looking Grim right
now for ruang and C5 must be a complete
shock I feel like players who are
playing b game I'm just are just not
themselves right it's like they're just
giving away presents strange oh my
goodness there a there's a hex on the
event uh where both Karissa and beum
have just you know keep giving me more
and more points and by the way Karissa
is also doing very well right now one of
the shocking things I am seeing early
Knockouts I mean we saw Talia playing a
very very poor opening uh losing uh out
Andrew Tang had an incredibly bad
position against Hans Neiman he managed
to save it but that was Hans doing as
well was a miracle yes uh but he was
like losing after 11 round 11 moves
losing after six moves something is
going on you have uh Na's position Kista
is doing quite well as well I think we
left it somewh around here Bishop B4 was
on the board when we Bishop to B4 okay
so
this6 was some sort of a novelty seems
like F6 was played after only 3 minutes
of thinking Bishop take take but I'm not
sure this F6 was the right moment to do
so Bishop to D6 Knight to
E5 I've said it before and I will say it
again these are the type of positions
Karissa loves she loves to play against
two openings from my experience seeing
her and commentating on her games quite
uh uh for a long time she loves to play
against the French she loves to play
against the caran these are type of
structures that she enjoys and she knows
she can handle very well even if she
gets surprised out of the opening right
now nasia I have to say this is not
inspired this is not an inspired opening
choice and right now her position is not
inspiring either because after I put the
Knight on E5 you take it at some point
you will have to take it and probably
right now you have to take it I don't
think you want to go back to f8 this
doesn't look good I I play Rook F7 and
encourage destroy it right now right can
I go Rook G7 sure so in case you play F4
I'm opening at least the G file yes but
who are you opening that g file for and
I don't even have to do this now I have
ideas of Bishop cannot go back to G7 so
I can take one of your Bishops with a
move Knight to G4 you can give me the
light Square bishop or the dark Square
Bishop whichever you want
yeah now I why is it so bad
this oh this is a problem okay you take
I take Knight F7 I take on D7 I'm
picking up at least a pawn and I still
have a tremendous attack no weaknesses
for white that's another big problem
that black is having right now you don't
have any uh sources of counterplay in
the position as black I'm not liking it
Karissa and beggy yeah I wow Head to
Head you win I win you win I win you
make a draw I make a draw you win I win
it's just an incredible uh race that
these two ladies have been engaging all
throughout the event take a look at this
mirror
image Incredible line scores for both
both of them were to win today that
would be five victories in a row and uh
we thought Alice Lee's
40 was impressive five wow eight rounds
without losing a game just perfect score
it's crazy and and wow I'm just kind of
stunned by this uh again uh big
advantages out of the opening for both
big um it's a little bit depressing if
you think about it yeah right you're on
eight out of nine and you're thinking
okay I'm cruising give me the check give
me the title give me the trophy right
but no no there's another lady next to
you here's a sh out of n here's a Sher
of second right right right it's
incredible absolutely incredible uh
historical I said it at the beginning I
don't think we've ever seen this type of
race before at na only one Championship
you got to go way way way back to the
40s two ladies both scored perfect
scorers except against each other they
made a draw hence they had a mirror
result with one another right CU they
only had one draw they won every other
game uh that they played which year was
that gosh remember I'm going to have to
ask Ed Gonzalez he is the
archivist uh amongst our group but this
is amazing I'm watching it and it's kind
of disbelief I remember this wonderful
wonderful line by Magnus Carlson we were
here in St Louis during the SFI cup and
Fabby had gone on a streak 7-0 won the
tournament handsomely with many rounds
to spare Mike Klein of chess.com in the
uh post tournament interview
said to all the players please give me
one word to describe Fab's performance
and it was like brilliant outstanding
marvelous it comes to Magnus Carlson
depressing I mean for the other ladies
of the event what do you think of this
amazing scores by beum and Carissa
depressing I mean they just keep winning
all the games now again it's still early
days for Nasi but I agree the bishop on
D6 the Knight coming to D4 for white C4
F depressing how do I open the position
Bishop H Bishop H5 is it's in the air as
well I mean depressing it's depressing
it's depressing and the problem is you
play this move Rook to C8 just a couple
of moves ago you actually wanted that
square for your knight to attack the
bishop Pawn D6 now you have to go back
to A8 lose another temp in the meantime
you get killed unfortunately things are
not connecting very well for Nazi in
this tournament she's struggled in this
one as you can see she's not the type of
player that will be ever happy with
points you see that just a moment ago
with a kind of
like kind of a growling frown I must say
as we prepare for a break we just want
to say that uh coming up on the break we
had a very very nice day here in St
Louis uh Community Day on one of the
rest days all the grand Masters went out
and into the community and uh high
school or elementary school and play
with kids yeah and the lectur and we've
got some highlights of that coming up
before we go on our break I just want to
check in on our
friends and see what's happening for
today well today we have the hip hip bag
and the puffy vest check this out gear
up in the newest apparel from the St
Louis chess club with this official
branded hipb that's a fanny pack say
what that's a fanny pack
hey man I I mean didn't write the script
don't don't I love that fny P I love it
it features check this out a fully
adjustable belt and the chess club
signature logo across the center of the
bag also feature today is our St Louis
chess club puffy vest that shows the
chess club logo across the left breast
pocket pin it pairs well with a club hip
bag now dude you're throwing me off my
game over here so you can keep warm in
style available at cutique stl.com all
your chess shopping needs do check it
out we'll see you on the other side of
this break Fanny bag what the
[Music]
heck uh so today's Community Day all the
for students of the US Championship are
going to schools around St Louis and you
know teaching kids um openings and games
uh tactics doing some fun stuff like
hand and brain some simos and uh we just
finished our first class and it was
really fun I see kids taking the um
skills that they're learning in chess
whether that be critical thinking
decision-making skills planning skills
and I see them applying that throughout
the rest of their school day whether
it's in classes or sports or even just
how they interact with one another and
with their teachers I played with my
Auntie my mom my sisters sometimes on
the weekends like we go to the park and
we play they be begging me to teach them
I like show them like new stuff like new
openings I show them that and so I'm
trying to see them get better and try to
beat me what I like about Chess is just
trying to have fun and learn new things
and maybe I'll get more into it and
it'll maybe be my full career I heard
that if you play chess you make bad
decisions in life life so I always want
to make better decisions in life I can
tell you that they've engaged more in uh
critical thinking they are looking
analytically at moves and trying to
think ahead I like the um complexly of
Chess how you have to think about every
single move you make like every move you
make whether it's going to put your king
and check whether it's going to put put
your anything in danger whether it's
just a move that you make everything
counts in the long run I like um how it
makes me use my critical thinking makes
me look at the whole board I think it's
teaching them to be persistent you know
we have a lot of students who it takes
them like it may take a few weeks or
even months in chess club to master a
particular strategy or skill um and what
I think that teaches kids is even if
they don't get it the first time around
or even if it's difficult the first time
around um it's worth sticking to it well
well one thing's for certain without the
St Louis chess club we would not have
chess instructors because I don't know
if you all know this but there is a
critical shortage of teachers and
Educators and especially those in areas
that are not core content area and
because of the St Louis chess club
collaboration we have people who come in
here working with students who want to
work with them today with the experience
of the grandmas community outreach day I
came up and I'm like well what's a
grandm and they like oh you don't know
what a grandmas is they were able to
explain that and they recognize the
importance and the seriousness I mean
it's a sport it's a profession and so
they're able to see things outside of
the sports that we typically promote in
school it makes me feel good because
like learning stuff like this will help
me learn help me build my problem
solving skills help me build strategy
and like you know helping my
[Music]
brain
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for juniors helping around
schools and they've just grown the game
so much across the United States I think
if I look at my own career and I look at
American Trust in general we're in a
much better place than we were 15 years
ago and so the contributions have been
immense and of course it's all thanks to
Dr juny singfield and Rex
sing I would say that St luia Club is
like a rock in the ocean of Chess and we
know that it's it's there it is there it
will be there I think it sense a hope
that the game of chess will always stay
Float by the mere fact of its existence
I think it it it sends positive waves
acoss the
[Music]
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly t
and so much more visit St Louis chess
club.org to claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both inch
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
[Music]
seducation St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the worldclass
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph collectible chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex singfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomes chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including The Prestige sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit St
Louis chess club.org to claim your
membership
[Music]
today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1,500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chest piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
concerts and much more whether you are a
beginner or a professional there is
something for everyone to learn here at
the World Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free
admission to our rotating exhibitions in
our Galleries and sign up for chess
events familyfriendly programming and
art classes and don't forget to stop by
our award-winning gift shop Q Boutique
and Shop a wide selection of Chess
related merchandise for more information
on current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of these 2023 National
Championship things are heating up in
round 9 but as we get ready uh to bring
you the action first we wanted to
welcome a very special guest on Studio
Alex kerford Alex welcome
aboard nice to be nice to have you
between Kate and I and Alex I got to
tell you obviously you wear a lot of
hats here in St Louis so if I can do uh
some honors you're on the board of
directors of the St Louis chess club and
Scholastic Center you're really The Man
Behind the initiative for the corporate
chess League here in St Louis you're on
the US chess trust and you just recently
beat Rex singfield with your group of
all stars in the ultimate moves what is
it that you don't do It's Been a Good
Year it's been a good year for my career
in chess exactly well it's not a slum
welcome aboard thank you very much thank
you for having me absolutely now tell me
a little bit about your work with the US
chess trust because Yuri shman was on
the show and he had been inducted into
the Hall of Fame and I know the US chess
trust does a lot for chess in the United
States so one of one of the highlights
would be at the beginning of this uh of
the United States Chess Championship
being a part of the ceremony to induct
Yuri into the the Hall of Fame it was it
was a wonderful ceremony it was a great
time to play a part in studying the
accolades of different people that are
um selected as candidates and then
seeing them um be a part of that
ceremony was able to have dinner with
Yuri afterward and just to hear his
appreciation his gratitude of being um
in that is certainly a highlight but I
would say even bigger than that uh would
certainly be the extension of the US
chess trust in our education programs in
the Scholastic support that we're doing
to help schools help organizations
throughout the United States um get
involved and and be a part of chess for
decades exactly it has been decades yeah
no I I remember the US chess dri way
back in the day uh really supporting
also our Juniors and our Allstars going
to now all of these youth championships
around the world too Kate so
it's really really nice and uh thank you
for that and also the corporate League
uh yeah Alex you are instrumental in
founding the corporate chess League tell
us how it started and where the league
is today well like a lot of good ideas
uh I was having a drink with a friend of
mine and we were talking about the the
the massive kickball league that they
have here in St Louis and I just
remembered thinking about uh
corporations do softball leagues these
these kickball leagues now why don't we
have a corporate Che league and so I
remember calling the club I see Lauren
there on the screen and I talked with
her about that and just said hey here's
this this idea I don't know where we're
going to take it how it would work and
ultimately the St Louis chess club took
that idea and has ballooned it
into a staple here in St Louis now I
think we have 10 teams some 60 plus
players Washington University They just
added a team um we've had we have
lawyers we have financial advisor have
all these different types of careers
that are now part of this this corporate
League Edward Jones yeah you're the team
captain right how did your team do Team
Edward Jones has done pretty well though
wait a minute that didn't sound like the
first place wait a minute a little bit
of humble
Swagger we won a number of them so far
last year though team Enterprise was the
big winner and um but it's always been
competitive a lot of great players come
out and it's about the networking these
cross industry ideas that are shared
that a lot of the the aspects of Chess
that translate over into your your
industry and so that's what we've been
seeing with the corporate chess leagues
development I remember being present at
some of these events it's really nice
networking event where people talk about
Chess but also talk about their stuff
and just enjoy competing against each
other absolutely it's been a lot of fun
Christian you're going to put our guest
on the hot sea I have yeah okay go for
it I have to your question we have this
incredible race in the ladies section
yeah you have beim Karissa and then you
have this big Clash that we're watching
right now Fabby with the black pieces
defending against Hans you have been
following the Championships who are your
favorites win on the ladies on the
ladies I will start with my with my
friend my partner in crime going back
when her and I played against varujan
and Rex in a in a in a duel Carissa yip
okay come back and win the female uh us
CH Championship that's that's a good
start I mean you're doing quite well so
far decent chances okay so on the on the
open section the open section with Bobby
onepoint lead but Le next three rounds
this our next world champion and oh Us
world chion and US champion will be
Fabiano Carana also predic you heard it
you heard it here first yeah that's
that's a good prediction I like it wow
now I said fa me too that's our did it
before the event started so like you got
to give me a little bit more credit on
this one I said h i mean I'm doing quite
well you're in the mix I said first
right before you even I'm not sure we're
going to have to go to the tape check
the tape check the tape on that one Alex
once again thank you again for
everything that you've done and I also
lastly I know you're also involved with
the quesa club as well here uh we have
our quesa dinners and uh the big chess
set outside the World Chess Hall of Fame
we've got our names on the squares as we
uh contribute each and every year to the
quesa club and that's a really nice one
too absolutely the number of things that
the St Louis chess club and World Chess
Hall of Fame have done in the St Louis
area in our community um over the past
uh 10 or longer than that now over 10
years has been absolutely amazing so my
wife and I have been involved with the
Kista Club um I believe about seven
years now and it's been been great to
get to see some of the um behind the
scene things that get to happen and
being engaged in so many ways so really
appreciate the opportunity and all that
the club is doing conversely thank you
so much Alex for everything you so much
and I have actually one last question I
know your children also play chess
they've attended summer chess games what
are your plans for for them and their
chess career I I just try and right now
hope that they have a lot of fun I hope
that they are enjoying it and seeing the
curriculum that they're doing at school
complemented by the curriculum that
they're getting through chess helping
with concentration with reading those
would be some of the big things I hope
that they're able to get from chess
right now and uh and that they can't
beat dad
yet very important very important don't
get too far ahead of yourselves
youngsters okay keep dad in the mix uh
once again Kate tell us about the
standings uh with the ladies as we're in
the thick of things here in round nine
and uh we have K and beg to here Jova
storming through the tournament
incredible performance seven out of
eight and again they're much better in
their positions right now so it's
incredible what we may see uh happening
next and then we have Arena crash and
Ally dying for third with Five Points
who are facing off today in today's
round and in the open section the
standings we know Fab's in the lead he
is in the lead with five and a half
points but look at that four other
players are kind of peeking and trying
to catch up with him Wesley so Lenard
Dominguez H Neiman and aanu Mishra
fantastic and uh taking it over to you
Christian where's the action well guess
what we were just discussing about this
game you guys highlighted this this one
I'm not sure about Fab's position right
now H is starting uh to get some
pressure yes yes out of the opening take
a look at this so we were discussing
this particular position we said E5
don't do it because Queen to H4 comes
right and then you have some problems
here you do have to give me uh this uh
bishop and then you have to try to
defend with a r coming over the C5 but
in the absence of the dark Square Bishop
uh because you had to exchange that
Bishop to to get one of my Knights away
with two knights around your king you
don't want to see that you're going to
get checkmated so you have to exchange
one of those the problem is the pawn the
bishop on A4 right I'm putting my Pawn
on C6 I'm blocking I'm creating this
wall uh against your light Square bishop
and I have to say I'm looking at the
position I go C6 then I go Rook to E8
defending the bishop PA E6 then I go F6
at the right moment I go F6 where is
your plan on the king side or on the
Queen side I know where my plan is it's
on the king side right so also Queen to
F3 which is the very typical position
for the queen in these type of
structures is going to get hit after the
move F6 opening up the f file your queen
on F3 in shambles I have to say this
position is looking really good for
black the pressure is on white but that
didn't happen he he rushed it he rushed
it yes F6 with a move F6 I don't like
this move specifically for the reason
that we've seen in the game this
exchange followed by the immediate
Knight to H5 and this is a very
important move you don't have time to
wait you don't have time to take on F6
Queen takes F6 in fact right now black
is completely winning now the Knight on
F4 is a super piece I'm going to take on
H3 either with the bishop or with the
Knight depending on what you do next and
then you have some problems on F2
beautiful position that f file is just
fantastic for black it it's in fact over
is Knight H5 is key very good move and
found immediately by Hans and now
Fabiano started thinking okay because he
has something uh very threatening coming
in the position F5 and this is not a
move that already a concession that's a
concession that Bop to be BL E6 Bishop
on E6 is just a glorified Pawn exactly
and uh I almost called uh this bishop a
PA now this bishop is definitely a pawn
in the position right now I'm going to
retract via C2 put some pressure on F5
we've seen this structure actually
against Andrew Tang a very similar
structure Hans was white and he didn't
manage to win that game managed to win
that one but I he was the one pressing
throughout the game this is not a good
situation right now for our tournament
leader and golden opportunity I mean if
you are hunt with white pieces you come
into this one how do I get my opponent
out of the opening I mean this guy is so
well prepared finally I get him out and
I get him out with a better position wow
this is the ideal situation and scenario
for Hans to try to put pressure try to
win this important matchup huge huge
opening success here but take tell us
tell our
viewers what we understand that the
bishop on E6 is a a bad piece it it it's
passive and is essentially it's covering
F5 but white has to win the game how is
white planning on winning the game a few
uh ways but the most obvious one is drop
the bishop to C2 okay you don't
generally want to uh you don't generally
worry too much about ideas of C5 because
after C5 first of all I'm going to be
able to take on C5 open up the D file
and create another um Square for the
attack the square D5 I'm going to go in
the defensive I'm go C6 Queen E8 please
trade Queen means I'm going to try to
make a draw we're not trading Queens
right we're not trading Queens I'm going
to go Queen to H4 I'm going drop back
whenever you attack my queen and then so
let's
begin
C6 it looks like clearly wants to attack
on the king side but with G white also
has to be careful right not to rush it
too much yes but I'm not sure about that
because I will go King H2 I will go G4 I
will put the Rook on G1 and F1 most
likely and at the right moment I will
take on F5 okay that's my plan right now
and the problem is you don't actually
have that many good ways to defend
against that you just have to sit and
wait so can I go not make weaknesses
just to kind of play A4 A3 I want to
weaken that A4 I might stop you in your
tracks just to be sure okay just to fix
that side yes yeah but it doesn't let's
go right otherwise but doesn't it come
down to one thing though Kate white has
to play for G4 like that's the only
break in the position and black has to
set up some kind of way of meeting that
so if you go Rook A7 in this position
for example and you go Rook G1 it
doesn't matter and if I go G6 yes and
just for example you well maybe Rook as
a preparation and I go Rook G7 so we
both you know I make my My Line in the
Sand right as as black I go Queen D7 and
I say you know I Hold On
that's probably what you have to do how
do you break how do you break that's a
good question because I have a feeling
that white May kind of prepare
everything on the king side and then
switch to C file or you know something
like that right because you got space
and I'm kind of CR it can be easier for
me to kind of transfer the pieces
whereas you know for black it may be
more difficult that's rule number one of
a strategical attack to be successful
you need more than one Target in the
position and the target is right now on
the king side but then as you mentioned
shift it on the queen side shift it
against the pawn on C6 so options again
it's play on one goal that's the problem
black only has to defend and maybe
that's why Fabiano after this move
Knight to H5 that's probably his train
of thought as well okay I'm going to
suffer I accept that I'm going to suffer
for the remainder of the game but do you
have enough to break through that is the
question Fabby seems to be thinking that
he probably has enough resources to
defend this one successfully and H I
mean look play on one goal he's happy
with the outcome he's going to try what
if we take a look at this game between
Talia cantes and atusa bashian these
players are not the leaders in the
tournament but they have a very
interesting position because Talia is
this time kind of trying to quickly
attack black uh she has some space
Advantage so what is happening she has a
pawn up oh she took on A5 and then she
defended that on I was very very
cognizant of the fact that look I mean
this is an impressive array of white
pawns on G4 and F5 Talia boy I tell you
if it wasn't for bad luck she'd be
having no luck at all so she currently
has an extra pawn and I would say just
an absolutely terrific centralized night
on e4 which she wants to keep you are
about to say this move Knight G5 aims
for E6 I'm a little worried about the
king in the center and all the pawns
Advanced but the king is kind of safe so
far exactly and in in fact fact if you
were to if if black were to play B7 B6
strangely enough even though White's
Queen side is Advanced you can't open up
the Queens side the Queens side would be
closed so maybe in such a circumstance
Bishop D2 followed by Castle long I
think that talia's got you know huge
Advantage just because of the extra pawn
and her ability to attack on the queen
side I wanted to ask uh Christian if you
don't mind uh your student beum I mean
she played that move C5 it it looked
like a huge advantage to us is it still
the
case it seems like ruang has found a way
to not lose a full piece let's take a
look she played night to D7 well first
of all she got stunned with this move
C5 like I mean that was not on her she
spent 30 minutes after C5 exactly she
spent quite a while up this point and
then after C5 this is only move n she
only has 30 minutes on her clock right
Knight to D7 Bishop takes C6 Knight
takes C6 Knight to very clever idea very
clever it's the best thing you can do
exactly you have to find some sort of
counter chance to avoid losing a whole
piece and now Queen to D1 very unclear
decision Queen to A7 seems to have uh
been just simply winning right now the
question is I guess why and this is the
answer you take an exchange that's a
simple exchange and the problem is we
also go into the end game and the
problem is your Bishop is also a little
bit iy on B4 right so Christi maybe
there was an idea to First instead of
Rook B7 yes to play Queen D5 and I take
a full piece a full I can take with the
queen takes B8 Bishop B I take capture
with the queen and that's maybe the key
yes that's maybe the key if you take
with the Knight I go Bishop B7 there's
something going on perhaps even though
the engine is saying F3 completely
winning right but I can also just simply
take take with the queen and then the
bishop on B5 Bishop on B4 sorry right
right uh and and I can't even Castle
because there is a fork on
E7 nothing is working your way yes yes
this is over when it rains it pours
that's that's bad news so in fact Queen
A7 Rook B7 is forced that would have
been an exchange in a nice ending she
said no I want to keep the Queens on the
board but perhaps this gives Ru Yang
some opportunity is more training with
B's required there's still a rook the
pawn take the pawn B Queen takes A7 it's
still a full Rook but she's going to
Castle and win her Rook back will most
likely F3 was played and now castle and
now what do we have not that easy I can
go Bishop to A3 and to be honest I think
this is the key move in the position for
the simple fact that you don't have time
to go Bishop A5 and keep more pieces on
the board because I take take a knight
D7 that's fair Knight gets out I get
another exchange game is over right
right so Bishop to A3 at least you do
take my knight on B8 but I do Force the
trade of another piece I'm not a fan of
Bishop takes A3 I don't mind trading
pieces I want to do it on my
terms so that at least the Knight on B1
is kind of stuck that's a very good
point yeah okay now maybe I can drop
back to B2 my Bishop isuck now your
Bishop is getting stuck Yes
Man we same Bishop just then moves later
you have to be careful you have to be
careful but again there are some chances
after that stunner C5 ruang got the best
outcome that she could have dreamed of
she has something to play for right she
has some sort of compensation position
hasn't simplified at all and right now
begim still has to calculate precisely a
few variations until she can uh get her
Advantage fair enough and how about
Karissa our other tournament co-leader
when we left it we really like Carissa's
position against Nasi how is the a C5 C3
got included we still like it we still
like it for the simple fact that that
Bishop Pawn D6 is moner yeah and the
question is how are you um how are we
seeing the position after Knight of C6
uh if you don't mind I the reason I
probably take right yeah the reason I
didn't like the move C5 for black was
that I thought um Carissa was going to
answer C4 yes and then if you play D4
that gives me time to either Play Bishop
F3 Bishop H5 F4 and I've kind of locked
in the I think opening up the position
on this side very favorable for Carissa
but she played C3 kind of slow playing
it maybe Nasi should play Bishop G6
Knight
F5 Bishop to G okay this is how you want
to play I'm not sure I want this
position as black I have this position I
like it yeah no it's a good move
question I'm trying to get the pawn yeah
well that you're attacking me from a
different that's the thing angle yes and
maybe that's why hold on B6 just go
ahead and kill me uh well I'm probably
going to take and then try to invade but
none of this is going to happen because
she played
A6 stopping Bishop stopping Bishop B5
yes specifically against that idea but
this looks so nice for white very nice
still some work no question be the same
very nice right now still some more true
that so and then finally our other very
key Marquee matchup that's Alice Lee
against Arena Crush if you had told me
coming into today's um round that this
game would be for first first place I
would say yeah you know these are two
great favorites why not not the case
they're two points behind the field
nobody could have guessed that what's
the current situation in this one how do
you like this one Kate white has a
little space remember this was the BOGO
Indian right and somehow we didn't get a
D7 D6 structure we had a completely
different huh that's interesting al5
move forcing the Knight to go away from
the center that's an interesting idea
for sure maybe a very nice one too
because White's enjoying some kind of uh
positional squeeze here I mean it's very
easy to imagine if I could play O excuse
me apologies if I could bring a rook to
D1 drop it like magically on the D6
Square you could get suffocated you know
just Rook double Rook so black Arena has
to be careful that uh none of that
happens and I suspect she'll have to do
it with a move like F7 F6 just to even
at the cost of
maybe making more Pawn Islands in her uh
structure uh Rook to D1 White's play is
too fast uh your take I think it's an
advantage but how big right because I
think this F6 move is really strong
immediately to Target that pawn okay cuz
if you capture I'm going to capture with
a rook
okay and then I don't know Rook e one
yeah just to bring the Rook double the
Rooks and you know funnily enough when I
see this bishop kind of
cementing uh I start to think that maybe
your Bishop is actually doing a better
role than my Bishop so whenever you know
strategically I weigh a a piece that's
in your favor then I want to take it off
so that's why I played the move Bishop
E4 and now I think black plays Queen C5
I do understand that maybe white has a
slight Edge but I don't feel like it's a
big one Queen captures B2 B3 and again
Kappa Blanca would say I have two Pawn
Islands you have three Pawn Islands
therefore I'm better but modern players
know it's not that simple and you think
it's somewhat balanced somewhat balanced
all right very good Christian you know
I'm going to ask you where the action is
well just to update on this game uh nean
versus car yes so Queen to E7 after F4
was the move uh A3 and now C5 okay
immediately trying to create something
trying to create counterplay on the
queen side so we were discussing the
strategies you can play C6 and wait or
you can try to go C5 and create your own
chances on the queen side he decides to
go with C5 which opens up the
opportunity for white also to create a
second uh weakness the pawn on D5 so D
takes C5 was an option I guess Queen
takes C5 actually right now just simply
works because of Queen to D4 and you got
a hit you have this Pawn on F4
unfortunately that's not going to help
you you just played the move F4 and
that's going to work against you in this
uh situation so perhaps after F5 maybe
what he had to do was get ready against
this C5 Rook to C1 played slow Rook C1
maybe bishop to C2 King H2 and then go
with the move F4 because I don't think
black actually wants to play that's a
question right if after Rook C1 black
can actually play F4 or not Bishop to
C2 I have a feeling you get check so if
I go G6 you just grab that yes yes yes
so G6 doesn't work you have to go
H6 um and that's a problem I think Queen
G6 Queen G6 and queen takes A6
so we have this position right now and
Rook A1 was played okay not taking on C5
saying okay it's kind of getting
interested how do you play it right now
do you take do you defend or do you push
with C4 and try to create you would
capture that pawn yes you would take it
okay um but I'm I'm expecting Queen to
D1 and then the queen will recap so if I
play Rook Rook f8 to C8 for argument
sake Rook takes now the funny part I
would feel okay with black if my Pawn
were on B6 because I would play Rook C5
and I would be challenging the SE file
not the here I feel like white white has
a an advantage we'll take it back we
won't take on D4 right away in in fact
we'll we'll keep the tension with the
move B7
B6 and and know what if I go Queen F3
back I have some ideas of Rook Rook C8
Rook C which Rook that's a good question
I'll tell you
after that's not how chess Works a C8
Rook A8 R A C8 so in this case if it's
my turn maybe I want to take on D4 play
Rook C5 or Rook C4 so the whole thing is
I do want to take four Rooks off the
board but I want to do it on my terms I
want to be uh because the one thing I
don't want to avoid is the passive
position we were looking at before where
it's kind of play on one goal by the way
you make a good point should black play
C5
C4 that's because that I
mean the idea then of course is to put
my majority to work Rook B8 B5 B4 and I
don't have to wait for you to crush me
with G4 on the king side and at least it
does seem like what white has to do
right now is keep the bishop on B5 in
fact M try to stop me from going B5
myself it does seem that if you allow me
to go be for example Bishop to C2 let's
say you're trying to go uh G4 this is
already bad for white I'm the one that
breaks through on the queen side first I
go B5 B4 that already creates an
opportunity and then B3 if you allow me
to so you have some problems in the
meantime you're a bit slow on this side
so Bishop to C2 doesn't seem to be the
right approach and if you do have to
keep the bishop on
B5 again how do you break on this side
I'm not seeing it anymore what I'm
seeing is in fact not a break on the
king side but maybe an idea of B3 and
breaking on the queen side switching
flanks right now uh for White's attack
this is not easy conceptually to do
because all your focus is on the king
side right now now you have to play on
the queen side I'm not 100% sure still
big decision right now for black C4 Rook
C8 and C takes D4 are all very viable
options by the way for me I'm suddenly
warming up the C4 because what you've
just showed is a variation I can analyze
very consequently I as black play the
move A5 A4 and I go haha you're Bishop
is trapped you you got back Rook A5
you've got to take the pawn I'll take it
B5 you've got to move the bishop sure
B4 no sorry sorry B5 B4 and
that's I was already
ahead and you know okay that was the now
I'll play C3 and I'm the one with the
more dangerous Pawn I I I respect the
fact I'm a pawn down I D3 Rook E3 and
just try to grab that pawn right Rook C8
maybe Rook A1 if you go Rook C8 I was
going to
go ah I was about to play Rook A2 but
yeah there you go okay uh then if you go
Rook eight I think I have Rook A4 also
no or maybe I can just take take and
Rook E3 okay so go go back to the
position when you went you're playing
without a piece that's the problem right
I was going to play G7 G6 to release my
Bishop here so it's yeah so instead of
Rook C8 G6 yeah yeah Rook A1 Rook
A1 Bishop to D oh now you might play E6
not in time yeah yeah I was going to go
Bishop B Bishop to B5 okay it was a PA
very Pawn sacrifice if you have enough
time to reroute the Bishop from V6 to B5
you're good okay if you don't you're in
trouble there you go simple chess lanir
Dominguez versus uh uh Andrew Tang
because again laner coming game for the
standings well and for lanir I mean he's
just saying okay you know I'm I I I'm
having a decent tournament I'm
undefeated and plus
one Hans do me a solid he thead
positions right he had that amazing one
brilliancy game almost uh finishing in a
win uh I would almost call this the
modern filor because I mean the old
classicists they didn't play Bishop 8 A3
to C2 they rather left their Pawn on A4
and black often played the moves B6 A6
and then played Bishop B7 white has been
putting the pawn on A5 and for a lot of
players uh it's a cramp position but
it's a solid position it's not that easy
for white to crack these positions last
move Bishop D2 it's kind of an
indication right there it's it's not the
most obvious move like yeah you know in
this position like Bishop F1 Bishop B3
Bishop A2 but as you said it's not at it
looks very pretty for white I have the
center I have a great Bishop on this A2
G8 diagonal but it's not that easy to
kind of break in okay so imagine that
you played the move Bishop D2 and
imagine that I'm black and I just played
the move Rook B8 it's sort of like what
are you going to do you going to go
Queen C1 and Bishop takes H6 well I've
already got that H6 what are you going
to do you're going to play Knight H2 and
F4 well pay attention the pawn on D4 is
hanging in the meanwhile let's say you
make a developing move I'm not saying
it's good and not saying it's bad now we
kind of start to understand what I'm up
to well you know on a good day B5 B4
start taking some space back on the
queen side Lan's for Choice don't get me
wrong I do like Lanier's position but
you know it's going to require some
really good technique to um show more
advantage and I don't know if clock
times are a factor so Lard has 35
minutes and Andrew tank 53 somehow
that's expected right lanir even though
you know he played probably his first 10
moves pretty straightforward like
because this is all standard stuff right
but he didn't he spent a lot of time on
those on each move I'm really surprised
because until Bishop A2 it's straight
Theory exactly I would expect them to
lose nothing just gain time right and by
the way in these positions I've also
been seeing white Play Moves Like B3
Bishop A3 as well as the inclusive move
B4 sometimes white then captures on E5
and plays Rook B1 and makes pretentions
that I've got a queenside attack keeping
an eye on this one again we have another
important game between Wesley so and Ray
Robson the former Webster University
teammates and um uh dorm mates as well
yeah roommates uh I I asked uh Ry and uh
Wesley what it was like dorming with one
another and they said well we don't
really go to school I go what we
basically play Blitz all day against one
another I mean that's what our days are
and here um okay so the story on this
one is we take away the okay the A6 pawn
and the D3 Pawn those are the
differences in the position right so if
we take away the A6 and the D3 pawn it
would be even since we're keeping them
on the board we say the pawn on D3 is
slightly more valuable than the pawn on
A6 so white is slightly for Choice C4
and this move is an indication that
Knight D5 looks just too solid though I
don't but I don't understand this C4
move honestly this change of Pawn
structure I thought we may want to play
something like Knight F5
D2 and the problem is is where do we go
we go Knight F5 we go King H7 you go
Queen D2 oh no that loses a pawn no it
doesn't KN C4 I still I'm still
defending that Queen with Knight on F3
right okay I was just going to go Queen
so the my idea is black is like you're
not really making uh sacrifices unless
you're unless I'm
targeting yeah I guess I would have to
play night D4 yeah I think I have Knight
D4 as an answer to Queen C3 so I I'm
satisfied uh he did play by the way the
move C4 and in this case I understand
that for Wesley's perspective if he can
play Knight D5 make Ray capture so that
C4 takes D5 maybe on a good day the C5
Pawn might be uh a little bit vulnerable
so Ray played Knight B4 which is a nice
move targeting the D3 Pawn makes sense
to me so we are expecting Knight D5 from
Wesley right exactly because Knight E1
would be really passive to just move
back that pieces yeah no that move uh
does defend the D3 Pawn but I don't know
it might invite Queen D4 yeah I just
find the move itself to be a little bit
too passive Knight Knight D5 and let's
again just kind of continue this line
for a moment I believe his intention is
to recapture with the c Pawn why else
did he play C4 and you think white is
better in this position those nice three
pawns for black yeah they they they look
good right but okay I always struggle in
these positions because I feel like
something looks good the pawn structure
but then how do we continue and the pawn
on D5 is protected so that's forever a
danger yeah it's like what we would call
the static Advantage right the protected
past Pawn that there that is there there
there whereas you have
Dynamic uh possibilities
uh thanks to your night thanks to your
breaks so long-term Advantage white
maybe shortterm you can prove equality
with Queen D7 and A4 but okay um
something to play for for white I think
Knight E1 to C2 on my agenda but I don't
see this as the action this is not the
action for me Christian come on Rescue
USR we'll get back to the leaders for a
second right because C4 was played on
the board so Faby played the move C4 but
and Bishop B5 was our main move not yet
played yet this is a key moment of this
match because if you don't play Bishop
to B5 what do you do B5 is a big threat
for black so for example if you play
something like King H2 sure I go B5 now
excuse me not B6 B5 and I take it if you
take it now I go A4 and I queen A7 in
the absence of the Pawn on B7 right
Queen to D1 that's fine Queen to A7
defending same idea Bishop is kind of
Trapped yeah high and dry right right I
mean I don't have an immediate way to
attack it maybe Queen to A5 I have to be
careful and perhaps you have to go
something like Bishop to C6 the question
is Rook a to B8 and you have to pick up
the pawn on uh A4 at the same time we
exchange this Pawn on A4 for the pawn on
B2 or Pawn on A3 is we my paon on C4
it's a tremendous weapon enough
compensation for black yeah so big
moment right now and if you don't go if
you place a bad move Rook to E2 let's
say you want to defend the pawn on B2 B5
I take Rook to B8 doesn't work because
the pawn on B2 is protected you're
actually lost right now because of the
same no more Queen to D1 and by the way
we do have a move Queen to D1 I like
this move this is a good move B5 no more
B5 for you yes at least not immediately
because Bishop takes uh B5 and then A4
is met by Bishop takes A4 so I like this
move Queen to D1 prophylactic move I
have to say the queen on H5 doesn't
really preparing B3 move by the way yeah
that's an opportunity yes because if we
can get B3 even if we give up the pawn
on A3 we can start maybe to push our
Pawns in the center let's say King h8 B3
sure you capture on A3 yes capture
captures I don't have C you don't have
but if you would have it then that would
be a very good and that's why King H is
actually
useful it's not a random move it's a
random move but it's a very useful
brilliantly by away because Queen takes
D5 doesn't come with check right um so
unfortunately no more D5 and that's not
good uh good news for you nevertheless
it's an idea B3 is definitely something
that Hans has in mind okay let's make H6
right B3 and then go into the same line
now D5 is in fact still not
still not work not working we'll get it
we'll get it we'll get it at some point
by the way King h8 is on the board King
is on inviting is he trying to go G5 now
are the roles getting reversed like you
were attacking you on this side now I'm
considering attacking you on this side
that's hilarious on the king side that's
kind of exactly hilarious maybe maybe
he's actually trying for G5 and in fact
you cannot really stop it that easily
right because H4 doesn't work you lose
that pawn uh and queen D2 doesn't have
uh allows B5 idea so an interesting
position I have to say very very
intriguing I hate to be a onetick pony
and King h8 is an absolutely fine move
right but if you take that move back for
just a moment uh Christian and you try
Rook f8 to B8 and I want to play B5 and
you know get on with business you with
Bishop B5 correct I was going to play A4
which is and you have to play Bishop
takes A4 A variation we we've seen
before B5 but I don't have to by the way
I don't have to take on A4 you don't
have to take on A4 well you're not
actually threatening anything right ah
Rook A5 isn't winning I will take them
yes so you could make a move like Rook
E3 or some useful move uh but if you go
down the line for just a moment the the
difference I wanted to mentioned was
that after Bishop C2 if I play B4 and
you play ab and I play Rook taks uh this
time B3 might be met by a queen A7 you
know it's not such a an easy uh yes the
pawn on D4 is a little bit vulnerable
and okay uh
so I I see the engine there's some ideas
for sure yeah that that it could work
but
okay5 was played King uh against King h8
so Queen D1 and now Bishop to B5
M I think we're going for G5 guys I I I
really think that that's what he's going
to do because now everything is more or
less closed on this side but you've also
committed your Bishop to B5 right so
that might play against you cuz you no
longer have the defensive mechanism
after Bishop to C2 maybe put some um
attack on F5 Bishop to B5 on the board a
rook to G8 we're expecting G5 Fabby just
made Mo G5
okay all right these players are not
playing around they're not playing
around I'm I'm forcibly reminded of a
brilliant line by Grandmaster from
Romania Michael schuba and he said bad
Bishops and he's referring to the bishop
on E6 protect good pawns the the bishop
on E6 is actually playing a role after
G5 you can imagine that F4 takes G5 in
the future will be yes mhm 5 F4 Rook is
on G on the G5 get to F3 and this bad
Bishop on E6 suddenly is an Allstar I
think that's why remarkable white
probably can never capture on G5 right
always waiting for black to recapture on
F4 but with this move G5 I mean Fabby is
signaling Rook G8 and he and he's ready
to go on the attack on the C this is
going to be a back and forth this is a
great G5 okay you committed I mean on
this side you've opened up your Bishop
doesn't move at any time because E6 is
coming and you get checkmated right B3
at some point is going to be the counter
chance that white is going throw at
Black forced actually as what I would
think immediately
or yeah B2 B3 is going to be a forced
move to rescue your Bishop so you can
play Bishop G Bishop F1 I don't think
you want to go back and then to D1
that's too slow allows me to play on the
other side as well with B5
so this one
beautiful conception quite tense because
it's kind of true we've been trolling
that Bishop on E6 but the bishop on B5
is also maybe not that great at the
moment exactly kind of hang stands out
um okay the we didn't look at yet Sam
saian Le Aron right was kind of equal
maybe we looked very briefly what is
happening there right now well once
again we have this ending of
uh uh Queen's Gambit accepted ending
four versus 4 to versus two uh well okay
white has the two Bishops leavon didn't
care that much we've caught up with the
players because I know sometimes in
these positions the bishop retreats to
the first Rank and then the pawns are
pushed uh but the knights are now
standing really well in the center so
it's not that easy for white to push the
pawns well I now that you've mentioned
it E4 F4 E4 E5 would certainly like
let's just throw in a move I'm not
saying this is good or bad just like
let's just see what would happen if I
did launch my my pawns forward H2 and E3
maybe I have to play Knight F3 Knight F3
defends and defends and the idea for
white is if I could you know get an E5
and then H3 and keep pushing you around
uh I would actually well have some
serious advantages in space as
well as uh uh the two
Bishops is G5 asking too much from the
position it just makes it a little bit
more Awkward after E4 to follow up with
F4 G5 a good day if I could play uh G4
and H5 I could secure my knight in the
middle of the Lord what do you think
Kate H5 doesn't look the like the first
move I would consider in the position
but it is stopping White's uh kind of AD
advancement with those pawns
exactly all right uh before we do take a
break I just wanted to check in on our
two lady tournament leaders let me just
see what um uh Carissa and
um no that's the Talia game Karissa was
uh the caroan where she had the bishop
on D 6
remarkably both players have slowed down
I mean we saw C5 C3 A6 Rook E1 not much
action but we're looking at this bishop
on
D6 and I love that did we like the move
Rook F F1 because we were thinking that
F2 F4 was a a kind of a key weapon for
white whether you combine it with Bishop
so Rook E1 means that you lose F2 F4 is
a a line of play what right I feel like
she wants to play Rook E1 and Bishop F1
to kind of protect that pawn on E5
because we can expect black to play
Knight G6 yes we can but then you have
of careful about white playing G4 right
and sometimes be trapping the bishop
there's a bishop although but still
Bishop E4 yeah
uh
intriguing uh game going on uh this is a
strategical game but a very very
tactical game that was going on was
between beum and Ru yangang Yen and let
me just find that game because that was
this whole C5 business right remember
this
incredible uh find I want to say by uh
Ru Yang Yen I thought beum was just
going to materially win a peace thank
you sign the score sheets no no no no
after the move Bishop B7 F3
we did see Bishop A3 and she took we
were expecting A5 right trying to kind
of keep that Bishop active yeah and then
we have to deal with this idea that
maybe we we left our Bishop high and dry
R said okay I'm going to win back I'm
now in exchange down do I have a pawn
for it by the way yes one Pawn okay
that's okay but maybe it's just not is
clearly trying to trade pieces right she
has a material advantage SO trading
pieces is the number one strategy you
want to you want to take uh now that you
said
it I I almost want to play Knight C2 and
Knight B4 take the great advice of Kina
trade pieces I was I was about to catch
myself and play the move Knight C4
because I thought okay the Knight looks
pretty good there but Knight C2 to B4
also the I mean whites for choice I mean
it's just an exchange for p
and you know as long as I don't get
checkmated down this diagonal I keep my
Pawn on F3 life should be what has to
kind of figure out what to do with the
F1 Rook right are we going to double up
the Rooks on the B file and play Rook B8
to trade them or is there something else
exactly and I I would think that Queen
D2 and you start playing moves like Rook
B4 and Rook B1 Advantage Why by the way
time factor in this uh so be has almost
one hour of playing really fast whereas
rang Yen only 20 minutes okay so uh
beging for choice on the uh clock as
well and as we do go to a break I want
to thank you all for sharing your day
with us as we are in the final three
rounds of the US championships and as we
go on break we do have a very special
message for you from our board of
directors have a
look
[Music]
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for juniors helping Ground
Schools and they've just grown the game
so much across the United States I think
if I look at my own career and I look at
American chest in general we're in a
much better place than we were 15 years
ago and so the contributions have been
immense and of course it's all thanks to
Dr J singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that St lucious
Club is like a rock in the ocean of
Chess and we know that it's it's there
it is there it will be there I think
it's sense a hope that the the game of
chess will always stay Al flat by the
mere fact of its existence I think it it
it sends positive waves across the
[Music]
glob the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess is
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1,500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit World Chess h.org
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess Co a partnership with the St Louis
Police Department looking to improve
relationships between atrisk kids and
police officers in the St Louis area
with over 600 students playing chess
over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and WR chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St louises club.org
education
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the worldclass St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is is something for everyone
at Q Boutique and all purchases go right
to benefiting new exhibitions and
programs at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q bouti stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
enjoy
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr jeie Karen sinkfield and
Rex singfield the St Louis chess club is
a nonprofit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development ment
critical thinking concentration and
analytical skills the St Louis chess
club welcomes chess lovers of any age
and skill level to come and enjoy the
game of chess we also promote Chess at
the highest levels hosting all levels of
the US championships and the American
Cup as well as high-profile tournaments
that attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit St
louises club.org to claim your
membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's his
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
piece sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
family-friendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value Val
of Chess to kids and schools across the
St Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting St Louis chess
club.org
education St Louis the chess capital of
the United States it also plays host to
an award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
enjoy
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of these 2023 national
championships we are in round nine and
it's been a very intriguing round thus
far as our leaders uh have uh good tough
games I really like the game of fobby
first of all let's take a look at our
leader group absolutely women's section
standings after round 8 and look at it
Kar say beging do janova at absolutely
fantastic performance so far seven out
of eight and then a two-way tie Arena
crash and Alis Lee with Five Points as
they uh face off against one another in
this round n uh tell us about the
standings in the open here we have a so
leader Fabiano Carana with five and a
half points and then bunch of player
behind him Wesley saw Lenard Dominguez H
nean and abanu Mishra with four and
health fa's going to have to earn his
National Championship because he's
facing Hans nean Mishra tomorrow and
Wesley so to finish so he's going to
play all of his closest rivals in these
last three games and let's uh just check
in on all the games we're going to go
around the horn we're going to start
with the ladies and we've got telia's
position and she just has this
massive you look at this grouping of
Pawns and you just say oh this is just
fantastic for white specifically why
well she's a pawn up to begin with
there's if you put a Pawn on F7 and a
Pawn on e4 that would not be the case
but it's really this great knight in the
middle of this board Knight on e4 her
last move A4 A3 sets up the very obvious
and very clear intention of uh
clobbering that pawn on D6 big Advantage
for Italia Jennifer Hugh this is a game
we haven't really looked at Kate yeah
what's happened we miss how miss that
yeah exactly this is like an old King's
Indian David brunstein special you play
E5 takes F4 and you get a cramp position
in the center but as a
compensation you get to play all kinds
of
tactics uh in these types of positions
as black if you have a if things go your
way one day you get to play F4 Bishop E5
and H4 woohoo but Jennifer is very
direct on her f file right she just
pushing that one forward and she just
made a move which was uh I think no
Queen somewhere Knight D4
E2 okay
so um in principle I've done well on the
white side of these but I do respect the
fact that this bishop often times comes
to the square E5 with or without G5 G4
and if you ever trade I'm kind of happy
I kind of equalize at this moment I
think ashria is doing well I would I
wouldn't say you know optically it looks
good you know you've got a Pawn on F4
it's just unclear how to continue with
what you can't push F6 G4 H I'm not sure
if I want to do that right now and I'm
also not so sure I want to take so some
doubts about how to continue this
position now we come to one of our
tournament uh co-leaders uh beum
everything has been going her way
certainly that's the case early in this
game she's an exchange up for for Pawn
these pieces are not that comfortable
last move was H5 R is trying to create
some kind of attacking chances on the
king side with H4 even giving up that
pawn well it's one of those things it's
it's Desperado time right because you
can see if you don't do anything and
allow white to play Queen D2 Rook B1 and
trade pieces as you've suggested it's
game over so but you know we've seen
this before when beging played against T
Abraham she was also an exchange up but
t started with this H5 H4 and she got
some play there no question about it in
fact I would say beam uh got lucky in
that one but okay we'll keep an eye on
that Karissa uh yep when we left it we
really liked karissa's position a lot
because of this move Bishop D6 um we
were a little surprised by C3 right
because we were like we want to push
that pawn to C4 I thought we want to put
pressure on D5 and potentially we want
to open that diagonal after Bishop F3
exactly
so she played C3 A6 Rook E1 Rook C6 and
now that you put the Rook on C6 the move
C3 C4 looks especially attractive
because again uh Bishop F3 is going to
come with the tempo takes on C4 I just
pause here for a second
because um I'm looking and I'm not
satisfied with the Knight on B3 it
should earn its oats right so the Moon
move Knight
D2 preserving F3 for the bishop and
Knight takes C4 has my undivided
attention Bishop but what if I after
Knight E2 I have Bishop
D3 okay so that means that you're going
to want to trade I assume the bishop yes
I'm assuming the bishop as well yeah so
if it feels nice it just feels nice for
white an easier Play She pardon me she
did play not Knight D2 after d takes C4
she played Bishop takes C4 which is a
very natural move you capture you are
putting pressure on the E6 Pawn so G4 is
in your uh Arsenal there because the
bishop on F5 does defend the pawn on E6
and you may also think about Bishop
takes C5 because that Knight on D7 is
pinned yeah Lee uh if you're going to
put it like that that's really ugly
because it does mean that you have a
double threat your threat threat to play
G4 dislodge this bishop so that you can
take the pawn and if you're just
threatening to play Bishop takes well
Bishop take okay so I'm going to play a
bad move so Bishop takes C5 does have a
a drawback that you are putting your
Bishops you know
um you could you could be getting no
Queen D that would run into Bishop but
yeah Bishop C8 so you I mean queen C8
you are saying you are putting pressure
on that C file with two Bishops but I
capture I capture oh you captured that
one I I I have a dream I mean my
position feels like an open Civ you know
just like blacks got weaknesses
everywhere but okay maybe bishop takes
C5 I like we can think about it but
maybe not play it I like's uh uh pardon
me I like Carissa's uh position a lot in
this one we're going to continue uh Anna
zatonski and
tatv looks a little bit balanced here
again not too much though because white
has some potential moves like A5
absolutely it's my turn right now and
black has not deved the bishop on C8 yet
and where going KN yeah I take it back
uh no I I I I dislike this development
uh for Anna and definitely tatev in Pole
Position Alis Le is in an end game
against
Arena even number of Pawns Bishop
ending looks pretty even I would say uh
King E3 Bishop B4 K D6 G4 I don't see uh
how I'm going to uh upset the
equilibrium in this one this one looks
balance Christian over to you and Fabby
cuz that's a big game big change is in
that important game between the leader
Fabiano Carana with the black pieces and
of course Hans nean with the white
pieces we left it off after the move G5
yes and we were saying okay things are
getting interesting in this one because
black is just blasting open the king
side while the king is hidden on h8 and
you have to do something really quick as
white on the queen side otherwise you're
in trouble and take a look at what
happened B3 Hans understood the
assessment and the assign but B3 I have
to say perhaps not the best way to start
with mimed the priority was to defend
first on the king side but this is not
easy this is really really difficult to
understand you have to go Rook to E2 I
that's a difficult move to make take and
now Rook to F2 ask me why I'm I'm not
really sure D2 Follow by Queen to D2 so
protect the second rank first and then
later on you will take recapture on F4
this is not easy stuff B3 but this is
already a step in the wrong direction
take a look at this take on F4 you take
on C4 but the problem is after Rook to
G8 I'm the one that gives the Checkmate
first in most of the variations right W
you cannot take on D5 because after
Bishop takes D5 that actually just
simply helps me now the G2 Pawn is
absolutely in shambles and F3 is coming
supported by the bishop on D5 as well
this is problematic so what do you do he
said okay I'm going to go Rook to C3 but
the problem is D takes C4
D5 check sorry he did not play that like
I was shocked for a second because after
D5 the game is over Queen to
C5 for a second my partner was trembling
right he played Bishop take C4 of course
but the question is okay what if I just
simply take take
take look at you you're just nothing but
a pawn grubber and it's not only that I
also want to
H3 is hanging I also want to Checkmate
you if you give me the opportunity thank
you very much right of Jennifer you and
Arena crush the queen is coming back yes
yeah nice check you are trying to run
away you're not running away anywhere
and queen to H1 would be game over so
this is the position that we have right
now big opportunity for Fabiano Carana
not to clinch the tournament by any
means but to take a very decisive step
in that direction because if he wins
this one he eliminates one of the
contenders right H ler still has some
chances and we will check that in just a
second abim Manu not so much and Wesley
not so much yeah going into the last two
if you have a onepoint advantage that's
quite significant no question at least a
one point Advantage as you came on the
show Christian you said that these two
players Hans NE and Fabby matched up in
a very strange way three games three
games three white pieces four four Hans
three victories for you have the white
pieces you lose yes but somehow it felt
like you know through the law of
probability at some point you have to
get a victory or to make at least a draw
to score some points but right now it
doesn't seem to be the case uh by the
way Bishop takes C4 was played we're
expecting Queen takes A3 and I have to
say this one is looking really good for
Fabiano at the same time it's still not
easy white still has those very
important Central pawns if I manage to
start pushing them if I manage to go D5
and E6 then I'm starting to get my own
play the problem is it's a very concrete
position and I'm also having my
checkmating threats so uh B Concrete
Bishop C4 Rook C4 Queen takes A3
attacking H3 threatening F3 threatening
Rook takes G
I going to have to play Rook C2 to just
defend now if you take h on H3 as well
F3 is another threat I got to play well
should it should it be Rook F2 should I
play Rook F2 yes so Rook F2 you you you
said Mike source of counterplay is
D5 and E6 and queen D4 check how bad is
it I mean I know I'm two pawns down but
if it was my turn and I could play D5 B
it's really bad oh no Rook Tak G2 it's
really bad yes to G5 the problem is
Queen to H4 with a threat of F22 and
queen takes G5 you cannot take because
that's a Checkmate that's clear so
everything seems to be working in
Black's favor and Rook takes G2 is the
most deci decisive it's not the only one
what if I play just like Rook G3 very
natural I can also probably go to G3 yes
and this might even be enough as well at
the same time you do get something here
right you do get some Queen E5 ideas
things that was what I was was hoping
for as as far as my counterplay would be
concerned Queen A3 is on the board guys
the problem
is you've been on the attack the whole
game as white you've been pushing
pushing pushing and trying to break
through and right now you have to defend
you have to make a couple of moves that
are very defensive in nature Rook to C2
Rook to F2 that's not psychologically
Pleasant to do no you might as well just
play D5 yeah and then unfortunately
after Rook to G2 you have to resign so
right there's big threats for black in
this position Hans must not be happy
with the way this game has progressed in
the last few moves and right now he's in
trouble and by the way yes we were
discussing about that second place yes
only one point behind well one of them
is doing quite well and that is lenir
Dominguez we expected this at the
beginning we said hey you're ler you
have white against Andrew Tang the
lowest rated player in the event you
have to get a victory if you want to V
for that top position you have to get a
victory that's right and he understands
the assignment in this one this is what
we have the times surprisingly are very
closely matched up so that's good news
for lener right because he usually is
very much in time trouble situations uh
in his games with a better position I
have to say I'm seeing so much control
over the D5 Square and at the right
moment I will go I I have the easy plan
right I go Knight to D5 maybe Queen to
F3 Rook to D1 to progress in that way
I'm seeing this position I'm seeing a
lot of tension on the king side I don't
see the counterplay for black and I have
to say lener has a good opportunity to
score a victory in this one for example
if you go B4 I just simply go Knight to
D5 Knight D5 Bishop takes D5 you're
creating another weakness in the
position so what if instead that I try
to trade Knights Knight takes G4 sure
yeah que takes let's say h takes or
queen takes let's say queen Knight F6
Knight to simplify the position
definitely by the way I can also take
and this is a big problem because with
the bishop on D2 G5 is a big threat
right now um and the problem is G5 comes
also for example if you try to go G6 G5
H5 something like this to stop me well D
I have Queen F3 first right there's no
more Knight F6 now without the pawn on
G7 that's nasty there's a lot of
problems in in Black's position right
now and it doesn't seem like he has
enough counterplay to create anything uh
for himself if you don't mind uh from
the current position I think the queen
on C6 for Andrew is some well somewhat
misplaced I I feel like Knight D5 Bishop
D5 I'm going to get hit let me get my
queen out of the way just a moment uh
Queen C8 let's get out que C8 yes best
mov in and then maybe now maybe B5 B4
and that's why maybe I have to stop you
with the move B4 it is a very nice
strategical grip but can I also do queen
F3 with the idea to put some pressure
you can do queen F3 the problem is B4
now C2 oh C2 is hanging well I'm very
aware C and with a bishop open now after
Knight E5 I can exchange everything
that's right the queen why he play Queen
C8 that's a very open up the bishop it's
a beautiful move yeah but you played
this move be Queen C8 B4 that takes away
Knight C5 ideas that um yeah no more
Knight C5 gee I'm kind of having that
grip right and it doesn't seem like you
get out very easily D4 D6 D5 is usually
my you know Cry For Freedom uh by the
way Queen to C8 seems to have been
played okay no never mind B4 was played
and now we have Knight takes F6 Knight
takes F6 and Knight to D5 we were
expecting
but we this looks great visually this
looks great PA on B is a target Bishop
on A2 has a really nice diagonal your
queen F3 even a Rover might appear too
now this looks very good for liner
strategically very going around the
board another player buying for second
place was Mishra
absolutely by the way shankland uh his
one and a half points if I'm not
mistaken behind the leader on uh 50%
out of eight yeah and right now he's
looking good compare this position to
what we were seeing after Queen to H3
yeah right take look at this it's very
difficult it looks like it's very
difficult I'm coming B5 A5 B4 I'm
opening you up your king is not in the
optimal position sure and look at the
position now after Rook to H7 well black
hardly made any progress what were you
doing B6 King B7 that was all got
everything exactly F4 Rook F1 F5 Rook G1
G5 no Sam has really improved his
position am Mishra is stuck yeah he's
stuck that's exactly the right word in
the position you haven't done your
homework on the queen side you haven't
open the position no counterplay for you
so now you all you have to do you're
tied to the defense on the king side and
you know my pawns are going to get
pushed F4 Rook F1 Rook G1 F5 and you're
going to be in trouble and also if you
look at the clock Mishra has only 17
minutes while shankland 35 by the way
for me could you just explain that one
position of Mishra the mysterious Rook
move Rook
H7 break that one down for us
coach well thank you for
that that curve ball yeah all right so
let me try to do this at some point I'm
going to go G5 at some point the G5 is
going to get opened and then I'm going
to be ready to defend my G7 square at
the same time if you do go G5 I'm going
to be ready to double up on the H file
and put pressure on H5 a preventive
that's about the only thing I can tell
you about this move Rook H7 the problem
is I'm not forced to go G5 I can play
for F5 I'll do it very slowly whatever I
whatever break I make I'll do it after
intense preparation Rook F1 F5 Knight G3
F5 and if I go G5 and I go F5 indeed
what is The Rook on H7 doing right
doesn't open up maybe after G6 I can
double up on f file or H file yes you
probably have to do this yeah something
like G6 the problem is whoops I will uh
happily where he go yeah happily invade
on the F6 square and remember this
bishop used to be on D2 by the way this
this really and the more I'm looking at
this position the more I'm enjoying the
white side I mean
the bishop went as you said from D2 to
H4 the king is strangely enough quite
safe on D2 yes yes it looks really good
uh the other games let's at Wesley what
what was happening in this one we more
or less left it here yes I guess it's
quite balanced seems um I I don't see
too many weaknesses for either side I
don't think black is going to go A4 that
quickly because that could potentially
let's say a rook to A1 A4 and less
straight then I can get my knight to C
I'm not really sure about yeah the
Knight on C4 would be awesome yes and
that blocks your pawn and your structure
becomes extremely weak so you have to be
careful don't hurry with this break just
keep the position as is keep the tension
as is and I think black is fine white is
fine as well is one of those positions
in which you cannot really make any
progress with either side I see this as
very balanced Christian can I have one
question so if we move back in this
position yes let's say this position as
we started off right so maybe I do play
Rook F A1 but my next idea is to try to
play H5 Knight H4 Knight F5 to kind of
wait maybe I'm going to create something
on the king side support my Pawn on D6
you won my heart when you put the Knight
on F5 those are really scary nights
those nights are ideal may I will go A4
but when you take back I take with a
rook and I try to exchange all the Rooks
trade the Rooks Yes Yes Trade tra the
Rooks that makes sense take I'm not
taking with a pawn I'm taking like this
so that at least after Knight to D2 I
feel like Queen to B4 comes and you
don't have as much uh Security on the
queen
side yeah this looks good for a black
yeah yeah so I have to be careful as
well again I'm not forced to uh to
exchange to start exchanging I can just
simply go Queen to see despite the fact
that you have this beautiful Pawn you
don't really want to push it that easily
right because let's say take take take
take and you go before now I go Knight
to D2 once again Knight to D2 Knight to
C4 you don't have another resource to uh
Force the push to B3 Kate's point was
that the idea of H4 H5 Knight F5 it
looks visually really good yes but I
guess the move A4 is going to be the
counter I thought maybe if black
recaptures with Pawn yes I'm like my
Rooks are stopping that and let me do
something on the king side yeah in that
case that makes a a whole lot and I have
to be again I have to be careful with
black not to be strategically worse so I
have to take with a rook on A4 two games
that aren't crucial to our tournament
standings but nonetheless the players
feel like it's the most important thing
in the world at least to them uh is the
game between Sam Sean and leavon aronian
again we think that well Sam's enjoying
the proceedings maybe not by too much
but it's the two Bishops on a good day
that Bishop on C1 will actually discover
that there's life in the position E3 E4
Bishop E3 on Sam's agenda I would assume
that leavon has enough resources to make
a draw so we might even we might even be
seeing it right now actually we could
potentially that's a nice way uh to play
from Level not to be passive and Retreat
the bishop somewhere to F6 and wait for
those pawns to to go exactly towards you
because then yeah Sam is enjoying some
kind of positional Advantage but with
Bishop E1 I'm forcing the king to go
back yeah and if I in this position play
E4 I'm not the first to play Bishop E3
and Bishop to D4 I think uh leavon will
probably make a draw out of this one and
finally uh darush and Jeffrey Jang again
we're seeing a lot of these uh I want to
say
um Queen's Gambit accepted endings on on
the
board
and Bishop A5 okay okay taking control
of that d8 square what is saying no Rook
is going to enter there intriguing
uh I don't know what to think of this
position because if I do manage to bring
my knight to the E5 Square my control
see one of the things that uh darou is
enjoying is that his Rooks are actually
perfectly placed right I mean uh Black's
Rooks on A8 and f8 would really like to
also centralize and the
pieces uh somehow are not allowing uh
black to to to do that so you know the
question is do you want to play F4 as
black because on one end you are kind of
targeting E3 and being happy that that
Bishop on A7 may get some really nice
diagonal on the other hand there's this
E6 pawn and I'm uh kicking your night
out of uh the center uh it feels good it
feels uh good for darush uh at the
moment but I'm not saying H2 H3 I was
just uh giving an example what was F4 a
threat as you've suggested um but hey
it's back to Fabby and Hans Neiman
Christian uh Fabby Queen takes A3 he's
cruising uh yes but not so fast not so
fast no because after Rook to C2 we were
discussing this que to H3 the problem is
you also have to see the idea of Rook
takes G2 and just simple sacrifice of a
full rook in the position the more
natural move is
F3 we feel like we have to break through
as fast as possible and that's what he
did right now at the same time this is a
slight inaccuracy because it opens up
the opportunity for me to start pushing
my pawns and I think I have to do it I
think I have to go D5 right right now
what I'm thinking he's probably thinking
Fabiano that is is that he's going to
take like this queen takes H3 on his
agenda and now if you go E6 then Queen
takes H3 and I'm actually close to
checkmating uh you you give me a check
but I cover and now you have to contend
with the fact that que the music of
Queen H1 not looking great not looking
good for example if you go here I can
just go G1 followed by Queen to H2 it's
problematic maybe not G1 right now but
uh it's still problematic in the
position okay so question is how do you
defend how do you defend the H3 and the
answer is Queen to H5 I believe this is
what Fabiano has calculated when he made
the decision to play the move F3 because
right now at least you have a way to
simplify the position and that is Queen
to D3 by force that's a double attack
you go Rook to F2 I don't think you want
to take open up G5 for me G2 is my Pawn
shield and at least I'm taking on D5 at
least at least you no longer have these
connected passers but at the same time
you know Queen takes F5 Queen F6 is
coming E6 next move so you have to be
ready for those type of ideas as well I
don't think it's over not that easy
anymore no no I I I agree with you
perfectly and if you have to make moves
like Rook G7 that's a bit passive right
this is UN natural it's not the right
direction I guess that you want to take
at the same time your two pawns out
simplify the position NY um the attack
of connected to this Pawn the promotion
of the E5 pawn and you're golden as
black but if you don't manage to do that
and you do have a weak King on h8 then
you're in trouble well I always see
these major peace endings is who's got
the more dangerous pawns now that of
course the pawn on G2 is dangerous but
we might also say his shield if I could
play Queen F6 check and play E6 I'm
thinking hey wait a minute I'm the one
with a dangerous passer and even though
you're right I'm two pawns down I feel
like I've got you know counterplay
there's still some Works to uh some
things to be worked though if you don't
mind uh go back to uh the position
before the move F3 for those of you who
are joining as late we had worked out a
very beautiful sequence which involved
The Rook sacrifice that one is not
obvious though Kate Rook takes G2
absolutely not this F3 looks like it
just attacking The Rook I move it's a
whole Rook but that's the key move right
there Queen H4 the double of F3 F2 and
give me back the rook and in this case
the white King has no Pawn shield now no
check this move out where do you put
where do you put a rook that's very nice
right that is you actually don't have
where to put a rook if you go to F5 now
I go g Queen H1 you get M it yes yes
again not from a human perspective this
is extremely difficult the very natural
uh move is to go F3 try to blast open
the position as soon as possible but
perhaps a step a slight step even if
that in the wrong direction once again
E6 F3 takes G2 Queen H5 go ahead put
those moves your no I think it wasn't D5
I looked at D maybe you can start with
E6 as well yeah could if you don't mind
E6 take on G2 now you're threatening
Queen H3 so I had to go queen5 you want
to do the same thing basically Queen H5
sorry right so I will uh do the same
thing as well okay so now I have to do
my Rook F2 business you take and can I
play E7 here Christian am I blundering
something CU I want to I don't think you
are but I want to make my my what if I
go rookie eight after yes exactly now I
got Queen F5 and I've got my PA on
H7 yeah Rook takes E7 and back that's
the problem right oh that's the problem
I thought oh oh I mean look the pawn on
G2 is a shield for your king
but give me a couple more give me one
check one check in the position and
that's it game over right so you do have
to be careful as well all right by the
way I think we do have some moves F3
perhaps we can see uh The Lads right
there never mind we don't have some
moves they were just readjusting their
position right F3 by the way I just saw
in uh
beam's uh game that uh ruang Yen had
just played a move that I thought uh yes
here it was um in my mind's eye we had
this
position and I never saw the move F3
F4 as being something that white wanted
to do then the current position I saw a
white Pawn on an F4 and I
said what you know like okay but they
have completely resorted the pieces uh
there's no uh attack down the
diagonal wow wow
okay Kate yeah I mean white is still
having a big Advantage but I don't know
I would prefer to kind of develop the
Rooks on the queen side try to trade and
trade a pair of Rooks whether it was on
the B8 square or any Square um so now we
are targeting the D4 Pawn sure black
cannot really play C5 because then
there's the bishop hanging so how are
you going to defend it something like
Queen I'm not happy about7 I okay let's
try Queen to D7 Fair
because it's this Knight on A6 that is
uh the the real bother right and I do
want to
desperately uh find an outpost for my
knight but also Knight E5 I'm not happy
here uh Queen D7 is on the board pardon
me Queen D7 is on the board it is okay
so encouraging Knight
E5 I still no beum I think has just too
many pluses in the position the problem
is this Knight on A6 put it on a square
I don't care F6 would be fine but F5
would be great knight on A6 that just
looks like I'm I'm playing we can also
try something like Queen C2 here to
Target the C7 pawn and think about A4
again trapping that Bishop especially if
it
were to encourage a move like C6 yeah um
looks really really good jumping into
the Carissa uh game for a moment because
a lot of Trades took place we saw it
right here Bishop takes
C4 and we were thinking that there's a
double threat right the first threat was
to play G4 uh chasing away this bishop
which is defending the pawn on E6 and
then the second idea was that this Pawn
on C5
we could even play Bishop takes C5
taking advantage of this pin Rook C1 on
the board Knight
G6 Bishop
F1 gift me pawn queen queen G5 Nazi is
trying to create an attack on the king
side because clearly uh the center is
not going for her no not going away G2
G3 keeps the knight at Bay as long as I
can keep this Pawn under uh guard with a
move like Queen E2 this still looks very
very good for Karissa there goes the
pawn and we have caught no I don't
believe that this is anywhere anywhere
close to compensation it looks to me
like Bishop G2 go ahead welcome uh I
don't even know if you have a threat or
not I'll just play I can always play
Bishop E3 to kind of Kick the queen away
worried yeah I've got that one in my
pocket and I'm really not worried about
you're playing H3 as long as I've got
this bishop on the diagonal Karissa wow
flying flying colors these two uh two
horse race is become more and more
dominant two R they keep continuing my
goodness by the way if Karissa and begim
win this round maybe we can see the
standings for just a
second that would mean out of eight
eight out of nine and if Alice and Arena
draw their game they catchable that's it
they're uncatchable Kissa and be is
going to be number one and number two
the only question is which one is going
to be the champ or whether we are going
to see tie break or not yeah and uh the
fight for third uh and once again this
mirror line score It's Not Unusual that
you have two players you
know going into the lead and just going
bang bang bang but the crazy part is the
mirror image yeah they they drew each
other in round four so that makes sense
but drawing round one and then seeing
four in a row and they're just
Unstoppable it's crazy and they can't do
any wrong and that's certainly the case
uh uh going on today in round nine is
they pick up the pace once more back to
the Fabiano game are clocks are factor
are the clocks are factor not yet 22
minutes about 22 minutes for both
players right now with nine moves to go
so not that many moves to go they they
they have plenty of time to think it
through mm I'm looking at some moves
right now and Rook to F2 seems to be a
very good one so we were looking D5 and
E6 right that's natural way of dealing
with this position but Rook to F2 I'm
really liking uh you have to be very
careful now no exactly F takes G2 is a
bad move because now I stop you first
and this is an easy move to uh Miss by
the way Rook to F3 I don't have to play
Queen H5 to defend h no more Queen takes
H3 and then next move after Queen to B4
now I start pushing my pawn and I get to
keep both Center pawns that's a big
difference right I mean now this is
starting to get quite unpleasant I would
say for a black so after Rook to F2 the
best move seems to be Rook takes G2 but
once again and this ises H3 on your
agenda Queen D2 is such a beautiful way
to defend what you take on H3 and now I
go to
G5 Rook to G8 and that's going to allow
Perpetual Queen F6 queen f8 queen to H1
now I go King to F2 and the G1 square is
protected you cannot sacrifice and
promote because the queen is in fact on
G5 so that's the perfect square not easy
to understand that I have to say trading
Rooks on G2 is a little bit
counterintuitive right very much so I
agree very very very much so Rook F2 is
a crucial move Hans needs to see this
one not necessarily to keep the balance
because objectively he's still worse but
from a practical perspective Rook to F2
is going to create some big difficulties
for a Fabiano's
attack uh remarkable just wow um I want
to turn our attention to uh Wesley so he
comes into the event as a previous two
time Champion uh one of the highest
rated players in the field he's he's got
the white pieces against Ray Robson who
at
50% uh will he have an opportunity to
win let's see well guess what Kate uh he
uh Wesley loved your idea of H5 followed
by Knight H4 because he said to himself
well if I can establish my knight on F5
I've got these mating threats Ray says
yes you you do have a very good position
on the king side but check this last
move wow PA C4
and look at this beautiful uh Pawn
breakthrough idea uh Ray obviously
anything that could get those pawns up
the board and after D3 takes C4 that's a
real visual you have really nice
strategic sacrifice because you are
saying I need my night to be active and
I don't mind giving up for that exactly
and suddenly again you I at the risk of
repeating myself like a broken record it
it's about the quality of the pawns
right I mean these are nice pawns but
they're kind of blockaded and this is
the dangerous Pawn so Knight C5 on the
board and the B3 Pawn is attacked right
now so you you probably have to
recapture on A4 or capture on A4 okay
like let me take a long a Tempo I'm I'm
I am going to recapture the pawn I just
thought that hey while I'm here why
don't I try to put my Pawn on B3 so I
can put my pawn my Rook on A2
and and I don't know my I mean I know
White's a pawn up but I would prefer to
play Black if you if your not if your
queen was on G4 you know like we could
be talking a different ball game but you
still got to get your queen over there
and maybe you have to do it right now
right takes takes but that's a problem I
really wanted to be doubled with my
Rooks on a file first do not uh have
such a weakness there and now the pawn
is running
yes exactly so Queen G4 Knight F5 but
this Pawn is fast so we'll keep an eye
on this by the way I'm keeping eye on
another game uh Talia cantes against
atusa bashian we saw how Talia is kind
of running with her pawns throwing
everything on atusa and I believe she
won an exchange right now well when we
left it she had just played this I think
very strong move A3 A4 which preps
Bishop A3 and you know give me another
Pawn there on D6 Square takes takes by
itoua
B6 oh that's a surprise move Bishop E3 I
thought seriously I would have bet
dollars for donuts that the bishop was
going the other way Bishop E3 was and
queen D3 just protecting so a control
game by
Talia and G5 she's she wants to play F6
and you just cannot recapture on F5
because of the exchange well that's the
thing you know often times when I have
like a positional dominating win I just
keep making POS again I think it's I
think I I I mean I had too much t petan
as a kid and T petan would sacrifice his
exchange and I would put my Rook on C6
in a New York second I would leave the
king side completely as it is as long as
I have pawns on F5 and G4 nothing I'll
put the Rook on C6 you'll take it I'll
take with the B Pawn I'll put my queen
on B5 and you can't move uh so even
though maybe the move G5 is good and
maybe it wins material it's like feel
like black is maybe getting some space a
little bit breathing space there
suddenly I have to calculate uh some
some variations Rook takes F5 so Talia
wins an exchange and she's got a really
really good position but it's not the
positional Wipeout that we might have
seen a moment ago the move King h8 well
okay it may not be uh something that's
the most inspired but she does have an
idea touha does Queen G8 Bishop takes E4
and okay let's go uh still a big
Advantage for Talia Jennifer and shria
when we left it we saw this position
where I was saying Bishop
E5 is a usual good
counter chance G4 by Jennifer you'd
almost expect H4 right H4 so that you
could secure I was actually thinking
about Queen G5 maybe even oh but it's
hanging a
night Deep
Thoughts good morning St Louis Tak takes
B7 B6 check this out one thing to play
with Queen G5 but actually being smart
and not blundering good point there you
go well you
channeling uh ashria she wanted her
Queen on G5 she protected her Knight
first first oh excuse me I was about to
say first indications things are going
well for black uh Knight F6 wait a
minute just a second maybe things are
still going well for black Bishop F3
defending the pawn uh your your take on
this one uh Kate so we can take that
Pawn if we want to right I'm not sure if
I need to take it right now by the way
ashita has a lot of time but she took
that pawn immediately well let's let's
see smack smack so cuz Rook E3 I mean
Rook D3 is coming that's what I'm seeing
I'm seeing Rook
D3 a rook up and over or Rook down to D3
and Rook over to H3
so
um so do I play Queen G3 Queen F4 I
really got to address uh the what's
going on on the king side uh I think
Queen G yeah one of those moves just to
try to retreat with that Queen and okay
let's go uh Queen
to uh F4 Queen trade probably black is
fine don't get me wrong but in some ways
I kind of I'm happy about it you know
like as white like I feel like your
queen is much my king is much more
vulnerable than your so a queen trade
maybe I'm satisfied with do you want to
go Queen H5 check I want to try Queen H5
but I do think that after trading black
should be still better because it's
going to be targeting that one on F5 I
agree I agree if you did if if you would
like to uh trade queens and if you would
like to take I I think that black is is
really happy uh she will play Rook to D2
maybe as you say King up over so so uh
this is nice and uh once again I just
want to check in on
beum it's still going well well wait a
minute there's a missing a pawns how did
the a pawns get traded here okay we did
have A4 and the a pawns got traded so
that beam's Rooks are now ready to she's
ready to go rook and any trade of Rooks
and it's just lights out and R Yang has
only three minutes but she has has four
moves to make so that should be a
reasonable time for her it's the
position that's the
problem over to you Christian and how is
lanir doing against Andrew yeah the
position first of all in that one it's
close to hopeless the problem is you
don't look you have a pawn for an
exchange but that's not enough because
your position uh doesn't get any better
right my structure is very very good as
white I don't have any weaknesses and
the problem is you will suffer because
of that weakness on D4 and why am I
calling it a weakness you can cover it
with C5 the problem is once you play C5
that Bishop PA B5 no longer has uh an
outpost and I will be able to Corral
that pawn on C5 and take it off the
board so this one despite the fact of
the material is not that bad for ruang
Yan the position is terrible yes Absolut
really bad all right laner let's see
what's happening in the laner uh game
against Andrew tang and by the way wait
Lenard 22 minutes Andrew six lenier
putting some pressure on the clock on
the clock as well as the position that's
dangerous right A6 a bishop to E7 uh
golden opportunity to just simply pick
up a pawn with Queen to H5 uh Queen to
G4 excuse me he played Queen H5 I'm
trying to understand why he didn't play
this move Bishop takes H6 is a threat in
the position if you do try to run away
first of all you cannot run away on h8
or H7 because you F7 if you go to f F
and I just simply go Queen F5 followed
by Queen to F7 and the problem is you
cannot defend like this because a bishop
takes H6 and that loses a pawn so I'm
not really sure what he missed after
Queen to G4 because again May Bishop D7
Queen G6 is another ex exactly no well
that's the idea that's actually the idea
behind it yes and now this one is under
attack PA on H6 is under attack this one
is pretty much over you have to go
Bishop B6 and that gives me a pawn
bishop takes E6 Queen takes C6 clean
Pawn uh for uh lenier he played Queen H5
still perfect position for lener is very
difficult to get out of this situation
Bishop to F6 and now again at least you
don't have Bishop takes H6 anymore right
so I guess you have to go back but it's
not as easy Queen to G4 was a Mis
opportunity because you do take a pawn
up you've been laboring in this position
trying to get that pawn trying to get
your material advantage
still you have a nice strategical
Advantage but it's not
enough well let me play de well let me
let me uh play four oh well
okay now lanir of course coming in
today's contest in second place trailing
by Fabby by a point saying okay Hans do
your worst and let me do my worst
against the tailender Andrew Tang if I
could win says lanir 5 and a half points
I'm in the
mix oh Arena and um Alice Alice Lee
about to make a repetition as uh they
stopping the clock and pointing to the
move they are going to she's going to
make let me just go over to Arena's
board for just a moment because we
thought that ending that Bishop ending
was pretty Balan right and I see Alice
already signing the score sheet we're
done we're we're out of here and as
neither King can actually uh uh progress
up the board and Alice is you know
keeping the protected pass Pawn under
control uh a draw for sure uh I wanted
to say in that game uh of lanir if you
would bring it up I will advocate for um
linear I want to play Rook E3 I want to
play Rook A1 to E1 and then I would just
want to play Rook G3 and I'm going to
sacrifice yeah that's that's probably
what he will do as well uh let's try to
get more pieces next to my King next to
the dark squares specifically the squore
G5 Rook e one Rook e one and maybe now I
can go Bishop G5 right can you Rook F3
Rook F3 and I'm going to defend of
course I'm not going to take this
because this is over yes uh but I will
defend the F7 Pawn okay and now if I
take
on right you take I take take you can
take a pawn yeah you can take a pawn and
maybe this is the best way to do it
but winning a pawn I thought I was
winning a pawn and and and doing more
damage exactly this Pawn on A6 maybe a
bit soft the pawn on e4 you're tied to
the defense of that one if you don't get
your Bishop back very quickly put it on
D3 to defend everything then you might
get in trouble right so it's not a clean
Pawn that's what I'm trying to say and
this is not something that lener wants
to see in the position because he had
such a dominance in this one and queen
to G4 would have one just a clean Pawn
up by the way after the move Queen to G4
the best move in the position is to give
me the pawn like this this is a
completely different Pawn than the one
that we just saw entering that end game
this is a clean pawn and you still have
ideas of Rook E3 Rook G3 or Rook E3 Rook
F3 the bishop on B3 still perfectly
placed against the pawn on F7 sometimes
not sure what he missed to be honest
well sometimes chess is really just hard
I mean I thought I was cruising there I
won a pawn I took it with Jack you know
we traded on G5 I'm a pawn
up andly it's not that clear but make no
mistake about it uh Andrew has 5 minutes
with a lot of moves still to make 18
moves still to make and a bad position
right so lener still very much in po
position to win this one and by the way
guys we were
discussing Hans had 24 minutes at this
point and we're saying okay time is
probably not going to be a factor
because 24 minutes with only nine moves
to go you're probably going to be able
to do something right Rook F2 was the
move he played E6 but now this allows F
takes
G2 and this is the position that we were
discussing about with the pawn on D5
this is an even worse version Queen to
H5 is what we're expecting you have to
defend to defend H3 you have to do it
but now I go Queen to D3 you go Rook F2
so that whenever I take it's not a check
right but you cannot even take this R f8
and The Rook is pinned hard so if you
have to start making moves well I wanted
to play E7 in so many of these cases and
now Queen F5 I think you guys took my
Pawn on E7 I was crying that was the
problem yes and queen to day they
transposed into my f takes variation F
takes G2 is on the board guys and right
now Hans is down to his last eight
minutes so he spent a lot of time on
that move E6 it was not the correct one
the most resilient defense was Rook to
F2 and right now Fabby is cruising
towards a crucial Victory got that black
magic going with the black Pieces by the
way to try like Queen A1 thinking maybe
I can survive the rook and game well
which Rook n game exactly not but now
check Rook G7 Rook takes oh I cannot
take
Rook what's happening show let's show
might have missed
Kina she might have missed
okay oh that's not
farry doesn't even let me touch the King
The Rook protects yeah that's it yeah oh
boy tough no oh boy I have to say it
right now F Tak G2 is looking well Kate
I mean seriously it's not a joke should
Fabby win this game I think it's a big
one it's a big win I mean then it means
like Wesley is in a forced wind
situation in round 11 to try to stop
Fabby had you know we've been talking
about the ladies because they're just so
incredible but Fab's had a not a quiet
but a considerably good tournament and a
good 2023 by the way very consistent
2023 and very consistent us CH
championship and it was a very similar
story last year as well I feel this year
the road seems to be smoother uh as in
there's not as many contenders behind
him but last year was pretty smooth as
well he was never in a worse position M
last year he scored plus four I believe
he started off very quickly and that was
uh all he had to do yeah in fact and it
seems like it's a very similar story
today and that's what lenier was saying
in the middle of the tournament I mean
this guy keeps winning what do I have to
do I mean it's very difficult to win a
game in this competition but this guy
keeps winning so well the other thing we
is his level of accuracy how many
mistakes like just give me you know like
on a you know two hands how many
mistakes as he's has he made through
nine rounds I don't think you need five
fingers I mean it's amazing his missed
opportunity against shankland that's one
that I could think he was winning and he
made into a draw and then missed
opportunity against Sam but that was
just one move that was we didn't even
spot it right here in the studio uh we
just spot it later uh at dinner um but
then he had a perfect defense with Ray
Robson Queen wait minute Queen is on E5
I have a feeling that's there's some
checkmates coming there Queen H1 is an
options let's take a look at uh what
they have done we just saw the move Rook
C2 to C1 with what five minutes on his
clock for Hans NE seven seven seven so
this makes sense Queen H1 King f and at
least there's no G1 right okay so the
Rooks are defending the first rank right
okay good so immediately check King F2
Queen H4 check you can go back to G1 so
that's not the way we're going to win
this game right so how do we do
it Queen to H4 is is the best move um in
the position Queen H4 Queen to H4 with
the idea that F4 F3 F2 that yes f F4
caveman and if you do go E7 the problem
is I go Rook to
E8 you go D5 I go F4 you go D6 I go F3
and I'm the first one so Queen H1 check
King
F2 You Queen H4 check you don't go back
to G1 because then I gain a Tempo and I
can go you go up the board and this is
safer up the board than to be honest
than being on G1 I'm looking at the
position and it seems pretty good as
well for uh black after this move King
to
G8 wow and well Fabiano having a
signature tournament that he does so
well there you these national
championships brings out his best chess
but we have special guest special guest
arena with you Christian Arena difficult
uh game today with the black pieces
against uh an ALICE Lee that was very
different to the Alice Le that we've
seen in the first part of uh this event
when she was struggling how did you
approach this game and take us through
the critical
moments yeah well um first of all that's
a really fascinating position that you
guys had on the board with Carana uh
Neiman um looks like Fabby has a nice a
nice game there and um well in terms of
my game my game was actually not hard at
all it was the easiest game I've played
in a very long time in this tournament
um
so I didn't have any problems from the
opening um like at all uh opening prep
worked out really well um obviously you
know you would like to play for more um
you know just to keep a glimmer of a
hope alive right but at the same time
okay you're black and I mean she played
well enough not to really give me I
think any chances in this game and
actually I wanted to talk about
something more interesting than this
game which is like uh my amazing friends
you know because it's been a pretty
tough tournament for me okay and um yeah
something a little bit different you
know um yeah it's been a tough
tournament for me especially the series
of draws that I had um just you know one
sort of crushing disappointment after
another actually the third draw with
Jennifer was probably the uh the easiest
to get over because by that point it was
just kind of comical how I was uh
playing um but those first two were
really painful you know and I feel you
know very lucky that I have my group of
friends like people that I do my walks
with here in St Louis people I talk to
on the phone people I talk to by text um
you know you even my kind of my fans and
supporters that write to me on Facebook
I mean just so like everyone has been um
you know doing such an amazing job of
supporting me so I wanted to just kind
of talk about that a little bit because
you get to points in your life you know
you're 39 and I don't I don't remember
having these kinds of friendships like
10 years ago so it's like some of these
friendships have been you know being
built up over a decade or more um you
know some of them are some things that
I've built you know in the last year but
um you know when you have friends like
that you uh feel very very rich you know
very blessed and so that's why even
though this tournament is not uh going
so well for me you know at least not not
in a terms of fighting for first place
but um yeah but overall I feel I feel
very very happy that is very uh well put
Arena thank you very much for that now
you mentioned at the beginning about
this glimmer of hope of course you were
talking about getting first place and it
does seem like right now if one of
either Karissa or beim wins their
respective games there's not going to be
any more hope for the first place what
do you make of this historical race
between these two
ladies yeah definitely interesting how
it shaped out because they were both in
amazing form um it's something that you
don't really see so often it kind of uh
hearkens back to those years when Anna
and I were you know trying to get as
close to the Perfect Score as we could
and we would have those kinds of scores
of like seven out of eight and it would
be a question of you know who would win
first um and then for you know a long
time I really don't remember a situation
like this where people have you know
seven out of eight two points ahead of
everyone else um so it's definitely a
special tourn tournament like that
they're both in really good form and um
yeah I play B tomorrow so it's going to
be exciting absolutely big Clash for you
against beim uh tomorrow any special
strategies any special motivations for
this game because we know you are doing
quite well in general against begim
you've eliminated her twice in the
American Cup so this one is definitely
going to be a very interesting
Clash yeah I mean I feel like I'm in a
decent play like look I've had a hard
time here you know I feel like actually
getting over those disappointments that
was really the toughest because you know
you haven't lost a single game in this
tournament but actually you feel like
you've taken a lot of losses with the
way these games have went um obviously I
could have lost a lot of you know I
could have won a lot of games and it
turns many winning games into losing
games so there was a lot going on um but
you know now where I am I mean I feel
like this game it was actually kind of
nice to have a a quieter day like a day
that's not going on for five and a half
hours and there was like really no
stress here um and you know I got two
two more games and I feel like I at
least you know I I kind of survived
psychologically I'm definitely feeling
like you know like those games did not
break me well that's why you're the
champion that you are with this very
experienced mentality we'll see you
tomorrow Arena yeah Christian I'll just
tell you one last thing one of on one of
my walks with my friends um you know one
of the things he said to me was remember
who you are you know and that was I
think after my second draw maybe against
um a shria that really quite disastrous
game where I was trying to defend a game
where I had been up a pawn you know
remember who you are in the sense like
that you're a fighter yeah you know so
that really um put me back on track and
so yeah thank you to my
friends our congratulations to you uh
arena for all your sex successes say in
these national championships yes
disappointing because two players are
playing out of their mind including beam
and she's putting the finishing touches
on yet another Victory uh just here uh
this ruang Y what she could could she do
she's an exchange down she doesn't even
have her Pawn for it anymore she's in
the spin she walked into this Fork but
the the position was hopeless at this
point Rook takes uh Bishop G4 she could
easily have resigned she didn't really
need to play this move Rook takes you
know again it's a mop up uh operation
now this Rook is ready to I feel like
resignation is now coming because
there's really no play whatsoever you
can't move the Knight even anywhere
right the Rooks all com and even on a
worst day white can just go Rook check
and so it's over we're just expecting uh
nothing but resignation at this point
ban will go to eight out of nine it's
it's a there you have it uh stoppage of
the clock the tournament tpr for beum I
believe is over
2650 more than enough for uh
International Grandmaster Norm for her I
don't know what she needs to do in the
last two rounds to get that grandmas
Norm but well she's done I'm not sure if
she can get a Grand Master you have to
play Grand Master I'm not sure how many
Grand Masters we have in the tournament
I know we have Arena but that's that's
the only Grand Master I think there's a
minimum of three grand Masters you have
to play in a tournament to be able to
get for we know what kind of a result it
is but she hasn't she's not an
international Master yet so this
definitely clinches her last
International Master norm and that's
going to give her the title she's a one
grandmas she's still missing one Norm
for international Master uh title she's
getting it with this performance by the
way one
of one of the great stories in uh
Grandmaster chess was uh Larry
Christensen Larry Christenson never
became an international Master he just
assumed it he just jumped right into the
grandm seat uh Karissa can she keep it
going uh with uh beum beum just won when
we left it she was a pawn up that is to
say she kind of followed your strategy
right yeah just and the bishop was
sitting on H1 more or less this all
looks pretty good Bishop E3 a move you
advocated for as well
uh Rook C1 this all looks good B4 fine
uh Rook C7
fine or is this fine why not you have to
be careful about not getting Che on the
back yeah the one the one thing I'm
looking at and I'm kind of concerned
about is the move Queen to E2 just
around these parts by the way I might
have been more tempted to play the move
Bishop C5 and
you know the more I'm thinking about it
trade the trade the darn Queens off the
board that way my king is going to be
really safe anyway we do have this
current situation and the question that
we have to ask ourselves
is is can't my goodness looking at it
right now Rook takes right how do you
defend right okay so I don't think
you're checkmating me in some clever way
right and The Rook is hanging don't you
have to play Queen D2 that's a m right
well Queen D2 must might be enough
though because the B7 Pawn is going to
be Hing sorry thank you so even after I
trade okay so that I'm a pawn up at the
end of it but I also take the B is
winning so of course but what if you
take on E5 now with the Knight Knight
takes E5 defend makes makes a lot of
sense still got B7 hanging so let's take
on B7 but now wait a do the same thing
Queen E2 Queen E2 scares me right Queen
E2 so I do TR trade The Rook so I can
play Queen D2 right okay all right so
you still have that Knight takes E5 by
the way Knight takes on
E5 maybe sensing a little opportunity is
Nazi getting out of her predicament and
boy what a terrible predicament it was
this was another one of those where the
opening uh can we say opening failure
yes I think we can knight takes E5 on
the board clock's a factor so Karissa
has 9 minutes and N five minutes for how
many moves seven moves okay it's a
complicated position so seven moves is
not easy yeah that pressure uh of the
taking clock there Knight takes E5 and
by the way if you're Karissa right now
you're looking over your shoulder you
just saw that beggy won her game so now
the pressure is on yes to keep keep the
momentum keep head tohe keep that mirror
image of the score line I remember I had
a two horsse race situation it was in
the Tata steel uh championship in
vikon VI uh Walter Brown and I scored 10
and a half out of 13 and it was like
each round like would somebody stop him
we were both saying that to the rest of
the field we tied for first in that
event Knight takes E5 and um I'm looking
for a clean win uh help me out here
uhing that pawn right Bishop takes B7
stay yeah I mean I don't like the bishop
on H1 as a I mean it defends but that
pawn is a nice one and on a good day I
would be starting to look at Rook takes
and queen takes as well so I think our
problem is still Queen E2 right but can
I start maybe with like King G6 wait a
minute but Queen to E2 I also have this
wait no never mind I don't have it I was
thinking about Rook takes
F7 uh after Queen after Queen E2 Queen
E2 Rook takes F7 and then to take on
A6 wow with a queen that's and then my
queen goes to F1 the problem is you have
a bishop to D3 oh but never mind I have
Bishop E4 Bop E4 cross spin okay wait a
minute that's a kind of might work
that's a that's a that's a beautiful
check Cross Pin because Queen takes
E2 and it's like King G7
and and we're fine okay so okay just a
second so what do we have on the board
we have Knight takes
E5 and we're expecting Bishop takes B7
okay so pause for a second
here what does it make any sense Knight
F3 check I don't no no no not not with
the Rooks hanging I like King G6 to be
honest okay let's do it by the way want
to get away from that check if Rook
captures Rook it's perfectly permitted
here on set to be dishonest you don't
have to always be honest uh King G6 okay
um well I mean that's a very reasonable
question that was just asked right so if
I take Knight takes Knight takes Queen
takes Queen takes B4 ah this a per yeah
obviously Queen takes B4 I'm still
looking at that E1 square or B1 exactly
so Bishop to B6 and I'm well it's an
extra Pawn but it's not as clean as it
was a moment for Carissa work to be done
but we have our tournament leader with
you Christian in studio beim welcome uh
to the show today it felt like an easier
Day at the Office uh For You especially
because of this crazy moment that
happened in the first five moves she
actually took on B4 tell us about this
preparation did you know that Bishop
takes B4 is just
losing uh I knew that
because like people don't take on before
and then no takes on nobody
exactly yeah that's like I know Queen A4
Knight E5 I should be winning but after
Rook B8 I had to just sit down and like
understand that after C5 I'm not sure if
it's the strongest move but I didn't see
anything like any defense for her I have
a feeling she thought after Rook B8 if I
take on
C6 uh she's having a like fine position
if I don't then she's going back to
Bishop E7 and I have a feeling she just
missed C5 I had no clue after after
Bishop like before before I had no clue
what was going on C5 is just winning yes
C5 is the key move and the idea being
that you can also drop back with the
Knight to D3 to catch uh the bishop like
that so that's a problem for her
position what did you feel she missed
was it this C5 is that what you
felt C5 I didn't see Rook B8 I didn't
see anything I was like wait they don't
play like this so then I had to figure
out C5 and then after that I'm just
winning absolutely and um there were
some chances along the way did feel like
maybe she was getting some compensation
at this point but you found this idea of
a bishop to A3 and our question is what
if she would have played
A5 and this was something that Yas was
trying to make work as
well yeah I thought that was interesting
move I was uh thinking of Bishop B2 yes
if a before Bishop A3 back right that
was my idea because I'm threatening a A3
myself so I thought uh Pawn on A4 could
be better for me or for her and if she
that was my idea and if she goes it's
still complicated right Rook takes B8 A3
and Knight to B3 how did you assess this
one it seems like this was maybe her
only chance to go into this position
yeah I mean okay I'm I'm piss up I will
figure out
right 92 yeah yeah figure it out well um
after I cannot calculate everything so I
just thought position should be all
right yeah well after that she played
Bishop takes A3 and you never let go of
the decisive Advantage another great
Victory another step towards that
National Championship are you starting
to think about that or you're still
taking it one game at a
time yeah I'm taking one game at a time
it's still two rounds it's
you know it's hard to predict anything
so I'll just try uh to play my games
guys any questions yeah quick question
for you bam first of all our
congratulations really it's uh
phenomenal to come into studio and day
after day to see you and Karissa winning
and matching one another it's absolutely
extraordinary uh Christian is very very
proud of you very proud of your success
and I just wanted to ask you how
grateful are you to your coach Christian
for your outstanding
results well you know if he didn't
invite me to us I wouldn't even have
this result so I'm I'm forever grateful
and he did a great job good point and
for this tournament in
particular oh yeah sir I know where are
you
going just asking the S questions
no it's really it it really is
extraordinary we just had an interview
with Arena where she says two players
are in great form did you come into this
uh tournament feeling that you were
ready to play such a successful event
how how do you do it no I of course I
had no clue I was doing my school and
trying to do as much CH as possible you
know I I work as well so I didn't really
uh put all of me to prepare for this
tournament it's just like uh at some I
didn't start as you can see in my games
like I didn't start well I had some
shaky games so at some point I just
started to score and feel confident
better about my chess I guess uh we'll
see still two runs everything can happen
it's very early to assess all right
thank you bam and uh keep up the good
work we'll see you tomorrow thank you
guys absolutely
and what's happening with Karissa and
Fabby or I haven't looked at Karissa
that much um let's see what was
happening woo okay
so Rook to C7 take take take on C7 King
to G6 trying to hide the way trying to
run what you wanted to do queen to C8
and now a very important move uh King to
F7 wow I want to defend from the checks
because the problem is if I start
looking at check mates myself right
Queen to G8 is a huge problem Bishop G5
M Bishop G5 is a mate right gotcha so
you have to get ready for that that's
why you play the move King to F7 first
and the question is how do you harmonize
your pieces as white right now can you
take on A6 I have a feeling that you
cannot after Knight to F3 Knight F3 and
I was thinking even Bishop well what I
cannot do that I I cannot do that but
what if I just set up for these checks
on D 1 and A1 and then Bishop to a E4 is
also in the books in the absence of your
Bishop on the long diagonal so I think I
have too many threats I'm going to
create enough compensation for and by
the way we do have a move I believe is
Bishop to
H6 okay so she's threat you said how do
you harmonize my she's looking at B8
right but B4 is hanging let's take
that you have to give a chck okay where
do you run you cannot go to G8 you
cannot go to G6 means E8 because Queen
to G7 this is a nice one just check M so
you have to go to E8 correct and I've
got C6 protected so Bishop C6 doesn't do
you have time to take nope if you take
that's a mate ouch so what do you do now
oh oh so why is it just forced to give
another check right on C8 perhaps
there's another check here we take take
and now I I cannot go to d8
or can I go to E7 maybe d8 is Bishop G5
right this is game over we know that but
what about here by the way Queen takes
B4 was played I think after King to E7
I'm
escaping you are forced to give the
Perpetual well for Karissa this is one
she would let Escape right she had a
great position she she really had a
great position out of the opening but
right now seems like Nazi is fighting
herself out of this uh very difficult
situation
um wow I really don't like giving this
uh Knight I don't like any opportunities
to attack the white king coming to F3 no
I don't like this at all I think I would
start to look to bail with Queen C7
check and very quickly time uh trouble a
factor I my king my my clocks have been
Tak away have four minutes both have
four minutes but and two more moves to
make okay not many moves so she can at
least uh re re repeat once then think
for 30 minutes she'll get that 30 minute
bonus on her clock
um but it feels like the the the the
Lion Share the advantage just slipped
away in the last few moves
because uh well I mean think you're just
forced to give a Perpetual otherwise you
get check the these threats and then we
have C8 King
F7 and we we saw very quickly also the
KN on E5 is like solving a lot of issues
for black and our sole leader in the in
the clubhouse is Bon with
eight yeah I mean eight out of nine what
a performance seriously for the ages uh
Arena Crush uh as she said you know the
solist of knowing that she's played a a
decent tournament is just like these two
ladies are just like crazy and uh
understand was happening with them just
running through that tournament so
easily Arena has been on this roller
coaster ride her yes not yesterday's
game but the day before the free day her
game in round eight against Jennifer was
crazy game as uh where just going to
take a break uh here in the um round
nine uh we're just seeing something
phenomenal uh beum is just winning uh is
this her fifth sixth sixth win wow just
simply fantastic we'll see you on the
other side of the break and as we go to
break uh we had uh caught up with some
of the ladies and asked them the
influence that the St Louis chess club
has had on their careers their
answers
the St Louis chess club is celebrating
its 15th year anniversary tell me a
little bit about its impact in the
United States and do you have any
favorite
moments uh yes certainly so St Louis
chess club has become our home for
professional chess players all the
biggest events are held here and um it
certainly is my second home I have a lot
of random memories uh I think one of the
biggest ones was uh finishing US
championships last year and I was
surrounded by a lot of friends and
family and it was just like really
special um really special moment it
definitely has brought the rise of
American chess I remember my first
championship here in
2014 and that's probably one of my most
memorable memories especially my first
game here and I just love coming back to
St Louis and playing so they really did
a great job with American CH I don't
have a lot of experience here but uh I
heard did a lot of good things about St
Louis chess club the impact that uh St
Louis chess club had on like kids
education and I know that a lot of like
Grand Masters come here like every month
and the St Louis chess club has had a
huge impact on chess in the US I
remember when I was playing in the US
Championship prior to when it moved to
the St Louis chess club and um I do
appreciate that the US Championship was
still being held but it wasn't as
prestigious as it is now the price fund
was lower we're playing two rounds a day
so I feel like it has elevated chess uh
to a new level especially women's chess
uh uh I'm very happy to come to St Louis
every year and even a couple times in a
year yes American chess was completely
different I moved to United States in
2002 and there's I cannot even compare
like chess situation in now and back in
those years and main reason why I'm
still playing chess at St Louis because
I'm the old oldest participant already
for many years and it's keep me
motivated and it's
really it's really nice that we have
this opportunity to play us championship
at such a nice place and that we have so
many good tournament I think that the
impact it has is huge on us chess for
people both who are watching the games
um of Chess and the players who are up
and coming um I think the same with
chess clubs provides young players with
a lot of great opportunities and uh I'm
really happy that it's the 15th
anniversary um and I hope that uh the St
Louis J will continue to have these
amazing tournament well U my favorite
memory about it is when I came to 2021
for the US Champs how did CH with me and
then the whole experience is wonderful
St Louis chess club really did a great
job in promoting chess in general in the
US but especially for women's chess you
know I grew up playing in the US
Championship you know my first time I
was like 13 now I'm 21 so um I think
it's done a lot especially for girls
chess because it's been you know
something I've returned to multiple
times every year for like the last 8
years so yeah like I don't know where I
would be in chess or like in general if
it wasn't for a St Lou's chess club the
club has done so much for chess here in
America and it's been such a long time I
don't remember when like I can't
remember a time like before St Louis um
cu you know I remember like growing up
watching all the broadcasts on like
YouTube following along us Champs and
stuff and it was always like the
highlight of my my day back when I was a
kid yeah well the St Louis chess club
has had has had such an amazing impact
on American chess I mean it seems like
it just got better and better every year
gave so many opportunities to players um
and certainly it's like it's a
motivating thing for me as a chess
player like the level the number of high
quality events that we're having here
you know kind of um gives you a chance
to really stay as a professional player
in terms of memories here I mean in a
way they all fade into each other right
cuz you just come here like year after
year numerous times I mean it feels like
home for me um any place that I look at
I'll think oh yeah I remember I was
really sad after this game and I went to
sit in that place in Forest Park you
know so I have memories like that but
I'll tell you something funny like
recently um Tony Rich the director of
the club he he was talking about the
memories that he had and he's like I
remember how at the very beginning I saw
Arena Crush in her cool leather jacket
and I was like yeah why don't I wear
that anymore so I'm back to wearing the
leather
[Music]
jackets yeah um it's amazing what the
club has done for chess in general
because I mean it's already been 15
years and they've done countless uh
national championship ship tournaments
for juniors helping gr schools and
they've just grown the game so much
across the United States I think if I
look at my own career and I look at
American chess in general we're in a
much better place than we were 15 years
ago and so the contributions have been
imense and of course it's all thanks to
Dr junor singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that S luia Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it's sense a
hope that the game of chess will always
stay Al flat by the mere fa of its
existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
[Music]
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest level levels hosting all
levels of the US championships as well
as high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improved relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr Genie Ken sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
[Music]
seducation St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the worldclass
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact impa on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy hello everyone and welcome back
after a very eventful break I mean
tournament just blew up on us uh during
uh this break uh Kate let's start with
the lady standings as one Carissa y
right so we do not have co-leaders
anymore we have a soul leader begging
toir janova won her game eight out of
nine incredible performance leading the
women's section and Karissa right behind
her with seven and a half points as she
took that uh draw and in the uh open
open section we just saw on our break
one lanir Dominguez yeah he won
Incredible game on time we going to take
a look at that and he tied right now
with Fabiano Karana with five and a half
points and let's see what happened
because we were on break and we were
watching on break as Andrew Tang's clock
just kept ticking ticking ticking down
and uh we had left it uh much earlier
than this but essentially in a major
piece ending as it the you know which
Pawn is the most dangerous this Pawn got
to A7 and this very nice move
Queen uh B7 kind of freezing the Rooks
the Rooks can't move and after the move
B King G8 Rook D7 queenc W uh it was
actually just at this moment and again I
think we had the video where we just saw
that he had made this move and as uh it
we were just counting it down it went
like 18 177 n but what's the position
evaluation is it completely lost or well
the crazy part is when he played the
move Queen C3 C2 he did it at the very
end of the time control and it looked
like it went to zero and then the clock
said well
3030 and 3030 like well did he lose on
time didn't he have a because you're
supposed to have one second but so on
your clock so if you have zero seconds
you don't get to have just the
increment well
you well if you don't have more than
3030 than I thought you lost and it was
sort of like there was a moment there
when both players weren't sure
but but the time trouble expert said
dude I think you lost and here let's
take a look at what we're talking about
right here we've just seen this move and
Andrew's clock you can just see on the
left there is 8 seconds right now no
right and he and he's not moving he's
not moving and he keeps ticking ticking
and he's supposed to make his move with
at least 1 second on his clock now 3
seconds only here it comes here it comes
he's about to make his move do it
quickly do it he just forgot about the
time and he moved the clock and moved
the and lanir immediately looked saw the
3030 and said it's like confused what is
happening like wait a minute I think
I've won the game on
time we we do see a zero appeared there
so right they didn't hit move 40 because
that would make sense to maybe get the
increment for 30 minutes and extra 30
seconds but that's zero right there as
he hovers over the clock yes that's it
no lir is confused yeah like why do you
have 30 minutes why do you have 30
minutes because I think he lost lost on
time and the AR Arbiter did of course
confirm now for lanir this is huge I
mean Fabby you know has been having a
nice event but he came into today's
round in second place or at least tied
for second place he did his uh job but
let's go over to the game of uh Fabby
not so fast we'll get to that one in
just a second tell me what you're
looking at I'll tell you the story of
this absolute drama going on in the
Wesley so versus R Robson this was move
40 Queen to C2 Rook to D3 maintains a
slight Edge for black you cannot take on
C5
because that's over right I'm going to
is also hanging by the way as we were
just discussing about this Fabiano has
won his game the most eventful things
happen on our break we have been on
break for two hours and that was a fast
one that was a fast one good job guys I
said let's not go oh my goodness all
right so tell us the drama in this one
so Queen to C2 and Ray makes his move
with two seconds on his clock Queen to
E4 which loses what loses and right now
he is lost because after Queen takes a
B2 the simple Queen takes B2
unfortunately you cannot take this
because B8 and there's going to be a
mate on G8 you can give me the Rook you
can give a check but there's no more
defense right now after Queen to B3 to
defend the G8 Square I go Queen to C8
attacking the knight at the same time
looking at the F5 square and you cannot
go to E6 it's it's a very Knight D3
where's the M Knight to D3 Queen to F5
right Knight to
G6 you cannot go to G8 because of Queen
to C8 so that's and actually maybe we
should show it just in case check check
again and the queen
drops if you go to H7 queen h8 queen and
Knight that's a perfect combination to
be attacking your opponent's G and if
you go here first of all I can just
simply take and take on D3 yeah that's
easy way that's that's enough that's
that that that's enough absolutely so
after Queen takes B2 right now Ray is
waking up to the
realization that after move 40 from a
better position now he is just simply
losing has Queen takes B2 been played
Queen B2 is on the board oh my gosh so
that will mean that
laner and Wesley are tied at 5 and a
half now tell me about the Fabby game
well let's look at the end of it because
we have it on camera right now let's
take a look so oh first of all I'm just
going to bring up uh the game on my
board last
move right
now and for uh Fabby it's been a kind of
black magic that he has over Hans demon
because four games that they've had in a
classical tournament four blacks four
blacks and four
victories uh for Fai right and now the
last move has to be played start looking
at that E6
Pawn because if you captured that that
is the weapon that white has been
banking yeah his only yeah that's it if
you capture that pawn on E6 the game is
over Hans knows it he's looking away he
doesn't want to see the move that fa is
about to play the dagger in the
position Rook
to8 simple chest attack the pawn on E6
there's no defense Hans is not even
looking is not even looking the he knew
it's going to come he knows oh oh oh and
he understands this is over and and
there goes uh the handshake holy smokes
the last 10 minutes the most eventful 10
minutes of the round and we almost
missed the whole thing and tough two
games for hands because he lost both of
the games let's pause our uh
conversation for a moment and go uh to
Studio with Christian because we have a
winner with us lanir first of all
congratulations a very important Victory
to maintain your chances at the national
championship going into the last two as
you were getting ready for this game uh
during the rest day were you thinking
that this is a must-win situation for
you well yeah thank you uh no I mean I I
was thinking that uh it's uh I just have
to play well I mean I wasn't thinking
that I need to win this game uh that I
was forced to win this game or anything
like that I was just taking the more
simple approach um just try to play my
best chess and um yeah if chances uh
come to me then I'll I'll try to take
them uh and that's uh that's what
happened in the game I got quite a nice
position uh from the opening I was very
happy because uh it was risk-free
advantage and and quite hard for black
to defend I think I didn't play precise
did his opening Choice surprised you
because you are known as one of uh the
best theoretical players on the planet
he tried to shy away from all sorts of
known Theory and you were spending some
time in the opening as well were you
surprised by
that yeah definitely I was surprised I
mean he always goes E4 E5 so I prepare
for that and uh yeah the fador I mean
it's a it's a surprise but also I mean
not not not a very unpleasant one
because white gets a white gets a nice
position most of the
time yeah I was thinking but uh but yeah
I was trying to remember something but
then I think what I play this sorry it's
quite decent and white should be
slightly better and and and then yeah I
was able to to keep increasing the
pressure absolutely and tell us when did
you feel like finally you're breaking
through at this point the structure
changed you were getting this attack
going on on the king side was this the
area where you felt like finally your
attack is showing
off yeah after B5 and this dc6 queen C6
I felt that I had a huge Advantage
because even I can play B4 after Queen
takes C6 just to deny the C5 Square um
um from his Knight and the I can't go to
B6 either because my pawns are
restricting the KN quite well but I
thought that I can even uh yeah maybe
this is better um and then Knight G4
eventually should be uh big Advantage
but I thought that I can allow him to
play B4 and and it's good anyway but I
um I thought that after Knight H2 B4 uh
I can go uh I mean Knight H2 Bishop B7
Knight G4 B4 I thought I can go Knight
D5 and yeah like in the game yes uh but
then I but then takes on D5 Bishop takes
Queen C7 I didn't find I mean initially
I thought that here some Knight H6 is
something will will work for me but uh
but I
didn't uh I wasn't able to make it work
maybe it doesn't uh so I went for more
positional approach and uh it was anyway
I think quite a quite a nice advantage
it was a very difficult uh position for
him he was also getting very much down
on time I want you to take a look at
those last final uh seconds and tell us
your perspective let's play
it at this point were you starting to
look at the clock were you aware of the
fact that he's down two seconds I wasn't
aware at all I was surprised when I
looked at the clock and I saw 30 minutes
on his clock I thought uh yeah maybe we
made the time control but then yeah I so
but I wasn't aware when when he was
about to make the move I I was trying to
to calculate some lines I mean how to
play after Queen C4 it's what I was
trying to do and and then I realized
that he just lost on time but the final
position is probably lost anyway because
uh yeah after Queen C2 I can simply play
probably Rook F1 or something and and
and it's just lost yep that's that's
correct Rook to F1 defend the f to pawn
there's no promotion the F7 Pawn is in
chambo uh this one is a very important
victory for you lener
congratulations and good luck in the
last couple of rounds thank you our
congratulations to you as well lir as we
have some amazing results in the U open
section uh lanir winning Fabby winning
as well and uh we think
Wesley win position as well an amazing
position in Sam Shanklin abanu Mishra
game something incredible happened oh no
what I mean not another one I mean
another drama I mean look at the white
king it was on the queen side and now it
went all the way back to the king side
oh jeez and and The Rook is look look at
it's very funny actually on
H7 The Rook on H7 but look at what The
Rook on E2 is uh going to do this Rook
on E2 is is is going to be heroic not
really sure if I would call that heroic
I'm he's going to
H2 what is he going what is he doing on
H2 well I mean uh we could imagine that
the queen The Rook I mean aren't we
going to uh sacrifice on funny it's just
funny that's yeah to2 now Rook goes back
to H2 the strange part about this exact
position is if you took a screenshot say
after move 15 there would be a King on
D1 there would be a Pawn on G7 then 10
moves later there'd be a bishop on F6
and then 10 moves later there' be a king
on G2 it looks like black never moved
his pieces he left his Bishop on D7 his
Queen on C7 and really didn't make any
um moves while white trying to find some
sort of a breakthrough yeah exactly and
he just simply not there again Michael
schuba had this great line of one side
was doing
MH the other side was watching and it's
like Sam Shanklin is doing and Misha is
just watching whatever it is that Sam's
doing and we have our tournament leader
with you Christian in studio Fabi a
crucial victory for you once again with
the black pieces we were just discussing
that you've played Hans only with the
black pieces and you actually have a
score of 4 Z yaser aptly called it black
magic do you feel like that give us your
perspective
yeah I yeah I have a very good score
against him but I didn't feel totally
confident be before the game today I I
thought it's still going to be a very
tough game uh it's clear that Hans more
or less had to win the the game to fight
for first place I don't think that a
draw would have given him any chances
and so I I really expected a tough fight
also it's after rest day so he he
definitely could prepare something so I
I was I wasn't um entirely at ease let's
say mhm and the the game of course I
can't say it was a very good game I mean
I feel like uh I mostly benefited
because Hans was not in good shape today
and and he played probably not uh not
very well and uh gave me chances that I
really shouldn't have had give us your
uh critical moments where do you feel
like things are murky and when did you
feel like you're finally taking over the
initiative yeah I think the opening was
very interesting uh I played an idea
which someone played against me so I
didn't really know much about it but I
just remembered that um whoin Beth
played it against me in a rapid game
quite recently this ed4 which is uh
probably was a novelty when he played it
against me I mean black can also play C6
or something this is a very direct path
and yeah after um yeah something like C6
is possible or queen C8 there there's
definitely a variety of moves so I
didn't know much about this ed4 but I
remembered that I didn't really get a
good position after with the white
pieces so I decided to play it and E5
kind of surprised me I I actually
expected this queen F3 D4 Knight
E4 Queen H4 this is the yeah F6 is a bad
move yeah I had a feeling that and here
I thought uh here I thought I could play
Queen D4 I thought I wasn't 100% sure
yes that's why we were expecting Bishop
C more or less yeah here I I guess I'm a
tiny bit worse but more or less within
uh
equality yeah E5 I mean why why did I
play this F6 it's already very it's a
very bad move after I played it I
regretted it it was kind of a lazy move
um because I was considering Queen G5
and that that move didn't look super um
promising after Bishop C2 so I kind of
um didn't didn't look any
further sorry I'm just uh oh no worries
take your time yes working with this
this thing Queen to G5 you spotted that
but you weren't very happy with Bishop
to C2 you decided to go F6
and then he blissed out this sequence of
moves take take and Knight to H5 were
you surprised by this did you see it
from afar how did you assess this
position yeah I thought that um I
thought I'm slightly worse but I thought
it's more or less um more or less okay
after F5 I mean because I'm probably
getting C5 by force or I'm getting F4 uh
so of course F4 is very logical that he
played Queen
E7 I I I didn't think that he could play
Rook C because Queen B4 how does he
continue here M Queen D1 Queen D1 B5 can
I play yes B5 okay Rook C6 seems to Rook
C uh yeah I think I actually saw this
move but I thought something was working
here but uh but I guess not yeah then
then Rook C1 of course he K kills my
counterplay um then in in that case A3
was a mistake right uh because after I
get C5 I'm yeah it's not so bad anymore
um Rook C1 I was very happy that he gave
me C4 as well and then he opened up
things on the other side once he started
arranging his pieces to stop your
counterplay via B5 then he opened with
G5 very very aggressive uh way of
handling the position uh are you okay
with uh the
earpiece not not working out too well
today it's okay we'll we'll
manage it's the bane of the commentators
as well I mean Welcome to our world
febby we'll get through you don't
the issue is really not the uh earpiece
it's the glasses it's uh I I think it's
just one of those days you
know yes yes you get luck in one area
and then it doesn't work out in another
area all right let's discuss the last uh
final stretch of this game G5 B3 and
things get very very complicated but
once you play this move Rook to G8 we
start realizing the fact that it is your
attack that's coming first did you
realize the same thing uh over the
board yeah I I already thought that I'm
much better here and I was also uh not
sure if maybe Queen A3 instead of Rook
G8 was um I was deciding between
different options Queen A3 yeah I
thought that maybe Queen F3 here or or
he somehow gets control of the F3 square
and then things uh maybe Rook F1 I I
wasn't sure but then Rook G8 okay really
um really looked very tempting I thought
Rook C3 is kind of forced Rook F I
thought if he plays like C5 Rook G3 I
just just C start crashing through yes
uh and yeah once my Rook is on G3 just
attack is Unstoppable so he has to play
Rook C or I thought he has to play Rook
C3 uh I take on C4 everything it's of
course Very concrete and then I couldn't
decide at this moment after Rook C2
which is again forced to stop the threat
of Rook G2 uh yeah Queen H3 is of course
the first move that I considered is what
I wanted to play and then after Queen H3
Rook F2 I didn't see what I was looking
at is Rook G3 here I thought
uh yeah yeah first Rook G3 was was my
intention I mean Rook G2 I I see is but
and then I saw that suddenly this E6
Rook G8 and queen E2 and I couldn't
believe it and then Rook E3 and queen D2
and I was like what do I do here it's it
looks like I should have have something
but then I realized that it's actually
very double-edged because he plays D5
and okay he spawns things are getting a
little bit dangerous for you I see yeah
and and this Rook takes G2 move I
thought that the The Rook end game was
unclear but I was maybe a little bit um
rushy in my decision because after Queen
to D2 right yeah I I don't know why I it
it was difficult to calculate and uh
yeah and he starts pushing his pawns I
don't know if King G2 or D5 uh maybe D5
first I I just wasn't sure and F3 I also
thought was much better for me and okay
now I I see that of course F3 is a huge
blunder um I wouldn't say a huge blunder
from from my perspec it was also kind of
the practical way out just because
you're exchanging a lot of pieces and
you're getting closer to something more
simplified yeah but it it does Blow The
Wind I mean I once he played once I
played F3 I started to realize that
Queen A1 is very unclear because my
first intention after Queen A1 was to
play Queen D3 and then Queen D1 and yeah
then I realized I probably have to play
a rook end game anyway mhm because I'm
not really escaping with why I was
thinking maybe Queen B3 Queen B3 here is
very interesting uh cuz Queen B 2 I
thought and queen D5 and it's some sort
I couldn't figure out this mess uh E6
yeah E6 Rook G2 Rook G2 F G2 probably
also a draw um so I thought Queen A1
would be a very decent practical chance
and uh I thought other moves were losing
after F3 so uh now I see that Rook F2 is
a draw of course uh what I I thought
after Rook F2 that I I simply take Rook
G2 Rook G2 F G2 I'm not sure if it's a
draw by the way don't worry about this
engine the engine is not that strong
like you have Queen D2 but it's uh it's
stronger than me
Christian probably yes no I I I just
thought this was winning I I didn't see
Queen D2 Queen H3 Queen G5 uh like I
didn't see this that the square is both
defending and and threatening the
Perpetual yeah okay the good news is I
always have a draw like Rook G8 he has
to force a draw but um but to win this
is probably like I probably would play
Rook G8 at this moment I I don't think I
would get get the uh get the courage to
play Queen G4 here uh so yeah but of
course E6 is shocking no matter what he
chooses maybe Rook F2 maybe Queen A1 but
E6 is just resigned I didn't understand
his idea I guess it was just like Panic
or something because this of course I
can probably win this in a variety of
ways because he actually doesn't have
threats here I mean E7 is always met
with Rook E8 so I thought yeah maybe I
have other ways to win maybe Rook E8
maybe some H H pawn move but I guess
what I did was also pretty um clearcut
yeah well an important victory for you
you're eliminating one of the contenders
but you still have a couple of them
behind you lenier is one of them he just
won his game and Wesley seems to be
primed to win his game as well how do
you see the last couple of rounds
playing
out I still think it'll be very tough I
yeah there some players are starting to
get some momentum uh I'm actually
surprised that Wesley is is winning I I
thought his position was pretty
dangerous looking but of course it was
so double-edged that anything could
happen uh but that's that's an important
win for him lenier I did have a feeling
that he he would be a heavy favorite to
win today because um Andrew is a good
player but he doesn't have good openings
and lenier is one of the best prepared
players so it's uh it's very difficult
uh to get a good position against him so
yeah I'm not too surprised that some
people are starting to try to catch up
and also I play Wesley in the last round
with black I play misra who is also
doing very well tomorrow so it's uh yeah
I don't imagine it will be an easy
finish definitely a Tense one to be
followed guys any questions our
congratulations and I actually do have a
question uh Fabby uh I know we had a
rest day yesterday but still it's been
nine rounds already how are your energy
levels going to the last two
rounds uh more or less okay a little bit
a little bit more tired than I I was at
the start of course but uh and it yeah
it is like nine rounds is usually a full
tournament so it's it's quite a long
event but compared to um let's say some
other events it's it's relatively
relatively relaxed schedule let's say
the candidates or uh or the World Cup
these events really are much more
draining so I think everyone's getting a
bit tired but but probably not overly so
and we do we do have two rest days in
this event so also some some time to
rest and um yeah I would say not too
tired at the moment okay that's good
good luck in the rest of your
tournament thank you absolutely as uh we
just had a plethora of results uh let's
take a look at the standings and we'll
start with Fabiano so here we go he won
again so he's leading the tournament
with six and a half points and he's
followed by Lenard Dominguez who also
won and has five and a half points right
now Hans neeman's loss to fa means that
he doesn't move but we're expecting that
Wesley could join lanir with 5 and 1
half points and that last round matchup
between Wesley and Bobby could be for
all the mares and what's happening in
the ladies we know we have a clear
leader at last be to janova won her game
so she's eight out of nine leading the
tournament right now and she's followed
by Kisa who draw today only made a draw
so she's second with 7 and a half
exactly as Nasi held what we thought was
probably a losing position
against uh Carissa and that would have
been remarkable if Carissa had won that
game and uh what is happening in the Sam
shank pardon me the Wesley so Ray Robson
game you were showing as Queen G8
they're following the line that we uh
discussed after Queen takes B2 Rook
takes D6 and Ray is asking okay where's
the mate show me Queen to B8 has to be
played clear I don't see any other
opportunities if you do try to go to G8
via A2 Rook to E6 seems to be stopping
everything
uh that's one of the ways maybe not to
mention Rook to d8 as well to defend G8
Square Rook to d8 as well but Queen B8
looks so tempting threatening mate and
you're threatening The Rook now the only
response is Rook to d8 to stop you don't
have a different way to defending
against uh Queen to G8 Queen to C4 just
drops the rook and unfortunately for you
there's no more Rook on B1 to be at that
exactly so Rook to d8 this is all forc
King to H2 now once again you have
options but only two of them Queen to B3
or queen to A2 you have to protect the
G8 Square so I would assume at least to
my eyes Queen to B3 looks a bit more
active not 100% sure why Queen A2 to my
eyes looks like might win we might win a
pawn why not let's let's do queen to A2
that's favorite you want your Pawn I
understand that I defend against mate
might win a pwn you want your pawns
obviously so now we expect Queen to C8
either Queen to B3 or queen to8 or queen
to C8 is the idea Knight hitting the
Knight but also hitting F5 you cannot
touch the pawn don't touch the pawn no
no I got that part all right so what do
you do now and by the way we do have
some moves I
believe Wesley at least touched his pen
I'm not sure he he sometimes does uh I'm
not sure touch move on the pen No Okay
so he hasn't played the moveie yet okay
so if I go Knight E4 I know I'm losing
the Knight I'm picking up the pawn on F2
but you get checkm on a ah I get checkm
so you don't pick up this Pawn no oh I
don't even have time you're right you're
right that's that's curtains so I can't
play Knight E4 in that position with the
queen on C8 so what do you do okay let's
hide the Knight right yes perfect let's
go to A4 right B3 doesn't work because
you're cutting the action of your queen
that's a mate in one A6 doesn't really
make sense A4 seems to be the most
aggressive let's say stance of the
Knight okay so if you can call Knight on
A4 aggressive
but you just set up active you set up
the mate I'll give you a Chun I'll give
you you have to go to H7 correct g g
because of this this is the easy way out
you probably have Checkmate in a couple
of moves I do as well you do get the
queen queen D7 and it's m yeah that's it
Queen to D7 is also a CH also M yeah so
you have to go to H7
H7 what do you do now well I pick up a
pawn with check let's pick just in case
just in case just in case sure let's
pick it not worse if you go back okay
then I go back now I go to F4 and what's
the big diff and the big
difference I'm waiting for the drum
roll give it some time give it some time
all right let's go back to E7 okay how
do we do it Queen D7 but where's the M
what but wait can we are you in suwang
if you're telling me I'm in zugang I
mean I was afraid I was going to lose if
you move you lose right you lose the
Knight yeah if you go to B2 let's say
you stay connected to your queen now I
give you a check I set up the mate no
the the the the Knight is hanging so you
can go this is the easy way sorry check
check 96 that's
it but Christian isn't it in many lines
if we go back that we just go Knight G6
first and just force the queen to go to
G8 so if you go five moves earlier let's
say when the queen is on here right yeah
let's say here I go just Queen C8 Queen
C8 okay I have to go to G8 and queen C2
Queen C2 okay I give you a check G3 G3
and now I go King G8 maybe King G8 let's
see just out of the discovered check and
there is nothing nothing
wow yeah it's a funny position um you
would expect the game to be finished in
a couple of moves with Checkmate right
but in fact what you have to do is go
towards the next Target forget about the
Checkmate just go towards the G7 square
and that actually wins it
effortlessly um it's not that easy to
find
this I I I didn't put effortlessly in
this game well the thing is you get to
this point and then you find it you
don't even have to calculate everything
from the beginning because Queen to B8
has to be played you're a pawn down you
have to play Queen B8 but it's it's a
crazy situation with the Knight on A4
where you said zuk Swang right you know
you just made a move and then you said
you know like the queen is on A2 it's
got to patrol G8 it's got to keep the
Knight protected and there's just no
moves that was the unexpected thing cuz
I was expecting at that point you were
going to deliver some Knight f8 to E6
and queen
that was the
Deliverance wow and finally uh this uh
Sam Shanklin game Sam is still trying to
break
through the Rook on H7 is well placed
after you know 40 moves The Rook on H2
finally got a buddy yeah I got a buddy
on
H1 but is it too late maybe I can take
you have to take with the G Pawn right
okay I don't think you can take like
this opening up my queen I wouldn't do
that right I have some Queen F4 ideas H4
IDE want positional control absolutely
G5 takes F6 please right and then I take
and you take and then we exchange and
then maybe I even go Rook to h8 can I do
this okay then I trap your knight take
the rook and Bishop F5 Bishop a yeah
Bishop H5 sorry Queen C1 Queen H6 my
agenda the French
is such a disturbing opening well it's
what Lu Luber leovic would say miserable
it's miserable it's a
disturbing it's a
disturbance
miserable oh my and look at the computer
saying z00 and we're thinking it's
miserable apparently I don't have a way
to win this unbelievable oh that's very
very funny that's the French for you
yeah wow and the Kate the remaining
ladies also in the lady section uh a lot
of
and
ataashi
nowal material right now yeah but when
we left it we thought Talia had total
control she's just
nursing three pass pawns she has two
pawns advantage that would please you oh
very much so I I you you you said it uh
but uh Bishops of opposite color though
is there a chance for uh atusa to save
this Talia really wants to go in front
front of her pawns right to kind of hide
the king there well indeed she wants to
nursemate the pawns up the board as best
she
can but atusa SL Square Bishop whenever
it's going to be on e4 or
somewhere yeah that's this work this is
not I mean it's an extra two pawns I
don't don't get me wrong I I like
talia's position but it's not I claim
the game or something like in track
bridge this is not that easy and what
about the other game between Tata and
and
Ani okay whoa whoa whoa time T is having
Pawn but she's down in exchange
right how that happen uh I'm still not
sure I've got this position
so
I'm thinking that you want to play
Bishop C4 and Bishop D3 right so you
want to put your light Square Bishop on
this diagonal so that I could force F4
F5 the problem is I see it is H5 and H4
with the tempo is a counterplay yeah
with the tempo so this suddenly
became very concrete who is on move by
the way is it Anna's yes it's Anna's
turn right now so but actually let's
look at this variation so Bishop uh I
mean H5 yes Bishop C4
Bishop C4 H4 H4
yes that's a check Bishop
D3 wow okay so I took a a pawn I took a
bishop with check yeah and the problem
is if I captured the with King on G3 and
queen captures on
E6 yes takes takes yeah even after F5
there's Rook E3 yes precisely and a
we're looking at H5 and on a plate h a
we're looking at H5 pardon me and Anna
played
A5 okay so just a second A5 was her
choice talk and let's do it again now
those moves that you what is her idea I
think her idea is to run with that pawn
as quickly as possible and then she's
going to just give up Yep
this and then she's what she's going to
go E3 yes and something of this nature
and okay yeah I was sure and then she's
sitting there going
okay Bishop C4 expec A3 she's done it
A3 and you are right on h8 the king is
better because there are no checks right
okay but if I go Bishop
[Music]
H7 then I go Rook e too yeah now I'm
thinking to myself how am I I I want to
be able to give up my dark Square Bishop
on this on this uh against this pawn and
I'll have my Bishop on F7 I'll have an
easy Fortress if I have to give up my
light squared Bishop for your Pawn I
don't think I have an easy Fortress
anymore H that is how peculiar so once
again you just played the and so I have
to okay let me let me tickle your
Rook Bishop here so the difference now I
can even push A2 and Rook
E2 ah that was the that was the
question so oh you want to play this can
I create a fortress with no you go check
ah pity oh wow
yeah I was thinking if I could put my
Bishop on G1 and put my king on H1 and
you you can't play with your king MH
that's a very nice Fortress I was trying
to make a fortress no I can't but let me
just refresh my board and come back to a
Tat's position we have Bishop C4 now
after the move
A4
um do I have to be I think she's looking
fing Bishop to D3 yeah she's probably
looking towards that the problem is
Bishop D3 Rook takes C6 is a problem
right also right we were looking mainly
at Queen takes E6 but Rook takes E6 okay
so I move my queen yeah the question is
where and now I go Queen
F6 oh that's a Tempo against my I can't
find a square for my queen maybe
D7 okay I'll find a square for ah A3
okay okay that's it's a funny Square oh
but then Rook E3 now Rook E3 yes oh
man you guys you're off the Christmas
aist that's it no Christmas cards for
you guys Queen D7 okay so I'm Dreaming
Of course of playing the move F4 F5
you're dreaming of a white Christmas yes
I got that on my wishless as well okay
okay so how this feels good for a white
it feels like it should be right because
as soon might just be over as I get the
chance to play F4 F5 I'm
golden all right but how bad is the end
game after Queen takes C6 we're not sure
is the question right yes we're not sure
we we've actually been investigating
this position with the King on h8 and by
the way it's worth questioning uh Bishop
takes G6 as well what after Queen to
E6 Bishop takes G6 King takes G6 and F5
and the King goes for a walk but I think
the king might actually be safe on F5
like Alice Lee boldly uh bringing the
king up the board to lead her que D3 you
actually go Queen to E4 and say okay my
king is going back now yeah okay so you
might be
safe wouldn't be
shocking okay and this is E3 captures
King h8 and this is where I think that
all I have to do is somehow uh finagle
my
Bishop to get to the E5 Square so let's
say I go here and by the way Anna played
A4 so we may be getting this position
what are we playing for in this position
which get playing for a win oh white is
trying to draw ah white is trying to
draw okay white is trying right well
funnily enough it actually isn't so easy
oh so when we go Rook B3 because well
the last move was A3 right okay so yeah
A3 so you can move your see what I was
trying to do was give up my dark squared
Bishop for the pawn as opposed to the
light Square Bish okay let let me ask a
very funny question please let's say you
get to the position in which you take my
Bishop so the line that you guys were
looking at and you take my dark Square
Bishop as
well and I have a bishop on F7 no that's
a draw but you take my dark sore Bishop
as well yeah I I I'm I'm saying I'm
worried that he that uh that Anna is
going to win the light squared Bishop so
the mo the the thing but even that
position are we sure it's a draw because
I'm not convinced at all if you win the
dark score Bishop I he guys I'm lost I
don't know still win it all right so it
basically comes down to this Anna is
going to win a bishop
right I think that Anna is going to win
the light squared bishop and when she
does win the light squared Bishop for
the pawn for example we'll just put a
move on the board yes here here here
here here so you got to give up your
Bishop the problem as I see it as we
give up our Bishop that's that's that's
the question I'm asking no no I'm
talking about Queen versus Bishop ah yes
queen versus just one
Bishop oh queen versus one Bishop one
Bishop on F7 yes no you can't how do you
get me out of my sh uh zukan okay but
how do you get Queen on E1 oh Queen on
E1 yeah Queen on E1 the pawn on H4 and
that's it yeah
exactly cuz I wanted to get a fortress
with the two Bishops no with the two
Bishops we know it's a for exactly
so here this is the so pardon me so if
we make a move let's say wait a minute
can I can I play Bishop D6 here this
is no wait a minute now I'm really
confusing
myself I'm like no I I'm winning the
light squared Bishop is my
problem and this is this is the problem
I'm having right is that tatv will have
to give up this bishop and then we get
into an ending where there's no the pawn
on G6 is beautiful but there's no way of
saving it The Rook is going to collect
the pawn rook and two versus bishop and
two is a win uh for the Rook of course
so it I think I think uh Anna's winning
this ending so let me
refresh and we'll just go to
tella she should be this is a very
interesting move by the way the bishop d
for but we can go back to Roy robson's
game because I think they're following
the line that we were talking
about yes and there must be some kind of
very very slow reaction from the players
as you suddenly have this
awareness if when you're Ray Robson like
oh my God I'm a pawn up and a queen and
night ending and I'm lost yeah I'm not
worse yeah I'm lost and Wesley is
thinking oh my gosh a moment ago I was
seriously worse now I'm winning you know
and it all happened in that time control
uh scramble at the very end with that
Knight on G6 supported by H5 Pawn that
looks like just wonderful position for
white indeed check Knight G6 King H7 and
we've been taking this Pawn do we need
this Pawn uh I don't think you do no no
I don't think you do actually uh should
and to be honest I'm not sure it's such
a good idea take it because Knight takes
C5 I go King G8 in this moment right not
King h8 because that allows the whole re
whole sequence once again so maybe you
don't need to take that pawn maybe you
should just go Queen D7 the move that we
were making in this position uh sorry um
I'm going to just refresh my Bard now
right now Queen D7 instead of Knight G6
Queen David 7
yes so we're threatening exactly what
Knight
G6 you have to go to H7 Knight f8 or I
even have Queen C8 by the way now Knight
to E6 in what exact moment here after
King H7 I have Queen C8 because you have
to come back with the queen and the
Knight is hanging right yes which means
that Knight on C3 is not well placed oh
boy which means that in this position I
have to go Knight
B2 yes and then again you're you you're
you're doing that whole thing with the
oops excuse me you're doing the whole
thing with with the Knight Knight going
to E6 and targeting the G7 Pawn no more
defense that's a beautiful maneuver it
really really is I mean because from the
current position the focus has always
been on the G8 and G6 squares right and
then suddenly the new focus is the G7
Pawn you go Knight G6
to f8 all with Tempo and Knight E6
that's when we have a PA chain it's
always the weakest link right the base
the base but thinking about it right now
instead of capturing that pawn on E5
right yeah that's that's great it's not
that easy Queen F5
check on the
board King to h8 only
move and this is the queen D7 business
right still feel like Knight G6
capturing that only after maybe
rerouting the Knight that is what's
going to happen but this is such a nice
move too in the sense that you know you
can't you your knight has to go to B2
and only the B2 Square your King has to
go to H7 and only the H7 Square your
King has to go and the problem is the
queen has to stay to defend that G8
Square you cannot try to get any sort of
counter chances against myy right uh
again from the current position you're
yeah you you would love to set up some
checks or whatever but the problem is
you got to protect the G8 mating Square
um my goodness if I'm in Ray shoes I
just feel like Queen D7 wow he found
boss move what a boss move by by Wesley
Queen to D7 and you just got to feel
like the world's against you I mean wow
absolutely brutal Queen and Knight
versus queen and Knight he a pawn up and
dead busted just such a difficult move
not to go for that extra Pawn Knight G6
captur that pawn on E5 just just played
Queen D7 instead and uh just to butress
the whole point if if we do get a
position like this right
where the you you you you you've won the
E5 Pawn with a gain of tempo let's say
the crazy part is you might be doing
black a
favor because he's got the when the pawn
was on E5 you don't get to go Queen V8
check uh and maybe on a good day you get
your knight back into the game and
thankfully your queen is defending G8
and everything so by refusing to capture
the pawn Wesley is actually saying I
don't need the E5 Pawn at all all I need
to do is go Knight G6 check Knight f8
check and Knight E6 take this pawn and
it's made all right let's try to stop it
okay Knight B6 Knight B6 at least I'm
attacking the queen but with Knight B6 I
give check on no I or I start with that
I thought Queen G6 oh that's the easy
Knight G6 and threatening Checkmate and
attacking the Knight you convinced
me you you told me that all I have to do
is attack the Knight and threaten mate
force you to go Queen G8 and I'll pick
up the Knight for free that's why the
Knight can't go to C5 that I pick up the
Knight for free can't go to
B6 if I went to C3 you picked up my
knight same cleverly in the same way so
I ended up going to the B2
square and then after I went to the B2
Square then I got checked King H7
checked and that is a beautiful
redirection I
mean I I would be very proud of uh
finding this idea it's really it's
really nice as you say just attacking
the base of the pawn chain and there's
no defense it reminds me of this game of
Anish giri versus Yan neomi from
Bucharest last round it was something
very similar to this very very similar
and he did not find his maneuver I
believe it was Yan that was playing for
a win he did not find it
so it's not an easy one especially when
you start getting tempted by that pawn
on E5 exactly he found it though seven
minutes got off the board I think he
knows right now that yeah I I got this
in the bag and um the next 10 minutes
are going to be torturous for Ray Robson
because slowly but surely he will come
to the realization that there's nothing
he can
do yeah knight6 Knight f8 Knight A6 is
coming you cannot stop it yeah yeah I
would feel in race shoes like my
goodness it's just a cursed
tournament uh he wow oh boy uh tough
tough tough Sam Shanklin versus the
14-year-old Phenom am Mishra they have
gotten into that position where okay
there was a big trade it all captured on
F6 and Sam has been en pardon me uh yes
Sam has been enjoying the position for
quite some time but we know that the
engines are incredibly resourceful even
when you think the position is
overwhelming and you see their uh Mishra
uh kind of just he's intense he doesn't
see the win he thinks that he's
defending his position win for who what
win for who win for white right yeah
yeah yeah of course but but he doesn't
see it and he's saying Sam doesn't see
it either right he's saying look I mean
I've got my ideas I've got one weakness
in the position the pawn on F7 by the
way if I really want to defend the pawn
on F7 I got lots of ways of doing that
uh the French defense it's I mean that
Bishop the light Square Bishop it's
miserable miserable absolutely bad
Bishops defend good pawns and that's
what it's doing at the moment I'm not so
sure about that no no this is losing in
fact and Mishra it's losing how seems to
be losing after Rook to H7 okay let's
say B7 I believe I want to go Bop
H5 you Rook King A7 just King to A7 yeah
just go ahead and kill me maybe bishop
here first okay go King a yeah or King
A6 let's go King A6 why not just show me
how H5 Rook B7 Rook to B7 and now let's
put the king somewhere safe the question
is where
let's go to F1 there's no more checks at
least after you open with B4 right King
A7 I just want to see how you break I'm
bringing my queen now okay
B4 at some point probably you will have
to do it right let me give it a shot
take take take take Queen A1 now okay
any end game is going to be very bad for
you we know that like que A6 I feel like
any middle game's going to be bad for me
any end game's going to be B thanks for
the word of caution it's the French it's
the French what do you what do you
expect all right so what do you do now
okay let's say you go King B8 all I'll
fall for it I'll go King B8 but no I go
Rook h8 that's terrible this is already
looking bad no but let's not be opening
the queen sight I don't see how he
improves his position if I don't help
him exactly and that's his mistake that
is mishra's mistake what he played the
French and he got overconfident and he
tried to actually be active you are
never active in the French you just have
to stay passive no A5 B5 B4 business
just stay and wait and in fact try to
exchange all the pieces so this was the
critical mistake by the way by the way
won his game Ray was like okay I'm out
of here no we have a tie for second
place as Wesley and lanir are Point
behind our important victory for Wesley
that takes him to plus two and it just
sets up the the final round big match up
in that uh Wesley will have the white
pieces against the tournament leader
sorry at this point we were
discussing how you have to eliminate
everything from the board as black you
have to exchange the rots go Rook h8
allow this bishop H5 it doesn't really
matter you don't have enough after that
you can take and then Knight h8 but
black is fine Knight to C6 he got overly
ambitious I'm telling you that's the
mistake sometimes novice French players
too they get too
aggressive that would be me you know
like I play the French defense to win I
don't like this P pacif okay go on this
is what we have right now and we're
expecting something like Rook AG sa but
again I want to uh butress Kate's point
if okay go ahead play Rook H7 you don't
mind yeah I'll go I don't care King C7
okay you might go Knight to d8 and I
want to defend F7 stop it Bishop d uhoh
f some point I will I will come this way
right maybe not and this allows B4 okay
so I go here well here you know what I
mean I'm not defending F7 in a nice way
by way what about this yeah that's the
problem I that that's now we have to
deal with B4 ideas but it does seem like
this is the plan right like at some
point you will run out of squares yeser
you're too active I don't want to be
doing anything k6 what do you mean I
played Bishop E8 and and Knight d8 you
can't accuse me being active knows come
on Kate you can't accuse me of being
active I put a knight on d8 and a bishop
on EA you cannot be this
active as a French player so definitely
uh yeah very good point
Kina very good don't compliment
her I did the good thing I was being
passive take a look at this uh by the
way wait wait wait a minute 2 minutes
and M only has two minutes on his clock
minutes h s on the board yes you're
expecting King A6 right home well or
King King A8 I I got it I got killed on
the back rank there when I played King
A8 let me just refresh my board and
again we do have some
incredibly huge results in this round
nine in the open section three decisive
games all on the top tables as
tournament leader Fabiano maintains his
tournament lead uh let's take a look at
the current standings after round nine
look so Fabby won his important game and
he's leading with six and half and then
there is a two-way tie for the second
place wesle saww and lener Dominguez
both winning today's game and having
five and a half points exactly and
and in the lady
section and in the women section for the
first time in this tournament we have a
Sol leader beim to janova won her game
today in a style very easily outplayed
her opponent and is eight out of nine
and then Karissa right behind her she
made a draw today and she is seven and a
half points but Karissa slipped because
she had a big big advantage against Nasi
and let it get away from her she
couldn't uh she couldn't uh keep the
pace uh so we still have the two two top
ladies and then there is a tie for the
third place Ina crash and Alis Lee with
five and a half points no chances of
course of no one can catch those girls
exactly uh they're away and and back to
the Mishra game for a moment because
actually can we go back for a second to
Abraham and zatonsk game yes we can
because we were looking how to win for
for Anna or how she's going to keep an
advantage and look what happened no
there's no I know this one no she's
going how did she
Escape well let's take a look see when
we left it we just had left it
here and we saw the move
A5 A4 okay Queen so she did not go for
at Bishop D3 and she sacrificed The
Exchange she was going to go for Bishop
D3 but in that way which is much more uh
decisive so she had to take on E6
because now A3 I believe Bishop to D3
just is very painful would be winning
for white I think so in this so Queen D4
very accurate move and so she took on E6
and Anna a pawn down but after this move
H5 with queen and Knight everything on
one side of the board that looks like
it's going to be a draw let's go back to
the game of Mishra for a moment because
we do have B5 B4 uh dare I say it active
play uh but but now the question is I'm
going to take ab ab so that just kind of
opens up my queen maybe for the near
future Bishop here Bishop to H5 but then
we Rook A8 Rook to
A8 and uh well let me
just slide my queen over maybe but now I
like it pawn takes C3 oh do you have
Knight takes E5
because uh I I thought my king was going
to be really really safe oh I was just
happy to get a
pawn and I understand you uh compl C5
looks very nice too well that's up Pawn
number two but I am crashing here right
and that's very very
important uh
my wow and one player who is definitely
in the hunt Wesley so with you Christian
Wesley anything can happen at the US
chess championships you showed that in
this game it wasn't an easy one it felt
like Ray was in fact trying to push for
some sort of an advantage but then move
40 came and that move Queen to E4 which
spoiled everything for uh Ray did you
understand that at that point you're
finally winning and tell us your story
about today's game yeah for sure but we
want to make it quick yeah so we can
watch Misha
again
but I mean the game was the game was
very interesting I mean of course if you
look at any chess game with an engine
these days then you see like tons of
mistakes like you think oh I played my
best game and then then you make like 10
mistakes but um I I
figured maybe that's the way the chess
is you know you got to take risks I mean
obviously if I wanted to throw it white
I could do it like I've done it a
million times before but uh I guess you
got take risks in order to win like I
was watching some games in the Qatar
Masters the other day and uh like Magnus
Hikaru they
were they were not better like 95% of
the moment during their games but they
somehow managed to win it in the end you
know like give your chances give your
opponent room for mistakes uh I I mean
it's impossible to be better I guess for
the most part all throughout the game
and then win very smoothly but uh yeah
yeah Ray just collapsed and blundered
everything during
the during the but I thought I had a
very
interesting position with this Pawn
structure probably white is not better
yes but I was very tempted to push my H
Pawn on H5 and then bring my knight on
H4 I thought I always had enough counter
play but uh I clearly made some mistakes
like moving my queen maybe to C3 it's a
waste of time I don't I don't really
know mhm uh and I I guess like we all
just started blundering here Rook B1
minus three yeah it was this moment Rook
to B4 but again you guys were playing on
only a few minutes on the clock so this
is definitely not easy task so hard
thank you yeah you're so kind yeah I
mean I wasn't it wasn't easy to figure
out what was happening I mean I I I miss
some of his very good moves like B4 and
then C4 Knight C5 that was very strong
so the position was very concrete either
white is doing well or losing and I I
really had no choice at that moment like
I miss all this C4 Knight C5 which is
very strong uh then I couldn't really
figure out what was happening but um
fortunately Ray has always had um time
trouble problems as you can see from his
previous tourament during the
960 uh but uh also here like I've known
Ray for a long time he's always had that
problem uh he he's gotten much better
obviously but I guess it's still there
so he' have a really good position but
then he'd try to calculate it all the
way in the end try to find the perfect
move and so really cost him uh today um
yeah so it was a it was a tough game you
know Ray's a very good very solid player
you know knows the his openings well
he's very difficult to beat uh and uh
and in a good day he's uh he can beat
anybody so well Wesley thank you for
being so complimentary I don't usually
get that from this uh panel right here
next to me so you saying that I'm nice
that makes me feel very good so I'm
going to return the favor that's where
I'm going uh I want to compliment this
final maneuver because it's very easy to
get tempted for about taking the pawn on
E5 right but it's not the way to do it
Knight to G6 Knight to E5 it allows
black some chances but he did find this
idea of Knight to G6 Knight to f8 so
that was very nice Wesley thank you yeah
I mean I I was very happy after the time
control to find myself in a completely
winning position like I was just trying
to make a draw but thank you Christian
you've always been so nice to me uh all
these years well thank the grandest yes
are you
listening very kind yeah I hope the
answer is listening
yeah Christian always been very pleasant
all right we need to get Wesley more in
studio with us all right thank you
Wesley we'll see you in a couple we'll
see you tomorrow actually absolutely see
you tomorrow yeah our congratulations
Wesley indeed as again uh on the top
three boards we've had decisive results
and uh we we we had a a stretch there we
had draws in every game in the open for
two rounds running so this is very very
nice to see the the tournament exploding
and once again Fabiano really playing
very well I mean yeah you could
criticize a move here or there but to
win with the black pieces and G Queen
takes A3 really well it wasn't just G5
it was like C5 C4 then switching to the
king side it was all very very nice
what's going on in the game of uh Mishra
and
Sam
what what crickets crickets uh I'm
trying to understand I was we Kate and I
we were looking at Queen G1 for Sam
Shanker probably the best move and then
we were looking at captures on C3 and
then I wanted to plant my king in the
middle of the board with King E3 she
took on E5 and I went Queen G5 okay and
then we stopped because Wesley was in
studio and we didn't come to a
conclusion yeah it seems like it's it's
some sort of equality but this is
obviously not an equality an easy
equality I thought it was a mess
complete mess I want to push E5 right
with black and I wanted to push with F7
for white who's getting first right
that's that's what we always ask who's
by the way Queen to B1 was played not
Queen to G1 Queen to B1 by the way this
is what we need to be looking at one
minute for Mish right now this is the
important aspect factor of the game and
he captured on B3 check C3 that's a
check you have St with the Knight right
yes King C1 no probably not we don't
want to go I don't think you want to go
there Knight takes C3 Knight Queen takes
B1 and Knight takes D4 shall we look at
that of course which one do you want to
start with Queen takes B1 and maybe we
can look on your board just so that we
can continue seeing uh this uh final
moments not necessarily final moments
but and he has done Knight takes C3 I've
got the wrong position up on my M's
final
minute oops that's the
wrong and here it is yes Knight takes C3
so our last moves were Queen B1 we
weren't in we weren't heading in that
direction but takes and now thanks to
this pin we're going to have to trade
Queens
do we have to trade can we go Knight to
B4 and Bishop takes F7 Queen takes D4 oh
who Knight Knight B4 breaking the pin
threatening Queen takes B4 we can't step
up yeah you can because of Rook A3 right
ah so I E2 yes I like that one you can
definitely play that move but now
back3 but now King E3 now I'm very safe
aren't I cuz now the Knight is spinned
and Bishop takes F7 is coming Rook
A1 invited you to the party and by the
way Queen takes B B1 Knight B4 might
have been tricky but uh Misha was having
none of it he captured in his his time a
factor it is absolutely Mishra is having
one minute now 1 minute 20 seconds while
Sam Shanklin has 11 minutes by the way
we were actually down the very correct
path with that variation Knight B4 was
the correct move was equal this is still
equal by the way this is still equal yes
goodness even after we after we captured
the base Pawn where we think okay I do
understand there's a knight F3 check
Bishop takes F7 is a blunder guys Knight
F3 and Knight
G5 are you kidding me G5 no
not not with the French the French
defense lovers are so gloriously happy
with themselves when they make these
kinds of cheapos not with the French M
I'm not going to hear the end of this
I'm not going to hear the end of Bishop
takes F7 was a massive
blunder M knows holy smokes the players
who were in second place let's them okay
lanir won he was a point behind
like look at him and Hans didn't right
now cuz he Hans lost tabi that was the
only person in second place but you know
it's so easy to capture on F7 and just
calculate recapturing black recaptures I
take but this Knight F3 intermediate
move wow Knight and then you have to see
that Knight G5 is
forking The Rook as well as the bishop
so The Rook doesn't have time to move
Knight takes F7 and if you capture the
bishop whoop There Goes The Rook the
Knight will defend the pawn so you don't
get to go Munch Munch Munch and it's
over it just
wins s wanted to play quickly because
Manu has only one minute ye of little
faith no no worship at The Shrine of the
French and you too may win a Collegiate
Championship one day I've won plenty of
those don't worry about
it oh my goodness oh my goodness but for
I want to say for for for for Sam this
is the cold shower moment this is really
it cuz he just thought you know Knight
Bishop takes F7 what am I you've got to
take I will recapture with the Rook I
will you know one day try to escort my
Pawn up the board and it's a two result
game I mean that was what he was
thinking and guys we've got to set up
what this could mean for tomorrow's
round Mishra is playing Fabby wow that's
going to be a big match oh no kidding
right I mean cuz Misha is in second
place he may unfortunately for him he
plays with black so he's doubling black
yeah he gets the double black that's
going to be a bit difficult well he
passed he's passing this test he's
passing every single test on the flip
side he can play French again oh oh but
look look at Sam he's so disappointed
and uh I mean just as Ry had that
sinking feeling that something has gone
wrong Sam also just like oh
dear but I have to say he's done it
before in this tournament he's played
moves too fast he's played on his
opponent time travel that's what
happened in this one because you uh stop
for a second you see Knight F3 Knight G5
this is a basic tactic can I play a
devil's advocate for a moment after
Knight G5 imagine I sacrificed a rook as
if it was all part of the plan Bishop
takes E6 check Knight takes F7 Bishop
takes E6 check now I presume you want to
play Bishop C6 yes and I just happily
take three
pawns okay do I have to resign shortly
Hereafter h i mean on a good day I get
to play Knight D2 and King F4 you have
to work don't you actually I do because
if I play even something like Rook E8
you just really go forward with your
king yes I do you're threatening both
Rook takes E5 well I thought about yeah
Knight takes F6 cuz I think I can give
up that bishop and kind of trap your
knight let's try it shall we have a look
see so you win the bishop right and
where do I put my probably there is a
good good spot about F7 right now how do
you stop wa how am I stopping you you're
not no I'm not stopping you this is not
good no oh so I I mean okay I'm a des
I'm a Desperado here I I just gave up my
Rook for three
pawns but is it so simple Christian not
that simple but guys what KV is winning
what I know wi that was my reaction as
well when I heard Knight versus queen
and Bishop three versus two yes she is
right what happened there let's take a
look wow what a turnaround that is Anna
must have done something terribly wrong
very wrong okay so first of all this
should be simple but go back go back go
back go back the King was on King was on
H you played H5 King G1
H4 Bishop H2 oh maybe bishop F2 she
didn't want to play that well but why
don't you want to play this you just
take another pair of Pawns of the board
uh by the way none of let's just get the
current position because the current
well the current position is this she's
going to pick up this Pawn okay you
don't play Bishop C3 immediately but you
do play Bishop B4 you do play Bishop A3
one day you attack the Knight and then
you pick up the pawn yeah Bishop A5
Bishop d8 right you just kick the Knight
the Knight can never leave so that's not
going to be difficult wow that's right
oh my gosh so now we can see what she
did wrong but how do you lose this
position
it's how do you slowly and then all at
once that's exactly she maybe Miss King
G5 that's my
guess Bishop A5 she's going towards that
d8 score she miss King G5 I don't know
this is boy is absolutely heartbreaking
for Anna
Anna wow I think her only defense right
at least try for a defense is Knight D5
right okay try to go uh H Knight F4
right and to be honest I think that's
but I have a good Bishop right so I can
capture on H5 yes well just you oh you
want to trap the Knight I want to trap
the Knight I think that's
beautiful so Bishop D2 at the end King
G4 Knight takes Bishop
D2 and then King G3 and got the bishop
wow okay I'll you know sometimes you
just got to tip your hat and say wow
nicely done uh no we have that position
that we looking I I think that was my an
what we do are are are you serious they
played
theh so Sam Shanklin gave up The Rook
yes wow and Knight
f8 and this is equal now but equal the
line to make a draw is absolutely wild
perilous how does you have to go E6 you
have to start with
E6 wait a minute you would re you would
stop yourself from playing E6 because
you would get this position in your mind
always yes and now you have to go King
F4 King
F4 and you take a and King
F5 wow and somehow this bishop and this
Rook cannot stop this is a study this is
a study like because now you go Rook E1
okay and I guess you go F7 no is that it
no I take your Knight come on King E6
your Bishop is extremely
bad the curse of the French Bishop this
is absolutely ridiculous and if I move
my Bishop you make a queen right how
about that and now I pick up your
Bishop this is wild okay that's sick but
you cannot you you cannot you're not
even looking in that direction no you
you can't play E6 because you're so
clever you see Knight takes E6 and you
go of course what I'm going to do is I'm
going to play Knight D2 like a human
being no this is a study like situation
my go Knight E6 would you have for for
for a second count
that you could draw after E6 no but I
was looking at that move but after I saw
takes Rook E8 I was like okay that's not
a way to go that's over right you stop
calculating you just stop you're shut
down and by the way now things are easy
actually for for uh Mishra
because he's the KN is stopping the F
Pawn and you can never push the E Pawn
exactly you can't play E6 because of
Knight takes E6 King F4 Rook E8 right or
Rook A5 even yeah and suddenly black
species just have cooperation perfect
cooperation fantastic
amazing
wow E6 Knight takes E6 Bishop takes
E6 crazy yeah absolutely crazy chess is
brutal uh we had a GM and residence here
uh very recently Victor Mel Chi from
Israel and he was showing me his studies
M and oh my gosh he just tortured me I
got a few right but he has and that move
E6 this a stud was a study this is a
study you I mean I will give this to my
students after the tournament wait for
like a month so that people remember
because it's fresh in their minds then I
will show them this position and ask
them how to make it wow what's the best
move uh Mish has been playing on his
increment Kate for some time uh but is
he picked up some time he has 1 minute
20 seconds um and Sam shank GL has six
minutes right now okay and we move
Knight D7 on the
board it's kind of funny that these uh
pawns it just it's just like this Knight
is horrifyingly bad like you need it you
need the night on an active square and
maybe there's chances to fight but I
just don't see it here the most
difficult thing in chess is to actually
spot the critical moments that's kind of
how you realize whether you're in a good
shape or a bad shape when you're in a
good shape you know when those critical
moments you feel when those critical
moments arise if somebody would have
tapped Sam on the shoulder and say okay
stop this is the moment he would
probably find Knight G5 easy oh he would
find E6 right that one was easy that one
was just a simple blunder but this one I
think if you give him 5 minutes he finds
it because he knows he has to have
something right somebody just told him
you have something you have a draw how
do you do it that's the problem with
chess right and playing um practical
games nobody tells you that you don't
know when the critical moments are and
you just play moves such as Knight to D2
you have so many factors that you need
to keep in mind do I play against his
time he only has a minute and 20 seconds
you have all these decisions that you
need uh to take into account and
unfortunately sometimes just simply
doesn't go your way King D4 on the board
and I recall very nicely this uh line of
Michael bod vinck uh as he spoke about
himself as world champion he said he was
first amongst equals he was first
amongst equals and Boris Basi was
asked what made him a world champion
with his equals and he
said my strength over my rivals was I
was better at recognizing the critical
moments yes yes which is very profound
but this is still not uh over right F7
how how is this over by the way this is
the idea you go Knight f8 right and now
I go King C5 he's done it Knight f8 King
C5 take my knight okay I'll do it I'll
do it you convince me I'll take the
Knight and I go E6 how do you stop me
once
again well he's going to play King C5 I
mean
he it's clear to me that Sam's not
backing off from this challenge King no
he went King
E3 the commentator's curse what is this
oh my king
E3 but now Bishop
D5 Bishop D5 doesn't this look close to
over over over because now you're ready
to go King C6 and your once your king
comes close the pawns are really uh that
they just fall yeah and sure Play Bishop
D5 just so King C5 Kate what did you
think about this well is there so if I
go Knight E7 you just go back right King
E4 yes no actually I can't even go King
D6 I'm I go forward I want to show my
aggression um but Rook takes
D2 E6 that's it that's a draw and I'm
closing in on a draw I'm Amazed by this
move King E3 because I was so certain
that Sam was going to go ahead and
support his pawns but now after Bishop
D5 he's got no cheapos left no more
cheapos yeah and the thing with King C5
again black is still winning but black
has to find very good moves very precise
moves so Rook takes the Knight
E6 E6 that's a draw yeah cuz you're
going to have to play Bishop D7 Bishop
D7 has to be that's an ugly move that's
not an easy move to play no no that's a
difficult one maybe he would play it but
it's such a difficult move my go
allowing checks Bishop D5 Knight E4
things are starting to flow for my
pieces now one of the things that is
absolutely absolutely incumbent upon you
when you're losing the position position
you have a lost position is you've got
to make it as difficult as for your
opponent as possible when I see King E3
Bishop D5 I think to myself no my
opponent will see Bishop D5 that's too
easy King C5 will
make make it life more difficult for my
opponent so I'm going to play King C5
I'm really stunned that uh uh Sam part
am allowed
that uh whoa okay so Knight F3 on the
board he's hoping against hope that
he'll be able to somehow get his Pawns
in but I I think black's King is just
too too uh too close
now like just for argument sake I'll
just put a move on the board ky4 yeah go
ahead and kill
me and I'm I'm just dreaming of King D7
King once I get my king in front of the
pawns then my knight can go and I can
start capturing pawns I'll be a happy
camper King C7 King C7 on the board very
practical move that's a good
move get closer to the Pawn King E4 e
you want to keep active and normally
speaking The Rook belongs behind the
pawns Rook F1 on but this is what it's
all about the king just get the king in
get the King get the king there I like
that move R want
yep oh
boy and by the way TF Abraham is
completely winning against Anna zatonski
she's she got that extra pawn and now
she's pushing forward yeah I see that
what a disaster for uh Anna she started
off brilliantly this tournament yes she
was doing great and she was also not
getting into huge time troubles which
she usually does yeah it's her trademark
Mark style right but now in the last few
rounds it seems like a lot of things
have gone downhill for her mhm um one of
them being this game which was
completely equal like she played a great
game equalized boom finish the game go
H4 take the pawn on F4 that's it
right King to G8 and unfortunately for
Anna she can't even Cheapo her opponent
like G6 Knight
H7 right take the Knight it's just bad
Bishop it's just yeah you got the right
Bishop this time there's just no no
Cheapo in the position H6 H coming and
even if we trade Bishop against Knight
this is just very easy to win by the way
Misha played not Rook D1 but Rook C5 he
says The Rook is perfectly fine on the
C5 Square he's going to play King D7
King E7 and there's nothing that Sam
Shanklin can do so that's certainly
winning and uh is that the only well how
did to you do with atusa she's still
playing they're still playing
okay but these are the two very
imbalanced positions right now I have to
say this I'm just going to refresh this
feels like a heartbreak for uh Sam
shankland again he played a great game
he really did massage almost it feels
like Mishra in that French right right
but then it just wasn't enough she
missed he missed that one tactic one
tactic one move that's all it takes
through the game came off
dang check nice
move the King goes to E7 next and yes
precisely the king just simply Walts us
to E7 pawns are firmly blockaded and
then I've got Rook G6 Jack on my agenda
too King G7 on the board yeah King E7
and that's a that's a r Anna's had
enough Anna Reon because we here see
that she has that bishop and a pawn
tatv and she's winning that game exactly
heartbreak now for tatv I mean when when
you think about the Rivalry that she's
had with Anna and Arena over the years I
mean it's a nice Victory it won't mean
that that that she's contending for the
Bal well she's trying to catch up
because she has five points right now so
she's only half a point behind Arena
crush and Alis Lee they're still that
medal this yeah okay third place right
why not finish up in the podium every
single half a point
matters a real Coach every half a point
matters yes it does yes it does and you
know that when you whenever you try to
get a a norm I don't care what kind of
Norm you're trying to get an
international Master Norm fed Master
Norm those half points matter 96 check
by Mishra and there goes the F7 Pawn
King G after King G6 there's Knight d8
yep precisely Knight to d8 check is
there any cheapos okay the one thing
Knight F5 maybe I should play King f8 as
a Prelude what do you think Knight f8
what if I just capture that pawn I don't
know uh so what if I'm
actually
okay here King E8 what chos king E8 no
sorry where's the Cheapo no cheapos I
still don't see it
nope
I'm I'm out of jet fuel yes you're going
to lose your membership to the pawn
Grabbers Club that's true that's true
shame on me what a dream event for this
young man oh this is beyond first time
you play at the US Championship
first and he's in second place with two
rounds to go and he's playing the
tournament leader for first by by far
the strongest event he's ever played in
and this is your result I mean this is a
and Sam says okay I've seen
enough very disappointing game for him
oh very yeah oof oof oof oof I mean two
guys who really need Solace Ray Robson
and uh Sam Shanklin right now
because well what to say they had really
really good positions we have L last
game Talia cantes against atusa bashian
but it looks like Talia lost her two
pawns on the queen side and this should
be an easier much easier position to
defend for
atusa yes for for Talia I mean just two
pawns up and she had pawns on A4 and B5
actually she was three pawns up actually
oh my goodness so she just Oh no you're
right they were they were there was H5
Pawn mhm okay okay so she she got one
well trade the H5 for the A and B pawns
that's not a good that's a good deal for
black I mean great deal actually there
goes the a pawn yeah she just couldn't
see a way to get her King out H it's not
easy it truly is not
easy I mean sometimes you think you'll
never win a game of chess again you know
like like all all of the
uh positions that talas had in this
tournament she might have a perfect
score for I mean she's had so many uh uh
winning positions and if this one ends
in the draws we think it will it'll just
be you know like another Stone lump of
coal can you just uh give checks now
forever like Queen F5 because we know
that Queen F4 if you exchange the Queens
that's it game over um for you also have
to be careful Queen
C2 I guess I can lose that as well yes
yes if you think you couldn't lose it
oops yes but I agree with you uh
Christian Queen F5
check continue King E1 right that's the
only way to try to escape if you go King
G3 or King G2 I keep this is a way of
Escape I'm worried about why is this a
way of Escape oh but you're threatening
Queen Tak G7 Checkmate well that's why
defend ended so King C1 I mean it's the
only way I can try right right so if I
if I take just one moment I'm
disappointed in you y sir that you that
I didn't go check check check and take a
p why didn't you take the pawn I mean
this is unbelievable okay just a second
I have to redeem myself revoke your your
membership card no I'm telling you the
last two rounds it's just
tiredness so you could check me I mean I
think you can check forever
like check check on B3 don't go to
A5 okay now I'll continue giving your
checks Ah that's a nice
one yeah that should be enough for a
draw let me just refresh my board and
get the current position how did she
played Bishop
D5 nice Bishop
D and H4 and a check on G2 is on the
board I mean just plant your Bishop on
e4 and you can say you're never
disturbing uh your E Pawn is not going
anywhere the pawn on E3 is not going
anywhere you can never
disturb and uh as we uh look watch over
the remaining game we have tat in studio
with you Christian t a crucial victory
for you this uh wasn't easy at all and
in fact
it was a complicated situation it felt
like you were on the defensive side as
we were looking and analyzing your game
but in the end it was that end game and
that mistake by Anna that uh turned the
tides in your favor how are you feeling
right
now when when was I on the defensive
side we thought that with that Rook on
E7 and when you played Bishop to C4 we
thought that you were going to go for
Bishop to D3 like right somewhere at
this point
okay not here at this point after Bishop
to
C4 we thought that you will go for this
and we weren't really sure how to assess
it we thought that you were on the
defensive in this one no I thought I can
easily make a Dy if I put a bishop on F7
and I just give up my other Bishop how
can she ever win this and that was the
question that we were trying to find
whether you can actually do that or
not well okay she has to go King h8
right bop C4 yes A3
A3 ah you think I don't have time for
this we couldn't find a way how you
actually gave up the pawn for the light
for the dark scare
Bishop ah but okay Bishop
[Music]
F2 y I'm looking at you you remember how
we got it you were saying that yes yes
yes
Rook okay Rook E4 Bishop F7 now and Rook
a no Rook E2 Bishop D4 how did we get we
had we we we tricked ourselves I can
attack right Bishop D5 yes after uh Rook
to E4 always yeah yeah I just thought I
cannot win this and I thought okay in
the other position at least I can I
don't know what they were analyzing okay
forget about it forget about it yes so
Queen to D4 and this Rook takes C6 you
guys got this position she goes H4 H5 if
she goes H4 this is pretty much over at
this point well I thought I'll go Bishop
H2 and then maybe I can I know I cannot
win this but uh so this I was very upset
because I know I was winning after that
Rook exchange sacrifice and then like I
just things got out of hand at some
point I don't know at which point
think at any point I I don't know where
I just gave it up I didn't see this
night h8 move I don't know if that's the
best move either but I I don't know what
exactly my mistake was I kind of got low
on time I just kind of got confused with
all this pins absolutely but still she
was the one that made the last mistake
and you got the full point now you're
getting closer uh to those Podium
positions how are you feeling going into
the last couple of
routes oh yeah this was a crucial
victory for me for the standings um
obviously I don't think I'm fighting for
first three because I already played um
well okay first two are already taken I
already played Alice so that's
completely out of my hand so I think
realistically I'm probably fighting for
fourth maybe if I get lucky fighting for
third but uh not a lot of Hope for the
podum this year guys any questions for
the top no just our congratulations for
beating a a rival of many many years
Anna and uh well uh two more games we'll
see you
T thank you absolutely as we have one
game remaining is that it yes and we are
expecting to to call that game a draw
very soon absolutely
uh as we see T Talia nursing the extra
pwn she's just made the offer of a queen
trade oh that's that's over yeah that is
an easy easy draw if atusa captures the
pwn maybe captures the queen pardon me
just capture the queen captures the pwn
King on F7 Pawn on G6 and the bishop on
C8 H3
diagonal wherever yeah and that's it
that's it that's game is over you can
also play Queen
G4 stop it stop it stop
it no I mean you're stopping the pawns
anyway with that move there's nothing
white can do after Queen G4 but Queen G4
Queen F2 and the game
s I'm not I'm not claiming white is
better no I understand that but but you
have 30 seconds you down just take on F1
that's the Practical solution certainly
no I I'm w w with both hands I'm
capturing on F1 I'm playing
G6 and I'm putting my Bishop on D5 so
that I could put my king on F7 and then
I call the Arbiter over I say Arbiter
I'm planning
that's it you're you're not getting me
out of here no no I am planning to and
there she goes she goes
atusa goes immediately like a magnet uh
for this drawn position and as we keep
an eye on this remaining game which is
now more certainly a draw we have an
extraordinary Phenom in the studio
14-year-old Mishra with you Christian
Mishra first of all congratulations but
I have to ask you what's wrong with you
why are you playing the
French yeah that's a question I asked
myself a lot yeah this game this game he
he he came up with some good preparation
of course I had no business winning this
game it was just it was a lucky blunder
take us through the he's one of my role
models again it was a very difficult
game right uh you were on the defensive
for the duration of the game you were
very passive and you just had had to
wait and it's always very difficult to
wait right to make those waiting moves
that don't create any additional
weaknesses you managed to do so and then
in the critical moment he wasn't able to
find the right way tell us a bit about
how you approach those type of
situations where you have to make those
difficult
decisions yeah this game was actually
like frankly it was quite depressing in
the middle of the game because the issue
is I think after this move I think like
Bishop F4 in the opening after I made
this decision to go back with Knight E7
I just never made another active move
again because the issue is if I don't if
I don't if I allow him to take on F5
then the issue is he can put the bishop
on H4 I believe and then bring the
Knight to say E3 and then it becomes
quite difficult to defend F5 tell me
again which move you uh 15 go to 15
let's say knight uh Knight E7 Knight
F7 got it we by the way just to
interrupt you for a second this was a
draw as we anticipated let's get back to
it uh move 15 after Bishop to G
four yeah so this Knight F B7 it was
very it because actually it's this whole
position it's kind of this whole kind of
this whole position engine I think it
overides it some engines they give they
give like plus one here yeah it's not
that high but it's against correct play
like what he did against very slow play
it becomes quite unpleasant to play
because the issue is one of the main
plans that black is kind of revolving on
here is that every time white goes say
like G4 or F4 you can you can meet it
with with say either G6 or F6 so
basically you wait for white to come and
try to try to beat you and then you try
to make a draw not sry not try to make a
draw you fight back with but what
happened in the game was that he uh he
he he brought the bishop to H4 Queen to
E3 and after this like every time like I
go g I can never go F6 because H6 is
always hanging right and I had I had to
go G6 in the game to stop F5 but like
now now okay this position is basically
two assault position white can waste
like 15 moves and black can't do
anything
and that's the type of mentality you
need to have as a French player you know
you need to be able to suffer like this
on your own accord it seems like but
then you're rewarded for your
suffering stop it the stop
it all right you play this move B4 and
at this point finally things are getting
a little bit less tense at least it
seems like because you're simplifying
the position on the queen side how did
you see your chances right
now I thought I was still trying to
fight to survive like I thought this
position was compared to before it might
be a bit better but the issue is even
though like visually it looks like I
have some more played now F7 is just
extremely weak and I had to make this
decision like a couple moves ago with
Rook B8 M I really wasn't sure about
this it's it was quite
uh I had basically two ways to try to
hold this position either I Tred to
bring my pieces to the king side and
just hope that I can fight on this
minimal ground or I just try to just
push the pawn throw caution into the wi
Play Bishop B8 start playing B5 B4 and
just start trying to break on the queen
side and I decided that okay suffering
with Rook F eight Queen d8 is I I've had
enough suffering in this game let's
let's do something let's do something a
little bit more active I look I agree
with you I feel your suffering uh but it
was
rewarded no that was our analis what
happened I think these were crazy lines
like
this was the moment Queen B1 I wasn't
sure like maybe I thought Queen B2 was
another interesting candidate move
because with Queen B2 if I go bc3 you
take with the King you don't get you get
a much better version of the same you
like you don't have to give up D4
there's no more Knight B4 also but I
think maybe Queen B2 like B3 some kind
of some kind of an idea I'm
not I'm still not sure what's going on
here like Bishop takes F7 like Rook A2
might be a candidate move Bishop T C8
King A6
like uh but okay realistically like
maybe this this this might not work
actually because Queen B1 and just F7 f8
next but maybe like Rook takes C2 but
King but Rook takes E2 just King E3 but
King E3 Knight takes E5 like can I take
I have some
tricks s and but yeah don't I was
thinking I had some Perpetual here but
yeah still very complicated yeah maybe
it's maybe there's
nothing okay to Queen to
B1 I think like yeah practically like
with with black having one minute on the
clock Queen B1 was kind of a good thing
to see that okay at least now I can get
some pieces off the board M and it's not
like even this position after Bishop 7
like if I even if I don't have Bishop di
of 7 if I sorry if I don't have Knight
F3 even if I go Bishop takes F7 uh Rook
takes F7 King
V6 like it looks bad because he has a
Pawn on F6 but it's not that terrible
like as long as the pawn is not
immediately queening E5 is quite weak
like now Knight F3 check is still a
threat now say Rook E7 I can go King
C5 like originally this is where I was
planning to play I'm like okay I'm not
not dead anymore right but he took on F7
and you did have that move uh Knight to
F3 and you guys got to this
position yeah Bishop takes E6 I felt was
kind of an interesting decision but I
thought he would take on E8 because
Bishop takes E8 Knight takes H7 like say
he plays some move like Bishop F7 or
Bishop G6
well over by the way this is still not
over I just want to take you to this
moment after Knight to f8 and do some
training because I know you you want to
do some training after the games let's
do some training right now what's the
best move for
why I was considering Knight C3 here
actually because Knight C3 as opposed to
Knight D2 maybe okay you don't I don't
have this same Rook Knight D7 King D4
Rook d8 because maybe E6 ever pass
through your mind
E6 uh what if
I ah you just want to play like but
Knight C6 Bishop C6 Rook E8 uh King F4
Rook takes E6 King F5 that's right say
maybe like Rook wow this is a draw yes
it's crazy yeah this is still like like
psychologically it's quite difficult to
recover after you made after the
evaluation changes like this it's but
yeah I I still had a feeling that after
Bic C4 it's not it's very difficult to
win this position I was I was even
contemplating going Rook of eight KN of
six just to make a draw
because this was
not I really wasn't sure like entirely
how to win these Pawns in the most
precise way because if I wait too long
if I play like King C7 King D7 maybe
somewhere he brings Knight to D4 yeah
yeah but you I kind of need to force him
to you did win it you did find the most
precise uh moves and right now you're
setting up uh the scene for an
incredible matchup between yourself and
Fabiano Fabiano one point in the lead
but you yourself Wesley and lenier are
one point behind you have the
opportunity to potentially catch up with
the leader how are you going to approach
tomorrow's
game yeah the French has been doing me
has been doing me good let's let's see
what happens and I think that okay this
this game realistically like this okay
this one was kind of a gift uh Sam uh
Sam shankin is one of my role models I
mean his worth ethic the way the way how
he's like the his his strength in
general is just truly
commendable like this was like I'm
pretty sure you'll see his game tomorrow
he'll come back he'll he'll win he'll
win a a great game tomorrow like the way
how he comes back from Bad results is
another thing I I very much admire about
him well congratulations uh amazing
Victory ABI Manu will'll see you
tomorrow thank you our congratulations
to Misha and do us the honors and tell
us the standings after nine very
eventful rounds of these national
championships we'll start with the open
so in the open open section we have a
soul leader Fabiano Carana winning today
and having set having six and a half
points out of nine but there are three
people one point from him Wesley saw
lener Dominguez and abim Manuel Mishra
and in the lady standings finally
finally we leader
exactly and it's beim to janova with
eight out of nine that is an incredible
performance K sa right uh behind her
with seven and a half and then two
players tying for the third Irena crash
and Alis Le with five and a half points
and uh tomorrow's will'll peek ahead
tell us about the pairings for round 10
so we have asaran playing Pur kashian P
kidza playing cantes and now in P match
zatonski playing yep not having a great
game today Anna zatonski but tomorrow
she'll try to get back then Yan playing
Abraham Crush challenging the leader
that's definitely the match of tomorrow
that is so cool and then you playing Lee
and the pairings for round 10 in the
open section look at that first board
Karana playing Mishra we talked about
that number two definitely the match of
the day as well exactly arunan playing
shankland Jong playing seian tank
playing against SCH Robson playing
Dominguez and niman playing so Wow have
great matches on the bottom boards as
well as we just refresh our memory as to
who chose who that's a good question yes
yes who chose who that's okay I'm doing
quite well all right I'm in good
position I like it my life
just
crashing aapco cliff diver right here
and uh Christian um another great round
eventful round what a round final
thoughts absolutely I mean in the lady
section finally at some point it was
meant to happen there was uh some
separation to be created at some point
and I have to say Karissa was putting so
much pressure today on Nazi but in the
end Nazi proved that she she is the
two-time national champion and she can
defend and this wasn't an easy defense
but I have to say tomorrow Karissa
against a struggling player Anna zansi
and the big clash between toir janova
and Arena Crush toava struggling against
Irena Crush so those two matchups
definitely are going to be quite
intriguing and of course in the open
section Fabby so far cruising huge huge
game today with the black pieces against
Hans Neiman but tomorrow this is not
going to be easy and you can see that a
lot of players are starting to pile up
victories
Wesley so then you have ler now you have
ABI Manu as well you don't want to be
sleeping because there's a lot of hungry
wolves behind you a lot to play still in
the last couple of rounds and we'll be
here to call all the action 14-year-old
Mishra I just can't I mean it's amazing
you're playing for first place Kate you
know it's just incredible like I think
he did not expect it either and just
playing really nice games lovely to call
the action I can't wait for tomorrow
thank you so much everyone for uh
joining us and sharing your day tell
your friends where you're hanging out
and come and join us tomorrow for the
championship rounds around 10 and 11
coming up bye everyone bye for
[Music]
now
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited
Ed